GOOD MORNING EVERYBODY-
WE WILL BEGIN TODAY'S HEARING
THIS IS THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE ON EDUCATION
FINANCE THIS IS A CRITICAL BOTH
OVERSIGHT HEARING OF WHAT'S
HAPPENING WITH COVID NINETEEN IN
OUR PUBLIC SCHOOLS AND EARLY
EDUCATION CHILD CARE SYSTEM AS
WELL AS AN OPPORTUNITY TO TALK
ABOUT THE ISSUES AND HELPED
SHAPE THE BUDGET GOING FORWARD
WHEN WE COME BACK IN AND-
ADDRESS THE MAY REVISE TODAY'S
A TWO PART HEARING- FIRST IS
FOCUSED ON OUR K. TWELVE PUBLIC
EDUCATION SYSTEM OUR OUR PUBLIC
SCHOOLS AND THEN IN THE
AFTERNOON WE'LL HAVE A
DISCUSSION ON OUR- OUR CHILD
CARE SYSTEM AND DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION AND ESSENTIAL
WORKERS. SO THE BIG PICTURE OF
COURSE IS HOW WE DEAL WITH KOBE
NINETEEN AND THAT HAD DE MAKE
WE'RE FACING ACROSS OUR COUNTRY
IN OUR STATE RELATE TO OUR OUR
KIDS AND OUR SCHOOLS AND WHEN
WE HI RECESSED IN MARCH I DON'T
THINK IT WOULD FULLY UNDERSTOOD
THIS YEAR MAGNITUDE OF WHAT WAS
GOING TO HAPPEN OUR COMMUNITY
IS IN A- AND OUR OWN HOME.
RIGHT NOW FAMILIES OF EVER SAY
MILLION. PUBLIC SCHOOL AGE.
KIDS ARE SELDOM IN PLACE AND
**** ON THING THEY NEVER THE I
WOULD HAVE TO WHICH IS ONLINE A-
HAVE THEIR PARENTS BIG SISTER
BROTHER GRANDMA GRANDPA. BECOME
THE TEACHER- MANY KIDS ARE
ISOLATED AND STRESSED IN THEIR
HOMES AND THIS IS SOMETHING WE
NEED TO ADDRESS. AND EQUITABLE
MANNER. BECAUSE NOT ALL
FAMILIES HAVE FRANKLY WHAT MY
FAMILY HAS I KNOW MANY PEOPLE
ON THIS DíAS HAVE SHARED THEIR
EXPERIENCES. OUR GIRLS ARE AT
HOME LUCKY THERE THERE ARE DAYS
FILLED WITH THEIR RESUME CALLS
WITH THEIR FRIENDS AFTER THEIR
CLASS THEIR CLASSROOM CHATS
THEIR ENRICHMENT PROJECTS WITH
THEIR TEACHERS THERE.
KHANACADEMY WITH MATH- P. E.
EVERY NOW AND THEN IF WE CAN
MAKE IT HAPPEN THAT'S NOT
ALWAYS EASY. BUT NOT ALL
FAMILIES AND KIDS ARE ARE SO
LUCKY. SOME FAMILIES DON'T YOU
HAVE ACCESS TO THE TOOLS TO DO
WITH HIS SCHOOL WORK WHETHER
IT'S A COMPUTER. OR INTERNET
ACCESS SO THAT WILL BE A BIG
PART. OF TODAY'S HEARING TO
MAKE SURE THAT OUR CHILDREN.
DON'T LOSE A YEAR OF EDUCATION
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT THE
ACHIEVEMENT GAPTHE OPPORTUNITY
GAP IS REAL AND WE KNOW THAT
THESE ARE OUR KIDS OUR ECONOMIC
FUTURE ON OUR PUBLIC EDUCATION
SYSTEM SO PARAMOUNT TO. WHAT WE
WANT TO FOCUS ON IN CALIFORNIA.
SO THIS PANDEMIC RECESSION HAD
HAS A LOT OF UNANSWERED
QUESTIONS WE WILL HAVE MANY
MORE. QUESTIONS THAN ANSWERS
BUT WE WANT TO GET DIG DOWN
INTO WHAT'S HAPPENING IN OUR
SCHOOLS ACROSS CALIFORNIA. AND
MAKE SURE THAT FAMILIES AND
KIDS HAVE THE TOOLS THEY NEED
TO SUCCEED- WE WILL HAVE A FEW
PANELS TODAY WILL FOCUS FIRST
ON- THE- COVE IN NINETEEN
IMPACTS ON SCHOOL FINANCES
ACCOUNTABILITY AND SAFETY. IT
WILL START WITH OUR FIRST-
PANEL WITH DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. OUR LIVES HAVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE CAN ARE-
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION I WILL
NOTE THAT WE HAVE- SIX OF THE
SEVEN- COMMITTEE MEMBERS HERE
TODAY FROM THE- SIMPLY BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER TO. SOMEONE
OR MEDINA COULD NOT MAKE THE
TRIP UP. BUT IT BUDGET CHAIR
TING WILL BE JOINING IN HIS IN
HIS PLACE- WITH THAT WE WON'T
BE TAKING ACTION TODAY BUT WE
WILL CALL THE ROLL. OF THE CAR.
HERE ROW HERE GALLAGHER THE MON
MEDINA. MURATSUCHI THERE BUT I
THERE. OKAY HAVE YOU WE START
THE PANEL DO WE HAVE A
COMMITTEE THE WOULD LIKE TO ANY
OPENING OR- PROBE ISSUES. YES
MISTER MURATSUCHI THANK YOU
VERY MUCH IT'S A- GOOD TO BE
BACK TO. DO THE PEOPLE'S
BUSINESS I JUST WANTED TO. I
THANK THE CHAIR FOR BEING- I
THINK WE'RE THE FIRST BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEEON THE ASSEMBLY
SIDE TO HOLD THIS SO. THIS
HEARING BECAUSE IT'S- SO
CRITICAL I KNOW FOR ME-
REPRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
SOUTH BAY. MY DISTRICT GOES
FROM- LARGE URBAN DISTRICT LIKE
LOS ANGELES UNIFIED TO THE
SMALLER SUBURBAN SCHOOL
DISTRICTS OF THE SOUTH BAY AND
SO THERE'S BEEN A WIDE RANGE.
EXPERIENCE IN TERMS OF- HOW
WE'RE DEALING WITH THE
REALITIES OF DISTANCE LEARNING
WE SEE STARKLY THE DIGITAL
DIVIDE. THE GAP IN THE ACCESS
WITH THE DEVICES- ACCESS TO THE
INTERNET- IN DIFFERENT PARTS OF
MY DISTRICT WHICH I KNOW IS-
ONE OF THE BIGGEST CHALLENGES
THEY WERE FACING- IN THE K.
THROUGH TWELVE SPACE-
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. SO I LOOK FORWARD
TO ADDRESSING THESE AND MANY
OTHER ISSUES AND THIS- HEARING
TODAY THANK YOU THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LIMA. THANK YOU
I ALSO- AND GLAD THAT WE'RE
CONVENING I KNOW THAT
YESTERDAY'S CONVERSATION- FOR
BUDGET SAID SIX A WAS- FOCUSED
ON REALLY WHAT RECOVERING WITH
THE ECONOMY WAS GOING TO LOOK
LIKE AND ONE OF THE FIRST
THINGS THAT CAME UP FROM ONE OF
OUR PANELISTS WAS THAT.
EDUCATION AND SCHOOLS AND
NEEDED TO BE PART OF THAT THAT
YOU CAN'T THINK OF AN ECONOMIC
RECOVERY WITH OUT THE IDEA THAT
TO SCHOOLS WITH POTENTIALLY
OPEN UP SO I THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT THE NUMBER OF ISSUES
THAT ARE DISTRICTS NO MATTER
WHERE THEY'RE AT COASTAL IN
LAND NOR IT'S SOUTH- IT RURAL
YOU KNOW BEEN THEY ARE SHARING
SO MANY ISSUES AT THIS MOMENT
THAT ARE VERY DIFFICULT FOR
BOTH K. TWELVE AND HIGHER AT-
SO I'M GLAD THAT WE'RE HAVING
THIS CONVERSATION AND I THINK
THAT THIS WILL BE. A VERY VERY
KEY AND IMPORTANT PART OF HOW
WE MOVE FORWARD- IN THE STATE
INCLUDING WE THINK ABOUT. OR
THANK YOU. OKAY NO FURTHER
QUESTIONS LET'S NOW PROCEED
WITH OUR PANEL WE HAVE THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THE LA L.
AND AFFIRMATIVE EDUCATION. GOOD
IT'S GOING FIRST DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE PLEASE PLEASE PROCEED.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND MEMBERS
AND THIS IS JESSICA HOMES IN
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DISCUSS THIS
VERY IMPORTANT TOPIC TODAY I
LOOK FORWARD TO YOU AND
ANSWERING ANY QUESTIONS THAT
YOU MIGHT HAVE ABOUT ARE ON
THIS POINT. I'M GIVEN WHERE WE
ARE WITH ME REVISION TO MAYBE I
CAN'T PROVIDE MENTAL CLARITY ON
BUT I WILL DO MY BEST AS MUCH
INFORMATION AS I. OKAY LA OF.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS AGREE CABRAL WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
I'M IN WE HAD A BRIEF HANDOUT
THAT WE PUT TOGETHER THAT I
BELIEVE- SHOULD BE- DISTRIBUTED
TO YOU THAT I WAS GONNA USE OF
THAT OUR BASIS FOR SOME OF MY
COMMENTS TODAY- FOR A PROPOSED
YOUR WATCHING ON THE LIVE
STREAM OR HAND OUT IS AVAILABLE
ON OUR WEBSITE LA DOT VA DOT G.
O. V. I'M- IN. IOWA HER. TOUCH
ON THREE ISSUES. IS JUST. QUICK
SUMMARY OF SOME OF THE FEEDBACK.
THAT OF A- I'M A RESULT OF THE-
BUYERS OUTBREAK. WHAT ABOUT
AVAILABLE. FOR AND THEN JUST
MAKE SOME. COME ABOUT THE
FISCAL OUTLOOK FOR SCHOOLS MORE
PEOPLE. I'M FIRST ON ON PAGE
ONE THE HEAD OUT IF YOU HAVE WE
HIGHLIGHTS FROM. THE AS AN IS
JUST GIVE YOU A FUND FOR. WHAT
HAPPENED OVER THE LAST MONTH
AND A HALF SINCE WE HAD A OUR-
ME HEARING IN TERMS OF. HOW
THINGS CHANGED FOR SCHOOLS ARE
A- UNDER A NUMBER OF EXACT
ORDERS BY THE- I'M THERE'D BE.
OF ALL THE OF LEGISLATION PASS
BY BLOOD. AND NUMEROUS. GOT AND
DOCUMENTS TO TRY TO SCHOOLS
UNDERSTAND OUT OF. THERE ARE A
IN THIS IS. ON THE- OF WHAT
HAPPENED. THREE KEY THANK YOU
THINGS THAT THAT ARE GOING ON.
FIRST IS AN ATTEMPT TO TRY TO.
SCHOOL FIFTY HARMLESS FROM
SCHOOL CLOSER. I'M THE MOST
NOTABLE THOSE ARE CHANGE WAS A
CHANGE OF STATURE. THAT THE
THAT SCHOOL. I WILL NOT BE
PENALIZED. FOR HAVING A FULL. A
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY DAYS. YEAR
FOR EXAMPLE THAT'S- IDEAL HERE
BEING. WE ARE A- THAT. WILL
HAVE TO MAKE THE DECISIONS. OF
THE- BY. TO OF THE OF PUBLIC.
ISSUES. I'M NOT THE FINAL THING
THAT THE CURRENT IS- BUT
THROUGH A VARIETY OF MEANS IS
TRYING TO SET CLEAR
EXPECTATIONS- FOR SCHOOLS IT-
BUT I DO CLOSE ABOUT WHAT IS
EXPECTED OF THEM. MEN ARE ALL
HIGHLY THREE KEEP IS THE FIRST
IS THAT- WATER SCHOOLS ARE
CLOSED THERE ARE. EDUCATION OFF
THE OLD SCHOOL THE TO PROVIDE
EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES
THROUGH DISTANCE LEARNING. I'M
YOU HAVE A SUBSCRIBER PANEL NOT
WILL TALK ABOUT THAT IN DETAIL
SCHOOLS ABOUT THE PIVOT FAIRLY
QUICKLY. MOVED TO DISTANCE
LEARNING ABOUT AT A NUMBER OF
IMPLEMENTATION CHALLENGES AS
YOU CAN IMAGINE. THE NEXT
EXPECTATION IF THAT SCHOOLS
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE MEALS WITH
STUDENTS- AND THAT'S SOMETHING
THEN ARE. PROVIDED IN PART
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF FEDERAL
FLEXIBILITY IN THE PHONE
TREATMENT PROGRAM. THAT ALLOWS-
SCHOOLS TO BE MORE FLEXIBLE IN
THE WAY THAT THE DELIVERABLES
MEALS FROM. AND FINALLY THERE'S
AN EXPECTATION THAT SCHOOLS
CONTINUE TO PAY DOWN PLEASE.
I'M ON ON THE NEXT PAGE WE HAVE
SOME BASIC INFORMATION ON SOME
OF THE KEY FUNDING SOURCES IN.
THE FEDERAL CARRIES OUT THE
WITH THE REFERRAL PIECE OF
LEGISLATION THE FEDERAL LEVEL
THAT IT PROVIDED FUNDING- I'M
THE ONE THAT HAS THE EDUCATION
FUNDING IS THE CARE THAT. I'M
THERE ARE THREE PRIMARY POTS
THAT I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT HERE
THE TOTAL TWO POINT THREE
BILLION DOLLARS. THE FIRST PART
OF MONEY WHICH IS- THAT
ELEMENTARY AND SECONDARY
FUNDING IS THE LARGEST SOURCE
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT PRIMARILY
WILL GO DIRECTLY. TO SCHOOLS
AND OUR SCHOOLS HAVE PRETTY
BROAD- THERE ARE SOME BROUGHT
ACTIVITIES THAT CAN BE USED
ATTORNEY COULD BE USED FOR- UP
210% OF THE SPENDING CAN BE
KEPT AT THE STATE LEVEL PARTS
THEY DECISION. ONE IN THE NEXT
TO POP FUNDING IS THE
GOVERNOR'S. EMERGENCY OUR
EDUCATION RELIEF THAT'S K.
TWELVE OR HIGHER EDUCATION BUT
ARE ELIGIBLE- USES OF FUNDING.
AND TV BGS CHALKER AND-
CHOCOLATE PRESCHOOL PROGRAMS
ARE KIND OF ON A PROGRAMS. OF
THOSE FUNDS WILL GO TO THE
STATE AND THE STATE WILL
ULTIMATELY DECIDE HOW TO
ALLOCATE. ARE NONE MOVING ON TO
THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET
OUTLOOK- THINKING ABOUT WHAT
LOOKSLIKE FOR SCHOOLS I MEAN.
AS YOU CAN SEE FROM A PREVIOUS
FIVE THERE ARE SOME FEDERAL
FUNDING AVAILABLE. WE DO THINK
BASED ON OVERSEEING A RECORD ON
THE ECONOMY THAT IS PROBABLY
NOT GOING TO BE MUCH LESS THAN
THE POTENTIAL- BUDGET AFFECTS-
THE GOVERNOR OF THE RECESSION-
IN AS A RESULT OF THE- VIRUS WE
DO. IF I HAVE ANY NUMBER THING
OUT- UNEMPLOYMENT AND OTHER
ECONOMIC FACTORS WE DO THINK WE
ARE IN A STEP RECESSION AND
THAT LIKELY MEANS A REDUCTION
IN STATE FUNDING. AND ARE
LIKELY REDUCTION IN OUR FUNDING
FOR SCHOOLS. I'M SCHOOLS
INSTALL SCHOOL DISTRICT
THEMSELVES TO HAVE- SOME
RESERVES AVAILABLE THE SERVICE
THAT DOES I CAN HELP CUSHION-
SOME OF THE EFFECTIVE
REDUCTIONS- BUT THAT IS
PROBABLY NOT ENOUGH TO WEATHER
A SIGNIFICANT DOWNTURN. AND I
CAN JUST GIVE YOU SOME NUMBERS
TO GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE SO IT IN.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
AT THE END OF THAT YEAR. SCHOOL
DISTRICTS HAVE ALMOST THIRTY
BILLION DOLLARS IN UNDER.
RESERVES AVAILABLE. NOW NOW ALL
THAT FUNDING ISN'T ALWAYS
AVAILABLE- FROM THAT IS AROUND
BECAUSE DISTRICTS MY HAVE CASH
FLOW NEEDS. OR THEY MIGHT HAVE
ALREADY OCCURRED IN SOME
CONTRACTS FOR SOME EXPENSIVE
TECHNOLOGY PRINCES OR SOMETHING
LIKE THAT SO. NOT ALL THERE IS
ALWAYS A FAIRLY AGREEABLE BUT
THAT DOES GIVE YOU SOME
QUESTION. AND IT'S A LITTLE BIT
MORE THAN DISTRICTS HAD PRIOR
TO. THE GREAT RECESSION- AND WE
STILL DON'T KNOW EXACTLY WHAT
THE FISCAL EFFECTS MIGHT BE OF
THIS RECESSION BUT JUST TO GIVE
YOU AN EXAMPLE OF WHAT HAPPENED
IN EIGHT NINE. IN TWO THOUSAND
AND NINE THE STATE PASSED THE
BUDGET. IN SEPTEMBER OF TWO
THOUSAND MADE THAT HAD FIFTY
EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS FOR
PROPOSITION EIGHT FOR SCHOOLS
AND COMMUNITY COLLEGES. ARE THE
END OF THAT YEAR- THERE WERE
MULTIPLE REVISIONS TO THAT
BUDGET AND THE STATE ULTIMATELY
PROVIDED FORTY NINE BILLION
DOLLARS I WAS A NINE BILLION
DOLLAR CUT. WITHIN THAT YEAR-
IF SOMETHING LIKE THAT WERE TO
OCCUR IN THIS SITUATION AND
DISTRICTS WERE TO ATTEMPT TO.
OR USE THE RESERVES TO QUESTION
THOSE REDUCTIONS. IT WHERE IT
WENT OUR- REDUCE MOST OF THE
FUNDING OF THE CURRENTLY
AVAILABLE- SO THEY ARE THERE TO
HELP IN SOME CASES BUT THERE
THERE IS. BILL NOT ENOUGH TO
SURF COMPLETELY QUESTIONER OR
KEEP OUR DISTRICTS ARE. NOT
HAVING TO CONSIDER MAKING
BUDGET REDUCTIONS. THERE ARE A
VARIETY OF WAYS THE STATE. CAN
MAKE REDUCTION SOME OF THEM ARE
THE STREET. OUR CUSTOMER CUTS.
ARE GONNA CUTS THE PROGRAMS-
BUT THERE'S ALSO THINGS LIKE
AND PAYMENT DEFERRALS ANOTHER
OPTIONS JUST DID IN THE PAST
THAT- HAVE THEIR OWN SET OF
SOME OF THE- THESE BUDGET
REDUCTIONS MISTER LEE AFFECT
REDUCTIONS IN THE CLASSROOM.
AND I'M HAPPY TO TALK ABOUT
THESE A LOT MORE DETAILING. IN
CULINARY. I'M THIRTY COUPLE
MORE THAN GOOD FOR THE
HIGHLIGHT. OR ONE OR I WANT TO
IS THE ISSUE OF THE UNCERTAINTY.
HOUSE OUR FREE IN THINKING
ABOUT WITH CLINIC SCHOOL YEAR.
WITH ANY RARE. THERE'S THE AND
OF GOING ON AND THIS RECESS NOW
COULD RESULT IN HAVING TO MAKE
MORE BUDGET RE VERSIONS OF THEM.
THE IN PREVIOUS SUBCOMMITTEE
YOU MIGHT HAVE. ARE A BUNCH OF
ITS PASSENGER THAT MIGHT NEED
TO BE UPDATED IN SAY AUGUST
WHEN I UPDATED TAX RECEIPTS
BECOME AVAILABLE- THAT AS YOU
CAN IMAGINE CAN BE VERY
DIFFICULT FOR SCHOOL DISTRICTS
TO PLAN- IF YOU SAY COMING TO
MAKE REDUCTIONS. THERE ARE
REDUCTIONS IN AUGUST. SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ARE TYPICALLY
BEGINNING THE SCHOOL YEAR AT
THE END OF AUGUST OR THE
BEGINNING OF SEPTEMBER. AT IS
AND NOT ENOUGH TIME FOR THEM TO
RESPOND AND REACT AND CHANGE
THEIR PLANS. FOR WHAT THEY WERE
GOING TO DO MORE- MOST OF THE
TIME AND SO THAT DOESN'T MEAN
THAT IT CAN BE VERY DIFFICULT
FOR DISTRICTS TO DOUBLES CUTS.
ON AND THAT'S SOMETHING THAT
HAPPENED IN THE PREVIOUS
RECESSION IT HAPPENED IN THE
DOT COM BUST WITH THIS THEY
HAVE TO GO IN IN THE MEDIA
REDUCTION AND THESE ARE. ALWAYS
DIFFICULT OUR CHALLENGES DURING
OUR- OUR DRINKS ARE ECONOMIC
DOWNTURNS. THE ADDITIONAL
UNCERTAINTY. THAT I WILL
HIGHLIGHT HERE THE IS UNIQUE.
IN THIS BUT- AT ISSUE BECAUSE
WE ARE IN THE PANDEMIC. IS JUST
A GREAT RUN. ABOUT WHAT
PROGRAMS EVEN LOOK LIKE WHEN
SCHOOL STARTS. ON AS
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LIMóN MENTIONED
AT IT YESTERDAY IS A SUB SIX
HEARING THERE WASN'T. ARE THE
ISSUE OF SCHOOLS BEING ARE.
CLOSE WAS HIGHLIGHTED AS A AS A
PROBLEM FOR GETTING THE ECONOMY
UP AND RUNNING AND SO. THERE IS
SOME PRESSURE FOR SCHOOLS TO
OPEN- BUT- IF THEY DO OPEN THAT
MIGHT BE DEVELOP VERY
DIFFERENTLY AND SO. AS THE
STATE OF THINKING ABOUT HOW TO
BALANCE ITS BUDGET AND WHETHER
ANYTHING BUT THE REDUCTIONS. ON
THERE ALSO THESE ISSUES OF
THINKING ABOUT WILL. WATER WHAT
DO WE EXPECT SCHOOLS TO LOOK
LIKE AND- THAT MIGHT HAVE. FOR
EXAMPLE CHANGES IN EXPECTATIONS
FOR WHAT.AUTHORIZES LOOK LIKE
IF. FOR EXAMPLE YOU NEED TO
HAVE STUDENTS BE SIXTY APART.
THAT MIGHT CHANGE EXPECTED WHAT
DISTRICTS NEED FOR PERSONNEL.
AND HAVE FISCAL IMPLICATIONS
ALL THOSE THINGS WILL BE. WITH
THE PART OF THE CONVERSATION AS
YOU'RE DELIBERATING ON HOW TO
ON. WHICH INCLUDING THE- SO I
WILL STOP THEIR- BUT I'M HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANSWER ANY. YOU MIGHT.
OKAY WILL COME BACK TO YOU
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION. GOOD
MORNING EVERYONE A LISA
CONSTRAINTS- HERE IN A LITTLE
BIT YOU'RE STEIN FROM THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION WE DON'T HAVE
ANYTHING SPECIFIC TO ADD BUT WE
ARE HERE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU MAY. OKAY
WASN'T PREPARED FOR THAT BRIEF
PRESENTATION BUT THAT'S ALRIGHT
WE WILL GET ON WITH OUR OUR
QUESTIONS FROM. COMMITTEE
MEMBERS I HAVE A FEW BUT
DEVELOPING A FIRST TWO OTHER.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MISTER
O'DONNELL- THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN THANK YOU FOR THE
PRESENTATIONS AND I REALIZE
THAT SOME OF THE QUESTIONS I
MIGHT ASK EVEN THE OTHER
MEMBERS MIGHT ASK IF THEY'RE
JUST UNKNOWNS AT THIS TIME BUT
THEY ARE. JUST QUESTIONS WE
SHOULD START PONDERING- AT THIS
POINT THE EXPERIENCE WHICH IS.
CERTAINLY GOING TO. IMPACT OUR
THINKING FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS
FROM MY PERSPECTIVE. BUT IS IT
A MINUTE AND I DON'T KNOW WHO
THIS QUESTIONS FORCE TO ANYONE
OF YOU CAN JUMP ON IT DO WE
HAVE ANY IDEA OF THE COVERT
RELATED COSTS ON SCHOOL
DISTRICTS IN OTHER WORDS IS A
READ A SURVEY- AT ALL WITH THE
EITHER ALL DISTRICTS ARE NUMBER
DISTRICTS TO IDENTIFY THE
INCREASED COSTS THEY HAVE SEEN
BECAUSE OF. THE COVERT RESPONSE.
I DON'T WOULD BE FINANCER
DEPART OF EDUCATION. SO JUST GO
HOMES DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE-
WE'VE RECEIVED AS SOME. CASE BY
CASE- INFORMATION FROM CERTAIN
DISTRICTS WHO ARE TRACKING THIS
INFORMATION- OUR SENSE IS THAT
NOT ALL DISTRICTS AT THIS POINT
HAVE ONLY BEEN ABLE TO GET
THEIR ARMS AROUND THE COST OF
THEIR INCURRING. IT DOES SEEM
TO BE. BUT ANYHOW REPAIRED
SCHOOL DISTRICTS HAVE BANDS TO-
DO. BUSINESS LEARNING OR
PROVIDING MEALS- IN A IN A
MODIFIED MANNER I'M SO IN
TERMS. WILL STATEWIDE VALUE WE
DON'T HAVE THAT BUT WE ARE
HEARING ON SOME ISOLATED
INDIVIDUAL- ESTIMATIONS OF THE
COST THE INDIVIDUAL. THANK YOU
AND I IMAGINE IN SOME CASES.
THERE MAYBE EVEN SOME SAVINGS
DOES MEAN THAT WHEN WE OVERALL
INCREASE EXPENDITURES BUT THERE
MAY BE SOME SPOTS DISTRICTS ARE
SAVING THAT WOULD BE
INTERESTING TO NOTE AS WELL.
BUT WITH REGARD TO PROVIDING
DISTANCE LEARNING I THIS IS A
CAN TO THE LAST QUESTIONI
DON'T KNOW WE HAVE A SURVEY OF
DISTRICTS OF THE COST. THEY
BORN. TO INCREASE THEIR
DISTANCE LEARNING I KNOW MY OWN
ONE OF MY OWN DISTRICTS. HAD A
BY A NUMBER OF- MOBILE DEVICES.
A COUPLE THOUSAND AS I
UNDERSTAND IT SO. DO WE KNOW-
ON AVERAGE WHAT DISTRICTS. ARE
HAVING TO SPEND TO ALLOW FOR
STUDENTS TO DISTANCE LEARN. OR
THE WAY THAT THEY JUST MIGHT BE
SOME OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION SHOULD THINK ABOUT
SOMETIMES SURVEY TO IDENTIFY
THAT GAP WHERE IS THE DELTA HOW
MANY DEVICES. DID DISTRICTS ON
AVERAGE HAVE AND HOW MANY DID
THEY NEED TO FULFILL THEIR
OBLIGATION IF YOU WILL TO
PROVIDE DISTANCE LEARNING THAT
BE SOMETHING INTERESTING THAT
HAVING SOME SOME DISTRICTS. ARE
YOU HAVEN'T ALREADY HAD A
NUMBER OF MOBILE DEVICES THERE
ARE ALREADY ASSIGNED TO
STUDENTS. A SOME DISTRICTS
DIDN'T HAVE AN ADEQUATE NUMBER
I KNOW SOMEONE OUT PURCHASED AT
SUMMER PROBABLY HAVE. AND I'VE
ARE WAITING FOR THEM TO SHOW
UP. SOME MAY HAVE OTHER PLANS I
DON'T KNOW BUT THAT'S JUST
SOMETHING I THINK WE SHOULD
IDENTIFY BECAUSE I THINK. THE
DISTANCE LEARNING MODEL IS
SOMETHING WE MIGHT HAVE TO
BOUNCE IN AND OUT OF NEXT YEAR.
THROUGHOUT THE THAT THE SCHOOL
YEAR EXPERIENCE. AND QUITE
FRANKLY AS A TEACHER. I MEAN I
THINK THIS IS SOMETHING. THAT
CAN BE INCORPORATED INTO THE
DAILY EXPERIENCE OF STUDENTS
WHERE AN- YEAH THEY GO TO
SCHOOL. IN A PERFECT WORLD TO
GO TO SCHOOL DURING THE DAY BUT
THEY CAN ALSO SOME MORE ACCESS.
ACCESS TO MORE ENHANCED. ONLINE
LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES- WHEN
THEY GET HOME. TO BACK UP.
THEIR IN SCHOOL EDUCATION-
DURING THE DAY BECAUSE I AM A
FIRM BELIEVER THAT STUDENTS DO
NEED TO GO. TO A SCHOOL GO TO
SCHOOL. BUT I THINK CALIFORNIA
ON A LOOK AT A SYSTEM THAT'S
MUCH MORE COMPREHENSIVE THAN WE
HAVE NOW. MUCH MORE FORMALIZED
WITH ESTABLISHED PROTOCOLS
POLICIES ETCETERA- TO PROVIDE-
STUDENTS TO ACCESS- THROUGH
DEVICE AT HOME- LEARNING. AND I
DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT LOOKS
LIKE. I KNOW WE HAVE SOME
SCHOOLS THAT HVE BEEN DOING
AND I NEED TO TAKE A LOOKAT
THAT. I THINK IT. CERTAINLY
VERY SAN RECORD FOR SURE WE I
THINK THE DATA REFLECTS THAT.
BUT THAT'S SMETHING AS A STATE
AND AS A COMMITTEE. WE'RE GOING
TO HAVE TO PONDER AS WE GO INTO
NEXT YEAR- HOW DO WE DO THIS. I
DON'T HAVE ALL THE ANSWERS I'VE
BEEN MAINLY IN IN CLASSROOM
TEACHER. TAKEN SOME DISTANCE
CLASSES MYSELF. BUT I DON'T
KNOW THE PLATFORMS. THAT
ALWAYS THERE. THEIR RADIO
PRIVATE PROVIDERS AT. THAT
PROVIDE THEM NOW THERE'S SCHOOL
OLOGY THEIR SCHOOL UP THERE
SOME OTHERS. TOO I THINK POWER
SCHOOLS OVER IN FOLSOM IN FACT.
THAT'S ONE OF I RECALL
CORRECTLY. BUT WHAT WE NEED TO
DO IS A STATE IS ESTABLISH WHAT
A GOOD PLATFORM LOOKS LIKE WHAT
TOOLS IT SHOULD HAVE SO TEACHER
CAN BUILD A LESSON. AND THEN
PUSH THAT OUT- MAYBE THROUGH
THE DAY BUT ALSO. AFTER THE
SCHOOL DAY ON A ON AN ONGOING
BASIS NOT YOURS DURING TIMES OF
NEED. BUT IT WOULD ALSO PROVIDE
MORSE FOR MORE SEAMLESS
TRANSITION. DURING DURING OUR
TIMES OF A- DURING ARM ARE WHEN
WE HAVE EMERGENCIES BE THEY
FIRES MUDSLIDES OR SOMETHING
VERY UNIQUE. LIKE WE ARE
EXPERIENCING A RIGHT NOW SO
THAT'S SOMETHING I THINK WE ALL
OUGHT TO THINK ABOUT AS A BODY
AND I HOPE THE DEPARTMENTS WILL
CONTEMPLATE AS WELL- WE NEED TO
GET MOVING SO THAT I TURN IT
BACK TO YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK
YOU. ASSEMBLYMEMBER EARLY
AMOUNT THANK YOU AT I EIGHT
THINK THAT THERE'S A NUMBER OF
ISSUES AND CERTAINLY DISTANCE
EARNING IS ABSOLUTELY ONE OF
THEM- THAT YEAH AND I THINK
THAT THE COST OF THE TECHNOLOGY
ITSELF BUT ALSO- THE TECHNOLOGY
THERE'S A COST TO THE
TECHNOLOGY WORKING THE WAY IT
SHOULD- THAT NEEDS TO BE
CONSIDERED I KNOW OUR
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION- HAS FORMED A TASK
FORCE. TO TRY TO DEAL WITH THE
REAL DIGITAL DIVIDE- IN IN OUR
STATE- IN COMMUNITIES ALL
ACROSS SO IDO HOPE AND THAT
THE LEGISLATURE IS UPDATED ON
THAT I HAVE- A COUPLE OTHER
QUESTIONS IN AND I WANT TO ASK.
IN TERMS OF ITS SCHOOL MEALS
AND FUNDING AND AT WHAT AT WHAT
FUNDING RESOURCES ARE DISTRICTS
AT THIS POINT USING- TO PROVIDE
THESE MEALS THERE'S BEEN A LOT
OF A- THAT. DISCUSSION ABOUT-
WHETHER OR NOT DISTRICTS HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO PROVIDE THESE
MEALS- WE ARE GOING INTO A
SUMMER AND- THE SUMMER WAS
ALWAYS A TIME. WHERE SO YOU SAW
SCHOOL DISTRICTS ACROSS THE
STATE WHETHER THEY WERE IN
SCHOOL OR NOT- PROVIDE SOME OF
THESE MEALS- SO I I'M I'M
LOOKING TO SEE WHAT AGAIN THE
FUNDING RESOURCES ARE WHAT'S
BEING DONE. IS THIS A
SUSTAINABLE THROUGH THE SUMMER
I THINK WE ARE- AT A STATE THAT
BENEFITS SO GREATLY FROM- THE
AD THAT'S HERE- BUT AND I'M
PROUD THAT IN CALIFORNIA WE'RE
NOT HEARING SOME OF THE STORIES
WE ARE IN OTHER STATES WHERE WE
SEE THAT OUR ADS ARE- YOU KNOW
COMMUNITY IS WORKING WITH NON
PROFITS AND- WE- WE DON'T SEE
THE WASTE. HAPPENING BUT I ALSO
WANT TO KNOW WHAT WHAT THIS%
MEANS FOR STUDENTS WHO RELIED-
A PRIMARILY ON GETTING FOOD-
FROM THEIR SCHOOL SO IF WE
COULD HAVE HAD SOMEONE COMMENT
ON THAT THAT WOULD BE GRET. I
THINK WE LOST DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE FOR A FEW SECONDS OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION ARE
ALEJO WANT TO TAKE A CRACK AT
THAT. GREAT THANK YOU. THAT
GIRL ACROSS THE LA I THINK I
CAN TALK MORE BROADLY ABOUT
WHAT WE HAVE BEEN HEARING THIS
IS A SIMILAR ISSUE WHERE THE
EXACT- COSTS ARE SOMETHING
SOMEWHAT DIFFICULT TO QUANTIFY
AT THIS POINT OR HOPING THAT
WITH A LITTLE BIT MORE TIME WE
GET SOME. OF THE COMMISSION ON
MEALSREPORTED TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION AND
GIVES US A BETTER SENSE OF
WHAT'S GOING ON- BUT WHAT I
WOULD SAY THAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT OF PROVIDED A LOT OF
FLEXIBILITY- SO THAT SCHOOLS
CAN CONTINUE TO PROVIDE MEALS
AND- SETTINGS THAT ARE
DIFFERENT FROM WHAT WAS- WAS
REQUIRED PREVIOUSLY SO NOW FOR
EXAMPLE PARENTS KATIC PICKUP
MEALS- THEY DON'T HAVE TO BE
PROVIDED IN GROUP SETTINGS-
IT'S ABOUT- AND YOU CAN ALSO
CAN PROVIDE SOME OF THESE
NIELSEN IN. FIVE STEPS PERHAPS
PREVIOUSLY WHAT AUTHORIZED
THERE'S A LOT OF FLEXIBILITY
FOR SCHOOLS WELL- TO STILL
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE THOSE KNOWS
AND GET THEM REIMBURSED I'M
MORE WE HAVE HEARD SOME
CONCERNS ARE JUST OF THE NUMBER
OF MEALS THAT- SCHOOLS ARE-
ISSUING ARE MUCH LOWER THAN
WHEN SCHOOL IS IN SESSION AND-
AS A RESULT THAT IS GOING TO
REDUCE THE OVERALL AMOUNT OF
FUNDING THAT SCHOOLS ARE
GETTING FROM- THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT FROM THE STATE IN
TERMS OF A MEAL REIMBURSEMENT.
THAT THE WAY THE FUNDING WORKS
WE TYPICALLY PROVIDED ON A PER
A PREMIER ACCOUNT- SO- FOR
DISTRICTS WOULD BE OUT OF DATE
BY AND LARGE HAVE THEIR SAME
STAFF THAT HAVE BEEN WORKING
WITH THERE'S THEY'RE PAYING THE
STATE'S STAFF- TO DO THE WORK
AND THEN THAT THE AMOUNT THAT
THEY'RE GETTING NOW FROM THE
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS
LOWER THAN THEY MIGHT HAVE
ANTICIPATED. THAT'S WHAT WE'VE
HEARD OF THE CONSERVE SIDES
IT'S NOT THAT THAT THERE IS AN
FUNDING BUT THAT THE AMOUNT
THAT THAT THEY'RE GOING TO GET
HIS LICENSE SO THAT'LL BE PART
OF THE COST PRESSURE- WE ARE
ARE HOPING THAT WITH A LITTLE
MORE TIME TO GET MORE
INFORMATION ON WHAT THAT LOOK
LIKE WITH THE MAGNITUDE OF THAT
HAS BEEN- BUT WE KNOW THAT ARE
ALSO VERY NICE BY SCHOOL SITE.
AND MY DISTRICT. THANK YOU. I'M
THE OTHER A PEACE I WAS. TO A
LITTLE BIT IN FOR. OF WHAT. YOU
KNOW CUT THE COST AND THAT
WE'RE SEEING AND WHETHER IT'S
NOW OR WHETHER IT'S IN THE
FUTURE RELATED TO- SOME OF OUR
UNDER REPRESENTED A STUDENT
COMMUNITIES ENGLISH LEARNERS-
AIDS A POPULATION THAT WE ARE
AND- I MEAN WE'VE KNOWN- PRIOR
TO THIS THAT- EDUCATING ENGLISH
LEARNER LEARNERS- IT DIDN'T
REQUIRE SPECIAL CONSIDERATION
BUT NOW THAT YOU COMBINED THE
POTENTIAL DIGITAL DIVIDE. WITH
THIS EIGHT SEEMS PARTICULARLY
MORE DIFFICULT- SO CAN WE
COMMENT ON WHAT WE KNOW IS OR
IS NOT HAPPENING- WITH OUR
ENGLISH LEARNER COMMUNITY HERE
IN THE STATE. I WOULD SAY A I
THINK YOU'RE THERE ARE A COUPLE
OF ISSUES FOR A WIRE OR
DIFFICULT ONE AS I SUGGESTED
FOR. STUDENTS MIGHT NEED
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT THE DISTANCE
LEARNING MODEL IS A LITTLE BIT
DIFFICULT PARTICULARLY RIGHT
NOW. WHERE WE DIDN'T REALLY
HAVE A LOT OF TIME SCHOOL
DIDN'T HAVE TIME TO SORT OF
IMPLEMENTED IN A SORT OF. AWFUL
GRADUAL MANNER THIS IS SORT OF
JUST HAPPENED ALL OF A SUDDEN
THERE'S BEEN ARE A REST TO
ADAPT SO IN BECAUSE OF THAT.
THAT SOME STUDENTS ANY
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT FOR EXAMPLE
BY STOPPING WOULD REALLY
BENEFIT WITH HAVING- SOMEBODY
THERE THAT'S BEEN A CHALLENGE
IN TERMS OF IMPLEMENTING THE
DISTANCE LEARNING- IN ADDITION
TO THAT YOU DO HAVE THE
CHALLENGES ASSOCIATED WITH. OUR
JUST STUDENTS NOT HAVING ACCESS
EITHER BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE
A DEVICE WE DON'T HAVE-
INTERNET CONNECTIVITY OR MAYBE
THEY JUST DON'T HAVE A OF
ENVIRONMENT IT'S VERY SUITABLE
FOR LEARNING AT HOME. I'M BILLS
ARE A NUMBER OF CHALLENGES THAT
IT HAPPENED I THINK THAT THIS
IS SOMETHING THAT. I WILL BE
OUT THERE ARE PARTICULARLY BIG
IMPORTANCE IF WE DO AS AS A
MEMBER OF DAHLE MENTION GO IN
AND OUT OF THE BURNING IF WE
DON'T GET. THE TERRIBLE WOULD
BE MORE THOUGHT OF IN TERMS OF
HOW TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT OUR
PLANS ARE IN PLACE FOR THE
STUDENTS- BUT IT IS A GET
SOMETHING THAT WILL NOT A WE
DON'T HAVE ANY PARTICULAR- A NO
IN A PARTICULAR OF THAT.
ANYTHING THAT WE KNOW OF DATA
OF WHAT'S GOING ON OR WHAT- BUT
THEM SPECIFICALLY. THANK YOU
AND I THAT PIECE OF DATA WE
MEAN. HAVE OUR- DISTRICTS- I
MEAN IT'S VERY HARD FOR THEM I
AND I DON'T KNOW WE CAN ASK.
MORE IN IN A TIME LIKE THIS BUT
IS THERE A WAY THAT WE'RE
COLLECTING OR CAPTURING SOME OF
THIS DATA TO BETTER INFORM US.
ON ON WHAT IS OR IS NOT
HAPPENING. TECH SPECIFIC THERE-
IN TERMS OF WHAT WE'RE
COLLECTING BUT I THINK- I DON'T
KNOW IF- THE I KNOW THAT PART
OF IT HAS ANYTHING. TO COLOR I
THINK THERE. ARE THIS IS
PART CONVERSATION IN TERMS OF
DECIDING HOW DO WE- ADDRESS NOT
JUST AND I THINK I'LL TALK
ABOUT IN THE NEXT PANEL HOW DO
WE ADDRESS POTENTIALLY.
LEARNING LOSS THAT MIGHT OCCUR
DURING THESE CLOSERS IN THROUGH
THE SUMMER. AND HOW. SERVICES
THAN CHANGE IN THE NEXT
UPCOMING YEAR TO SERVE ME
COUPLES- FOR THAT- LACK OF
ADDITIONAL ATTENTION FOR
STUDENTS. THANK YOU AND LAST
QUESTION ON THE LA ESTIMATED
THAT CALIFORNIA WILL RECEIVE
THREE POINT SEVEN BILLION
DOLLARS FROM THE CARES ACT. OF
WHICH ONE POINT SIX BILLION OF
THAT IS FOR K. TWELVE SCHOOLS.
HAS THAT FUNDING DIRECTLY REACH
THE SCHOOLS. THE WHOLE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. SO THE
ONE POINT SIX FIVE BILLION THAT
WE ARE RECEIVING FROM THE-
CARES ACT FUNDING- WE RECEIVED
A NOTICE THAT THE AWARD LAST
WEEK WE ARE CURRENTLY WORKING
ON FILLING OUT THE APPLICATION
IN ORDER TO DRAW DOWN THE FUNDS
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT SO
AND THE FUNDS HAVE NOT YET MADE
IT TO SCHOOLS BUT WE ARE
WORKING VERY QUICKLY TO TRY TO
WHEN DO WE EXPECT THAT THOSE
FUNDS WOULD REACH THE SCHOOLS.
SEN I THIS IS A GREAT STATE
CHIEF DEPUTY SUPERINTENDENT
FROM THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION SORRY WE'VE BEEN
TRYING TO JUMP IN AND BE ABLE
TO ANSWER THE QUESTIONS YOU HAD
RELATED TO SEVERAL PIECES SO
REGARDING THE CARE IS ACTIVE
THE STATE BOARD OF EDUCATION
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
AS IN FILLING OUT THE
APPLICATION FOR THAT. THE
FUNDING THAT WILL GO DIRECTLY
TO OUR ELEAZAR. THAT FUNDING
WILL BE ABLE TO BE JUST
DISTRIBUTED TO L. A.'S OUT
AROUND JULY FIRST. THANK YOU
AND ALSO IN QUESTION YOU HAD
QUESTIONS AROUND THE TECHNOLOGY
NEEDS TO. WE WANT TO LET YOU
KNOW THAT WE HAVE BEEN
SURVEYING OVER AT THE SAME OF
OUR SCHOOL DISTRICTS REGARDING
THEIR TECHNOLOGY NEEDS AND I WE
HAVE THE DATA COLLECTED FROM
EVERY ALMOST EVERY SCHOOL
DISTRICT ACROSS THE STATE
REGARDING THEIR DEVICE NEEDS
AND THEIR HOT SPOT NEEDS AND
RIGHT NOW THAT NUMBER IS OVER
FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND. OR
DEVICES AND OVER TWO HUNDRED
AND NINETY THOUSAND FOUR HOT
SPOT AND I'LL GO INTO A LITTLE
BIT MORE OF THAT WHEN WE
DISCUSS ISSUED TO ALSO IN
REGARDS TO ENGLISH LANGUAGE
LEARNERS AND WHAT WE'RE BE ABLE
WHAT WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO PROVIDE
AND SUPPORT FOR THEM IS WE'VE
HAD SPECIFIC SUPPORT AROUND
SUPPORTING ENGLISH LEARNERS AND
THIS TIME AND DISTANCE
LEARNING. THROUGH GUIDANCE
DOCUMENTS WEBINARS THAT ARE
DIRECTLY FOR EDUCATORS WE HAVE
ONE HAPPENING THIS WEEK AND ONE
COMING UP IN THE NEXT FEW WEEKS
AS WELL. EIGHT THANK YOU AND-
WHEN IT WENT WHEN THAT FUNDING
COMES- TO THE WAS SCHOOL
DISTRICTS WHEN IT REACHES A
SCHOOL DISTRICT WILL. WE HAVE A
SENSE OF WHAT IT'S GOING TO IS
IT GOING TO BE FOR SPECIFIC
USES ARE WE GOING TO ALLOW
DISTRICTS TO USE THEM AS THEY
NEED I KNOW THAT. IN A TIME
LIKE THIS WE DON'T HAVE THE WAY
TO AUGMENT- MORE FUNDING BUT
CERTAINLY THERE IS AT REQUEST
FOR AT SOME LEVEL OF
FLEXIBILITY IN A TIME OF NEED
WHERE THERE'S SO MANY DIFFERENT
ISSUES AND I'M JUST CURIOUS IF
THERE'S- ARE THERE GONNA BE ANY
GUIDELINES FOR THAT. I AM STEP
GREAT SO FROM THAT DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION THERE IS FULL
FLEXIBILITY FOR OUR ELLIE AIDS
AND HOW THEY SPEND THIS MONEY
COMING FROM THE FEDERAL. THANK
YOU THAT'S ALL THANK YOU CHAIR.
THANK YOU- I HAVE A SERIES OF
QUESTIONS ALL GOING TO COME
BACK AFTER THE MEMBERS GO BUT
JUST MAYBE ON THIS QUESTION
REAL QUICK SO I THINK THIS IS
KEY. IS WE DO THAT FEDERAL
MONEY THAT WHERE WHERE COUNTING
ON IT IT'S OUR HOPE THAT WE
COULD POTENTIALLY GET MORE IN
THE NEXT ROUND THAT CONGRESS IS
STILL. IN RIGHT NOW AS WE LOOK
BACK IN THE GREAT RECESSION I
THINK THE AMOUNT THAT WE GOT.
IN CALIFORNIA WAS MANY TIMES
MORE THAN THIS AND THE SEVERITY
OF THIS MAY BE EQUAL OR GREATER
TO. WHAT WE SAW- A DECADE AGO
SO THAT MONEY MAY BE JUST BE
USED TO KEEP THE DISTRICTS HALL
BECAUSE THE RIGHT NOW THE
NUMBERS WERE HEARING FROM-
PROJECTIONS ARE HEARD YESTERDAY
FROM THE LA- DEAL LAUGH. COULD
BE THE TENS OF BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS IN LOST REVENUE WITH
THAT. LACK OF ECONOMIC ACTIVITY
OUT THERE IS WE HAVE TO BE. BE
MINDFUL OF THAT- SO I GUESS I
JUST WANT TO ASK ONE FOLLOW UP
TO SOMEONE MEMBER LIMóN
QUESTION RIGHT NOW. IS THAT.
THEY DISTRICTS- THIS IS A
REALITY CHECK TIME FOR THEM
RIGHT NOW THEY'RE THEY'RE
THEY'RE PLANNING FOR THE SUMMER
AND THE FALL. AND MANY TIMES
THEY ONE WAY MORE THAN WHAT
WE'RE OFFERING RIGHT NOW. SO OF
COURSE THAT THAT THE PIECES
THAT WE'RE LOOKING TO FILL THE
GAP. OUR ONE TEN MONEY WE HAVE
IN THE RESERVE- ANY FEDERAL
MONEY WE ALREADY GOT OR WE
COULD GET INTO THE NEXT ROUND
FROM FROM FROM THE UNITED
STATES CONGRESS. AND ANYTHING
WE CAN DO AS FAR AS- DEFERRALS
OR- YOU KNOW PRIOR TOOLS THAT
WE USE BECAUSE- THE NUMBER ONE
THING WE NEED TO FOCUS ON IS
HOW DO WE- GET OUT OF THIS
ALIVE. AND NOT CUT OUR SCHOOLS.
NOT CUT OUR KIDS I THINK THAT
SHOULD BE THE NUMBER ONE GOAL.
THAT WE'RE FOCUSING ON IN
ADDITION TO OF COURSE BEING
HEALTHY CALIFORNIA DEALING WITH
THE PANDEMIC BUT HOW DO WE-
HAVE THE LEAST AMOUNT OF DAMAGE
TO OUR KIDS AND OUR SCHOOLS. SO
WHAT WHAT ARE WE THINKING FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. IS
THERE THE REALITY CHECK AS FAR
AS- WE KNOW MORE MONEY. FOR
EDUCATION AND GET ON TOP OF
JANUARY THAT'S NOT IN THE
CARDS. BUT ARE WE REALISTIC
THAT WILL BE ABLE TO HAVE. A
STATUS QUO- AT NO- NO NET LOSS
I KNOW THAT THAT WAS THE GOAL
WHEN WE VOTED. IN MARCH WHEN WE
WHEN WE WHEN RECESS WAS TO
HAVE. A HOLD HARMLESS TO DO WE
DO WE THINK THAT'S REALISTIC AT
SCHOOL DISTRICTS CAN CAN HAVE-
THE ASSUMPTION THAT THEY'LL BE
NO- NEGATIVE. ACTINS FROM THE
STATE LEGISLATURE RELATE TO
SCHOOL FUNDING. YOU FOR YOUR
QUESTION AND RECORDED WITH THE
JUST CALM DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. AND SO WE ARE STILL
WORKING ON BUILDING THE NAY
REVISION- AND GETTING A BETTER
SENSE OF WHAT OUR REVENUES ARE
GOING TO BE MOVING FORWARD-
HOWEVER A COUPLE OF THINGS.
NOTE AT JENNY AT THE JANUARY
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET WE WERE-
PROJECTING A PATH ONE IN OUR-
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GUARANTEE LEVEL WHICH IS VERY
SENSITIVE TO REVENUES- SO
IMPACT REVENUES ARE VERY LIKELY
TO- IMPACT THE AMOUNT OF
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
PENDING AVAILABLE FOR SCHOOL-
BUT SOMETHING IMPORTANT TO KEEP
IN MIND- I CAN'T SPEAK. TO WHAT
HAPPENED IN THE PRIOR
RECESSION- AS AS YOU NOTED- YOU
KNOW THAT THIS ECONOMIC IMPACT
COULD LOOK SIMILAR TO THAT AND-
THERE THERE WERE MANY
DIFFERENT- OPTIONS THAT WE
ADOPTED IN ORDER TO. MITIGATE
THE IMPACT TO SCHOOL- AND THAT
INCLUDES DEFERRED BANQUET
DEFERRAL ON USE OF ONE TIME
FUN- BUT IN THE LAST. RECESSION
WE ALSO- DID AT AT LOOK AT
PRODUCTION AND BASS-
APPORTIONMENT. SO YOU KNOW IF
IT IT'S HARD PROJECT EXACTLY
GOING TO LOOK LIKE IT IS BUT
BECAUSE- THEY SAID WE'RE STILL
WORKING ON THE NAY REVISION
BUT- THERE THERE ARE SOME
INDICATORS THERE THAT. THERE
MAY BE SOME DIFFICULT DECISIONS
THAT NEED TO BE MADE MOVING
FORWARD. AND DID LA WANT TO.
WEIGH IN ON THIS ISSUE AS WELL.
I'M SURE- I WOULD JUST SAY A
BIG THE LEGISLATURE DID TAKE A
VARIETY OF ACTIONS LAST TIME TO
TRY TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE- SO
THAT IT WASN'T JUST
SPECIFICALLY CUTS THE VOTE I
BELIEVE MY UNDERSTANDING IS I
THINK THE CUTS WERE ABOUT. 9%
CUTS TO GENERAL PURPOSE FUNDING
AOUT 20% CUTS TO CATEGORICAL
PROGRAMS WHEN WE DID RELY
SIGNIFICANTLY OF THE STATE ON
PATROLS IN THE- IN THE PREVIOUS
ARE RECESSION AND THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT- IS WHAT IS ONE
WAY TO HELP AVOID A SCHOOL
DISTRICT HAVING TO MAKE CUTS-
BUT THE ONE THING I WOULD SAY
WITH WITH DEFERRALS IS IT.
THERE'S A PARTICULAR THINGS
THEN YOU HAVE TO BE ONE OF THE
FIRST IS THAT- IT DOES CREATE
CASH FLOW BURDENS FOR DISTRICTS
SO TO THE EXTENT THAT THEY
CAN'T ADDRESS WAS CAST FOR
NEITHER. IT COMPLAINTS BECOME A
CUT I THINK THAT'S
PARTICULARLY- CHALLENGING FOR A
SCHOOL A SMALL SCHOOL DISTRICT
AND FOR CHARTER SCHOOLS. AND I
THINK THE OTHER THING IS THAT
WHEN YOU DO IT THE FOR ALL YOUR
SORT OF A. OF COUNTING ON.
THINGS GETTING BETTER AND
YOU'RE KIND OF. THE NEED FOR
THE- BUT IF WE DO HAVE US THE
STATE AND- RECESSION ANALYTICS
MULTIPLE YEARS THAT CAN
SOMETIMES THE NEED TO. CUT THEM
A FUTURE IF WE DON'T. IF WE
DON'T. HAVE AN INCREASE IN
REVENUES. WHEN THE STATE DID
THE PATROLS LAST TIME WE- YOU
KNOW THAT WE IMPLEMENTED-
ESSENTIAL NUMBER OF DEFERRALS-
AND THEN- THEY- COMING. OUT OF
THE STORE TO RECOVER AND THEN
PROP THIRTY WAS PASSED AND THAT
THROUGHOUT THE STATE WAS ABLE
TO PEOPLE'S DOWN AND- AVOID
SOME OF THOSE REDUCTIONS. BUT
THE OTHER THING THAT THE STATE
DID A LOT OF- IT IT WAS- TRYING
TO PROVIDE MORE FLEXIBILITY ON.
CATEGORICAL PROGRAM RESERVES- I
BELIEVE THAT. WE HAVE AT SOME
POINT IT WAS MORE THAN A
BILLION DOLLARS IN CATEGORICAL
RESERVES THAT HAVE BEEN- IN
DISTRICTS ARE RESERVES AND WE
SAID FOR THE- PRINTER. THAT
RECESSION PERIOD WE SAID. YOU
CAN USE IT FOR ANY PURPOSE AND
SO DISTRICTS RELY ON THAT TO.
MITIGATE SOME OF THOSE CUTS.
I'M WE DO THINK THAT THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT'S NOT GOING TO
BE- AS OUR HELPFUL THIS TIME
AROUND BECAUSE THE LCI FIVE.
ARE THROUGH THE PROCESS OF
CLEANING UP THE FIVE WE LIVE IN
A LOT OF THESE KIND OF LOCAL
PROGRAM SO. WE HAVE BEEN
LOOKING AT THE AMOUNT THAT THAT
ARE AVAILABLE BUT WE DON'T
EXPECT THAT'S GOING TO BE AS-
AS- ACOSTA MUSIC. THAT WAS IN
THE PAST. SO IN SAM HE DO WE
THINK THAT WE BE ABLE TO TELL I
KNOW TODAY'S. LATE APRIL WE
HAVEN'T. HAD A CHANCE TO
RECEIVE THE MAY REVISE AND
EVALUATING GRAND THE ME REVISED
IS. KIND OF I GUESS BECAUSE WE
DON'T HAVE ALL THE REVENUES IN
BUT WE HAVE A GENERAL
ASSUMPTION BUT- BUT DO WE THINK
THAT WE COULD TELL. SCHOOL THAT
THOUSAND SCHOOL DISTRICTS
ACROSS CALIFORNIA THAT OBVIOUS
IS GIVE ME A DIFFICULT BUDGET
BUT THIS WOULD BE A BUDGET UP A
STATUS QUO OR WOULD WE EXPECTED
WE WILL HAVE TO MAKE- AT A
REDUCTION IN THE NEGATIVE WHEN
WE ADOPT OUR- OUR- TWENTY-
TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET. YEAH
I WITH IT AGAIN I THINK WE
STILL DON'T- OF COURSE I DON'T
KNOW THAT. WE WITH A COUPLE
THING WE THINK THAT. WE CAN
AVOID THOSE THOSE CUTS ARE THE
GUY THAT IS AN IMPORTANT
CHALLENGE IN AN IMPORTANT I
THINK CONSIDERATION IN PASSING
THAT JIM BUDGET- I THINK THERE.
THE AYE THE IDEA IS THAT WE
NEED TO PASSAGE YOU BUDGET OF
CONSTITUTIONALLY REQUIRED. AND
THEN IF THIRTY TWO CHANGES
MAYBE THAT WOULD COME IN LATER.
THE LONGER WE WAIT TO MAKE
THOSE CHANGES THE MORE
DIFFICULT IT WILL BE FOR
DISTRICTS AND SO THE FACT THAT.
IT'S THERE I THINK EVERY YEAR
ESTIMATING REVENUES IS
DIFFICULT- IN THIS PARTICULAR
SITUATION IT'S PARTICULARLY
DIFFICULT AND CHALLENGING-
BECAUSE OF THE DELAY IN FOR
EXAMPLE IN THE IN THE APRIL TAX
PAYMENTS. ARE ABLE TAX FILING
DEADLINE AND JUST SO
SIGNIFICANT UNCERTAINTY WITH
GROUND ECONOMY. IT'S GOING TO
BE A VERY DIFFICULT TIME TO
SEND OF THESE CLEAR SIGNALS
AND- BUT WILL BE AN IMPORTANT
CONSIDERATION. WITH BUDGET. TO
THE EXTENT THAT YOU DO SAY FOR
EXAMPLE- TRY TO AVOID SOME OF
THE INITIAL CUTS FOR A- NINETY
CUTS IN THE IN THE IN THE
NINETEEN TWENTY YEAR- AND THE
SITUATION DOES GET WORSE THAT
DOES. DOES REQUIRE BIGGER CA ON
THE LINE. BUT IT. MIGHT BE.
THAT YOU. WANT TO PRESERVE.
IT'LL IT'LL BE CHALLENGING IN
TERMS OF FIGURE THAT OUT SO I
THINK. I'M FORTUNATE WE DON'T
THINK WE HAVE ENOUGH
INFORMATION TO REALLY SAY.
FIRST CORD YES THIS IS THE SORT
OF MAGNITUDE OF THE OF THE
FISCAL IMPACT THAT WE WOULD SEE.
THANK YOU THE NEXT WILL HAVE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MARC SAID SHE
AN ASSEMBLY MEMBER GALLAGHER.
MR MURATSUCHI THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- I APPRECIATED TO THE LAST
LINE OF QUESTIONING FROM- THE
CHAIRMAN AND THE RESPONSES FROM.
THE LA- AND THAT- IT REMINDS ME
OF MY EXPERIENCE AS A LOCAL
SCHOOL BOARD MEMBER- WITH THE
TAURUS UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
A DISTRICT WITH ABOUT TWENTY
FOUR THOUSAND IN ENROLLMENT.
SMALLER THAN A URBAN DISTRICTS
BUT- ABOUT MEDIUM SIZE IN TERMS
OF OUR SUBURBAN SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND- I KNOW THAT- A
LOT OF WHATTHE LA- DISCUSSED
IN TERMS OF. THE FLEXIBILITY-
AND THE DEFERRALS REALLY MADE A
WORLD OF DIFFERENCE IN ALLOWING
LOCAL SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO- IN A
BALANCED THE BUDGET AND KEEP-
OUR SCHOOLS RUNNING SO I- I
THINK THAT'S GOING TO BE AN
ONGOING THEME THAT THAT WE
REALLY NEED TO EMPHASIZE- THE
NEED FOR FLEXIBILITY FOR- FOR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO BE ABLE TO.
MOVE MONIES AROUND- THEY THEY
KNOW. WHERE THEIR NEEDS ARE THE
GREATEST AND SO WE SHOULD- YOU
KNOW TRULY FALL THE SPIRIT A
PERHAPS REDEDICATE OURSELVES TO
THE SPIRIT OF THE LOCAL CONTROL
FUNDING FORMULA TO ALLOW SCHOOL
DISTRICTS THE MAXIMUM.
FLEXIBILITY TO- ALLOCATE THE
DOLLARS- TO WHERE THE NEEDS ARE
THE GREATEST- I WANTED TO
FOLLOW ON THE CHAIR IS LINE OF
QUESTIONING AND REFERRED TO. A
JOINT LETTER ALL OF THE- SIX
MAJOR SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE THE
LARGEST SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. ALONG THE
LOS ANGELES UNIFIED SAN DIEGO
UNIFIED LONG BEACH UNIFIED.
SACRAMENTO UNIFIED. AS WELL AS
A KRONE NORCO UNIFIED- AND I
WANTED TO- ASK. MORE
SPECIFICALLY ON ON SOME OF THE
ISSUES THAT THEY RAISED IN THIS
LETTER THAT. MAY DRAW THE SAME
RESPONSES THAT WE'VE BEEN
HEARING- THAT THAT IS TOO EARLY
TO PROJECT REVENUES AND THAT WE
DON'T KNOW WHAT TO A SITUATION
WHERE WE'RE GOING TO BE AN BUT-
I KNOW I KNOW FROM MY
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS THAT DID THAT THE TO
CONSISTENT ASKS THAT WE HEAR
ARE- THE COLA THE COST OF
LIVING ADJUSTMENT AND PENSION
RELIEF. SO I WANTED TO ASK THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- FIRST.
YOU MAY HAVE ANSWERED THIS BUT
I WANTED TO- HERE ARE YOU KNOW-
MORE SPECIFIC RESPONSE WHAT ARE
THE CHANCES OF GETTING. YOU
KNOW- A COLA- GUN FOR THIS
UPCOMING MAY REVISE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THAT QUESTION
AGAIN- I YOU KNOW I DON'T WANT
TO SOUND LIKE A BROKEN RECORD
BUT WE'RE STILL ASSESSING THE
LEVEL OF RESOURCES THAT WE ARE
WILL HAVE AVAILABLE- WE RECEIVE
THE SAME LETTER AND ARE AWARE
OF THE CONCERNS AS MANY OF THE
DISTRICTS REGARDING AND WEATHER
NOT COLD WILL BE- PROVIDED AND
WHETHER OR NOT- YOU KNOW. THE
STATE WILL BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL. ANDASSISTANCE WITH
A PENSION RELIEF- SO WE ARE
CERTAINLY AWARE OF THOSE
CONCERNS AND ARE ARE JUST
DISCUSSING WHAT RESOURCES ARE
AVAILABLE SO. FORTUNATELY I
CAN'T PROVIDE YOU WITH MORE
CLARITY AT THIS TIME BUT LOOK
FORWARD TO DISCUSSING ALL THESE
ISSUES- WHEN WE RELEASED
MERITAGE AND- THANK YOU SO- I
WANTED TO FOLLOW UP A TEAR
RESPONSE BY AGAIN RFERRING TO
THIS LETTER WHERE THEY-
REFERRED TO THE PERHAPS THE
BIGGEST DIFFERENCE BETWEEN- THE
BUSES SITUATION THAT WE'RE
FACING NOW- VERSUS WHAT WE
FACED IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHT-
WITH THE GREAT RECESSION WHICH
IS THE- A COMBINED TWENTY
BILLION- AND- ASSORTED RESERVE
FUNDS THAT STATE A CALIFORNIA
THAT THAT WE HAVE BEEN ABLE TO-
SAVE YOU KNOW. STOCK AWAY UGH
YOU KNOW FOR THE RAINY DAY WE
KNOW THAT THE RAINY DAYS IS
HERE AND NOW AND SO THIS LETTER
RECALL REFERS TO A DECLARATION
OF A BUDGET EMERGENCY TO USE
THE STATE'S BUDGET
STABILIZATION FUND- TO FUND A
COLA ABOVE THE STATURE LEVEL.
CAN YOU COMMENT- DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE ON. WHETHER AND TO WHAT
EXTENT WE CAN DRAW UPON A FROM
OUR RESERVES IN ORDER TO TRY
TO- TO- IF NOT- FUND A COLA TO
AT LEAST ALLEVIATE THE BUDGET
CUTS THAT WE MAY BE FACING.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THAT
QUESTION. AGAIN WE SAYS THIS IS
THE NOW THAT THAT WE'RE
CURRENTLY DOING ON AVAILABLE
RESOURCES REALLY ESSENTIAL
CRAFT UNDERSTAND WHAT NEEDS TO
BE DRAWN DOWN IN TERMS OF- ANY
KIND OF RESERVES THE AND I
TRULY DON'T WANT TO GET OUT IN
FRONT OF THE GOVERNOR AND- AN
ART DIRECTOR ON ONLIKE- IS THE
PLAN FOR THE- SIGNS AND I KNOW
THAT THEY WILL BE LOOKING
FORWARD TO ENGAGING. I'M WITH
YOU ALL ON ON THE PROPER USE
THEIR POTENTIAL FOR A CONSUMER
TO BE DECLARATION- WHAT I CAN
SAY IS THAT- WE DO HAVE A
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT RAINY
DAY FUND. WITH THE BALLOT SAYS-
CURRENTLY ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED
TWENTY FOUR MILLION AND THAT-
CERTAINLY- WILL BE RECALCULATED
AND THE COUNTRY BECOMING
AVAILABLE TO SUPPORT-
EXPENDITURES FOR. OUR SCHOOLS
AND IN THE EVENT THAT- THE
EXPANDED AT THE AT THE FORMULA
LOT THE TAXES THAT FUND WHICH
E BELIEVE THAT WELL SO- THERE
ARE FUNDS AVAILABLE ON ON IN A
PROPAGATE RAINY DAY FUND- IN
TERMS OF THE LARGER ALBEIT SAY
ANOTHER. MEETING FUNDS FOR THE
STATE YOU KNOW CERTAINLY LOOK
FORWARD TO HAVING. A
CONVERSATION WITH YOU ALL. THE
NAME. ALL RIGHT OUT MOVING ON
THEN TO THE IS OF PENSION THE
SIGNERS OF THIS- LETTER REQUEST
A STATE FREEZE TO BE EXISTING
EMPLOYER CONTRIBUTION RATES- AS
FOR- THE SCHOOL DISTRICT
CONTRIBUTIONS TO- CAL STIRRERS
AND CALPERS- WHAT IS THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS
POSITION ON THIS REQUEST. SO WE
ARE AND WE'RE LIKE NO CUTE WE
AWARE AS THE INCREASING COST TO
YOU AND WE'LL DISTRICT OF
PENSIONS- AND BASED ON THAT THE
CLAIMS THAT WERE PUT I PLACE
SEVERAL YEARS AGO- AND WE
RECEIVED LETTERS ABOUT THAT-
YOU KNOW WERE AGAIN AFFECTING
WHERE WE'RE AT- AND THAT
LOOKING AT THE ENTIRE PICTURE
HOLISTICALLY THE ECONOMIC
PICTURE OF THE BUDGET- AND-
AGAIN YOU KNOW. LOOKING FOR Q.
Q. ENGAGING WITH YOU ON THAT IN
THE NAY REVISION I THINK WE'RE
ALSO LOOKING AT OTHER- COSTS
THAT AND WE'LL DISTRICTS HAVE
IDENTIFIED THAT THEY HAVE- YOU
KNOW SPECIFICALLY WRITING
COSTLY TO SPECIAL EDUCATION
WHICH IS WHAT WE HAD PROPOSALS
IN THE BUDGET- BACK IN JANUARY-
REGARDING SPECIAL EDUCATION
WE'RE LOOKING AT ALL OF THOSE
THINGS- AND ASSESSING WHEN
WE'RE EXPECTING THE FISCAL.
SURE FOR OUR SCHOOLS AND. IN
THIS DIFFICULT TIME. ALL RIGHT
LAST NOT I. WANT TO A AGAIN
REFER BACK TO MY EXPERIENCE AS
A SCHOOL BOARD MEMBER WHEN WE-
WERE- HAVING TO- DEAL WITH THE
STATE BUDGET CUTS. I WANTED TO
IT IS MY UNDERSTANDING OF THAT
THERE ARE OUR CURRENT SYSTEM
STILL REQUIRES SCHOOL DISTRICTS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO ADOPT THEIR FINAL
A SCHOOL YOUR BUDGET FOR THE
FOR THE UPCOMING BUDGET YEAR BY
THE END OF JUNE AND A GIVEN
THAT WE ARE NOW DEALING WITH
THIS REALITY OF- OF A-
SPECULATIVE MAY REVISE AND A
MORE- REALISTIC. AUGUST REVISE
BASED ON THE REVENUE FIGURES
THAT WILL BE GETTING- IN JULY
AND AUGUST. HOW OURS WHAT IS
THE- DEPARTMENT OF FINANCES-
PLANS IN TERMS OF GIVING SCHOOL
DISTRICTS GREATER FLEXIBILITY
IN ADOPTING THEIR- FINAL SCORE
YOUR BUDGETS GIVEN THAT- TO MY
UNDERSTANDING THERE ARE STILL
REQUIRED TO ADOPT THEIR FINAL-
SCHOOL YEAR BUDGETS IN JUNE
WHEREAS THERE ARE NOT GOING TO
HAVE- MORE REALISTIC NUMBERS IN
TERMS OF WHAT THEIR BUDGET IS
GOING TO BE LOOKING LIKE UNTIL
AUGUST. CERTAINLY YOU AND YOU
ARE CORRECT AND WILL DISTRICT
ARE REQUIRED KID UP THEIR
BUDGET BY THE END OF JUNE- TOOK
NOTICE I WOULD NOT A COUPLE OF
THINGS- ONE THAT- SCHOOL
DISTRICT ARE ALSO REQUIRED TO
UPDATE THEIR BUDGET THROUGHOUT
THE YEAR- AT THAT TRULY DEFINE
PEERING IT- SO THAT IS
CURRENTLY ALREADY BUILT. INTO
INTO OUR SYSTEM AND THE OTHER
THING THAT I WOULD KNOW IS THAT
AND THE GOVERNOR DID RECENTLY
PUT OUT AN EXECUTIVE ORDER- IN
REGARDS TO LOCAL CONTROL
ACCOUNTABILITY PLAN- WHICH ARE
AND AS YOU KNOW VERY CLOSELY
TIED TO THE BUDGET PROVIDING
SCHOOL DISTRICTS WITH
FLEXIBILITY- AN EXTENSION ON-
THAT BRING TOGETHER THOSE FULL
PLANS UNTIL THE FALL- WE ARE
LOOKING AT POSSIBILITIES AROUND
THAT- AND GET RECOGNIZING THAT
YOU'RE THERE WE CURRENTLY DO
HAVE PROPERTIES IN PLACE. FOR
INTERIM LOOKS AT AT SCHOOL BUT-
AND- YOU KNOW THAT THAT THERE
IS A PROCESS IN PLACE THIS FALL
FOR COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION
TO ENGAGE WITH THEIR SCHOOL
DISTRICT- AND HELP THEM MAKE
DECISIONS AT THEY'RE LOOKING AT
YOU KNOW. DIFFICULT ECONOMIC
DECISION. THANK YOU ARE. I WANT
TO MAKE MY LAST QUESTION- FOR
NOW- TO FOLLOW UP ON THE LA
OWES. DISCUSSION ABOUT HOW
DEFERRALS WHO WERE- VERY
IMPORTANT IN- ALLOWING SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO BALANCE THEIR
BUDGETS- DURING THE GREAT
RECESSION WHAT IS THE-
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCES
POSITION- AS IT RELATES TO- THE
DEFERRALS. THAT WERE USED
DURING THE GREAT RECESSION TO
ALLOW SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO
ADDRESS THEIR CASH FLOW ISSUES.
I'M SORRY I WANT TO MAKE SURE I
UNDERSTAND- ARE YOU ASKING FOR
WHAT OUR OPINION LET THOSE
THOSE DEFERRALS THAT WERE USED
DURING THE GREAT RECESSION. YES
AND THE TO WHAT EXTENT- THOSE.
ARE DEFERRALS ARE BEING
CONSIDERED- TO. ALLOW SCHOOL
DISTRICTS. TO DO WHAT THE
CURRENT REALITY- OF OUR A-
PANDEMIC INDUCED BUDGET CRISIS.
YOU FOR THAT CLARIFICATION ON
GO AGAIN AND AS I MENTIONED
BEFORE WE ARE YOU KNOW VERY
AWARE OF THE DIFFERENT- OPTIONS
THAT WERE CONSIDERED AND PUT
INTO PLACE DURING THE GREAT
RECESSION WE'RE CERTAINLY
LOOKING AT- ALL OF THOSE- AS
MEDICAL PROBLEM ENGINE BEFORE
AND THE FLEXIBILITY- ARE NO
LONGER AVAILABLE TO US BECAUSE-
OF THE ADOPTION OF THE ACT
THAT- HOWEVER WE'RE TRYING TO
BE VERY- A HOLISTIC APPROACH IN
TERMS THAT CONSIDERING ALL
AVAILABLE OPTIONS BUT AGAIN
WELL NO BETTER IN TWO WEEKS-
WHAT- WHAT DIFFERENT OPTIONS
MAKE MONTH THAN AND LOOK FOR TO
PREVENT CONNECT TO YOUR WALLET
IN THE VISION. OKAY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GROW. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN OF A LOT OF MY
QUESTIONS FOR FINANCE WERE WERE
ASKED WHAT IT LOOKS LIKE WE'LL
HAVE TO WAIT FOR THE MEMBER
VISION- I TOO AM INTERESTED IN-
IF YOU. THINK THERE'S GOING TO
BE ON AUGUST FOR VISION WHICH
WHICH I SEEM LIKELY BECAUSE WE
WON'T OTHER REVENUES UNTIL.
JULY FIFTEEN SO I THINK WE'RE
GONNA HAVE TO- LOOK AT THE
REVENUES JULY FIFTEENTH AND-
AND MAYBE MAKE SOME ADJUSTMENTS
IN AUGUST BUT- A QUESTION FOR-
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION SO
WE MOVE QUICKLY AND- I GAVE YOU
A HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS FOR
PP AND CLEANING SCHOOLS CAN
YOU- CAN YOU OUTLINE. WHAT
YOU'VE DONE WITH THAT MONEY-
CONTRACTS PURCHASES
DISTRIBUTION CLEANING- WHETHER
THE MONEY WAS SUFFICIENT OR- IN
EXCESS OF WHAT YOU NEEDED BUT-
IF YOU JUST OUTLINED YOUR
ACTIONS FOR ME APPRECIATE IT.
I
APOLOGIZE IS A CD- COULD YOU
REPEAT THE QUESTION PLEASE. YET
YEAH WE OF THE LEGISLATURE OF
MOVE QUICKLY AND- AUTHORIZE A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS FEE TO
GET PPVS AND CLEAN SCHOOLS AND-
I JUST WANTED TO KNOW WHAT YOU
ACTIONS HAVE BEEN TAKEN
CONTRACTS DISTRIBUTION. OF
DELIVERY- CAN YOU JUST GIVE ME-
THE UPDATE ON THE PROCESS AND
WHAT YOU'VE BEEN DOING WITH
THAT. THIS IS THE LOWEST BIDDER
EDUCATION I'M THOSE FUNDS WERE
ALLOCATED TALLY A IS. THREE
WEEKS AGO- AND ELEAZAR BEING
ASKED TO USE THEM BASED ON.
THESE ARE TIMES THAT WORK ON BY
ADMINISTRATION AND LEGISLATURE
AND SO ON SHELLY IS GOING TO
GET A TERMINATION ON HOW THEY
GO. WE DON'T HAVE ANY DATA
SPECIFICALLY ON AND THE
APPROACH ALLERGIES ARE TAKING
AND HOW THEY'RE GONNA SPEND US
BEYOND ELIGIBLE USES. THAT WORD
AND- QUESTION LETTER. SO THERE
BE ANY. THE ANY REPORTING BACK
OF SOLELY UP TO THEIR
DISCRETION. IT'S ONLY UP TO
THEIR DISCRETION THERE'S
NOTHING IN THE LEGISLATURE THAT
LEGISLATION THAT WE REQUIRE
WORK ONLY ACE OKAY ARE YOU
GETTING IT ARE YOU GETTING ANY
INDICATION THAT THEY'RE HAVING
DIFFICULTY AND ACQUIRING PPVS
OR- OR- CLEANING THE FACILITIES
IN GETTING PRODUCTS THINGS LIKE
THAT. IN TERMS OF PP WE DO HAVE
A STATE OR CALL THAT WE HAVE
WEEKLY WITH OUR IT COALITION
GROUPS AND OUR LABOR MANAGEMENT
GROUPS AND WE ARE HEARING FROM
THEM BECAUSE THEY ARE HAVING
PROBLEMS. ACTUALLY ACQUIRING-
EP EQUIPMENT SO E ARE ACTUALLY
WORKING DIRECTLY WITH CALLAWAY
ASKS AND WE HAVE CREATED KIND
OF AN INTERNAL WORKGROUP. ON
HOW BEST TO ENSURE THAT WE'RE
GETTING PP TO THE SCHOOLS THAT
YET SO WE ARE WORKING ON THAT
INTERNALLY HERE. OKAY GREAT IF
YOU COULD GIVE THAT THE
COMMITTEE POSTED ON THAT- AFTER
A CALL I WOULD APPRECIATE IT
THANKS SO MUCH. YES OKAY THANK
YOU MISTER BROWN I KNOW MR
GALLAGHER ASK QUESTIONS BE
STEPPED OUT I HAVE A FEW AND
THEN WE'LL GET TO THAT CHAIRMAN
TING HAS A FEW QUESTIONS BUT
FOLLOWING UP ON THIS PP E.
QUESTION IS ONE OF MY ISSUES ON
MY NOTES HERE BUT ALSO I WILL
NOTE THAT WE GOT A TEXAS NOW
FOR MAR ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA
BACK IN RIVERSIDE HE'S-
WATCHING US LIVE OUT THERE ANY
ONLY MAKE SURE THAT WE ASK THIS
QUESTION- WE'VE HEARD FROM A
LOT OF- CLASSIFIED EMPLOYED
SPECIALLY THE ONES THAT ARE
WORKING RIGHT NOW ON MEALS THAT
DON'T HAVE PROPER EQUIPMENT.
AND ONE OF THE ISSUES IS SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ARE STRUGGLING TO PAY
THE BILLS AND IF THEY HAVE TO
SPEND MONEY ON THIS P. P. THIS
MONEY THEY DON'T ACTUALLY HAVE
THE FIRST PLACE SO WE ARE AS WE
TALKED ABOUT. THE LAST HEARING.
HAVE THIS MAJOR BILLION DOLLAR
ORDER- THAT'S IN THE- PIPELINE
SO. THE QUESTION IS ARE ARE.
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND FRANKLY
THE NEXT ANEL AS WELL IN THE
AFTERNOON. OUR CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS AND FACILITIES ARE
THEY GOING TO BE ELIGIBLE TO
TAP INTO THIS- PP FOR THEIR
NEEDS. A HOME DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- AT I CERTAINLY CITY-
FOR FREE TO THE ADS- ON
ANYTHING I'M ABOUT TO SAY THAT-
YOU KNOW CURRENTLY THE PROCESS
AND IS THAT TO THE EXTENT THAT
PP IS NOT A BILL. WILL CAN'T
ACT OF PP ON THEIR OWN- THERE
IS A PROCESS AND THROUGH THE
EMERGENCY OPERATIONS THAT THEM
FOR SCHOOL TO REQUEST
ASSISTANCE WITH PP- FROM THEIR
CITY AND WORK COUNTY- AND THEN
TO THE EXTENT THAT- THEIR
UNSUCCESSFUL WIHOUT THEY CAN
WORK DIRECTLY WITH THE STATE-
AND I. DEFERREDTO FEED TO
PROVIDE ANY MORE ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION FOR HOW I'M
DISTRICT HAVE BEEN WORKING-
THROUGH THEN- WITH CAL- YES
JACKET PP. OKAY BEFORE YES. GO
AHEAD. SORRY I WAS JUST GOING
TO ADD THAT- JUNE TWO WHAT
JESSICA WAS SAYING THAT THAT
PROCESS IS CORRECT- WE'RE JUST
STARTING TO HEAR MORE AND MORE
AS AS I MENTIONED A LITTLE
EARLIER AROUND THE LOCAL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS NOT BEING ABLE TO GET
TO ACCESS PP SO WE HAVE REACHED
OUT THE SUPERINTENDENT REACHED
OUT JUST THIS LAST WEEK TO
CALLAWAY US DIRECTLY SO THAT WE
CAN START A DIRECT LINE I'M TO
DETERMINE WHAT THOSE NEEDS ARE
AND HOW WE CAN BEST I'M PROVIDE
THOSE CERTAIN BED THE NEEDED
EQUIPMENT TO THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT. OKAY I GUESS THE REAL
QUESTION IS LET'S USE MY
DISTRICT HERE AS AN EXAMPLE AT
SAKS CITY- THEY'RE CLASSIFIED
EMPLOYEES THROUGH SO YOU TEND
TO WONDER OUT THERE WORKING
HARD GIVING OUT. TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT OF MEALS THE NUMBERS ARE
JUST STAGGERING. AND THEY'RE
DOING THE BEST THEY DON'T HAVE.
PROPER MASK NORTH FACE SHIELDS
AND NOW THEY'RE PURCHASING THEM
BUT THE DISTRICT DON'T HAVE THE
MADE IN THE FIRST PLACE AND SO
I GUESS THERE IS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BITE BUT THAT'S
REALLY NOT THE ISSUE THE
QUESTION IS. YOU KNOW CHAIRMAN
TEAM WE HAD A BIG HEARING A
WEEK AGO ABOUT THAT BILLION
DOLLAR ORDER. THAT'S COMING FOR
PP ACROSS THE STATE SO WE'LL
DISTRICTS GET THAT. CHANCE TO
JUST GET IT WITHOUT HAVING TO
PAY FOR IT AND THAT'S THE REAL
ISSUE. THAT DISTRICTS CARE
ABOUT IS CAN THEY ACQUIRE IT
WITHOUT HAVING TO HAVE TO DIP
INTO THEIR OWN. RESOURCES TO
PAY THE BILL FOR THAT.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. HELLO
AGAIN I AS DEFERREDSAID THAT
THE PROCESS THAT I OUTLINED
BEFORE AND TO THE EXTENT THAT
SCHOOL DISTRICT ARE HAVING
DIFFICULTY THEY CAN CERTAINLY-
WORK THROUGH- THEIR COUNTIES OR
AT THE STATE- YES- IN TERMS OF
THE COST OF THOSE- I CAN GET
BACK TO YOU ON- YOU KNOW WHO
THAT THAT BECAUSE THEY DON'T
HAVE THE INFORMATION AB RIGHT
NOW. YEAH THAT'S THE ISSUE I
GET A FOLLOW UP WITH OUR
SUPERINTENDENT AND THEY SAID
THAT BE GREAT TO GET IT BUT DO
WE HAVE TO PAY FOR IT BECAUSE
THAT. REALLY IS THE ISSUE RIGHT
NOW I WANT TO MOVE ON TO
ANOTHER- ISSUE. AND WE'RE GONNA
GET MORE INTO THIS IN THE NEXT
PANEL BUT WHILE WE HAVE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ON THE
LINE RIGHT NOW. OF COURSE I
KNOW YOU'RE WORKING ON THAT MAY
REVISE YOU DON'T HAVE BEFORE US
THERE ARE SO MANY. QUESTIONS
NOT ENOUGH ANSWERS RIGHT NOW.
THE ONE THING THAT WE REALLY
WANT TO ADDRESS IS THIS. THE
LEARNING LAS ISSUE WHICH WE'RE
GONNA GET IN GREAT DETAIL THE
NEXT PANEL. AND JUST WANTED TO
PROBE THE INTERESTING ARC. AS I
SAID EARLIER OUR NUMBER ONE
GOAL IS TO KEEP DISTRICTS HOLD
TO NOT MAKE CUTS WE ADOPT THIS
YEAR'S BUDGET- IN ADDITION. I
THINK THAT WE REALLY NEED TO
ADDRESS THE EQUITY ISSUE AND
THE- ISSUES WE HAVE WILL GO A
LEARNING LOST SO. TO THE EXTENT
THAT IT'S POSSIBLE THE ASSEMBLY
IS LOOKING AT MAKING A TOP
PRIORITY TO HAVE A ONE TIME-
BLOCK GRANT AVAILABLE TO
DISTRICTS FOCUSING ON LEARNING
LAS WHETHER IT'S- SUMMER SCHOOL
OR SUMMER BRIDGE. OR OR OTHER
OPPORTUNITIES- TO FOCUS ON OUR
KIDS THROUGHOUT THE SUMMER
POTENTIALLY THE FALL TO MAKE
SURE THEY'RE- THEY'RE THEY'RE
UP TO SPEED WHEN THEY GET GET
BACK AT SCHOOL. SOME MAY SAY
WILL SCHOOLS MAY NOT BE OPEN
WELL WE CAN CERTAINLY DO WHAT
WE'RE DOING NOW AND FOCUS ON ON
DISTANT STAR BUT THE ISSUE IS
THAT. THE GAP IS REAL AND IT'S
IS GONNA EXASPERATING SO MANY
COMMUNITIES ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
SO WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
PUT IT ON THE TABLE- OURS PARK
TO SEND SIGNAL TO SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AT THIS. THING THAT
AS A ALREADY STUDENTS. THANKS
FOR IT ALREADY A NOTE.
YESTERDAY I THINK. DISTRICT
THEY'D LIKE TO DO OTHER PROGRAM
BUT WHEN MAKE SURE THAT WE THE
OP. TO PLANT WORD. AND PUT. BUT
REPURPOSE THEM OF OUR ONE TIME.
MONIES FOR THIS PURPOSE SO- I
KNOW I'VE SPOKE GOVERNOR
PERSONALLY ABOUT THIS BUT I
JUST WANTED TO. ASK GOD TO.
FINANCE YOU HAD INTEREST. THAT
AND ARE AT LINDA DOCUMENT
DEALING HIM AND I KNOW THAT ON
THE NEXT PANEL- AND CAN PROVIDE
A LOT OF. MORE DETAILED
INFORMATION ON THAT BUT- I WE
ARE CERTAINLY AWARE THAT AND
WE'RE WORKING- WITH OUR
PARTNERS A PART. OF EDUCATION
PART OF EDUCATION. ON
IDENTIFYING YOU KNOW WHAT THAT
THAT LEARNING HAD THEN- AND
WHAT NEEDS TO BE DONE TO
MITIGATE IT- BUT AGAIN. YOU
KNOW. I THINK THEY WERE AWARE
OF IT- BUT WE- CAN'T REALLY
SPEAK TO ANY POTENTIAL. I'M A
FUNDS AVAILABILITY OR ANYTHING
LIKE THAT INTO THE KITCHEN THE
REVISION. FAIR ENOUGH FAIR
ENOUGH AND THEN- LASTLY I KNOW
THAT TODAY THE GOVERNOR AT NOON
APPARENTLY IS GOING TO-
ANNOUNCED SOME AN UPDATE TO THE
STAY AT HOME ORDER RELATE TO
SCHOOLS. AND WHAT WE COULD
EXPECT IF SCHOOLS DO REOPEN
FOCUSING ON SAFETY AND
PREPARATION- YOU KNOW THE PLACE
BASED ACTIVITY WAS SCHOOLS AND
CHILDCARE CENTERS-
WORKSTATIONS- IS THERE ANYTHING
THAT. YOU WANT TO ADD MAY BE
NOW OR MAYBE AFTERNOON WHEN YOU
WE WOULD COME BACK YOU CAN YOU
CAN ELABORATE ON THAT THAT MAY
BE HELPFUL AS WELL. CERTAINLY
THANK YOU AND I WOULD NOT WANT
TO SELL THE GOVERNOR SANDERS SO
I WILL- FIT MY COMMENTS FOR
AFTER THAT OKAY HI BUT THIS
MAY. PUT YOU ON A LITTLE TIME
OUT IT WILL COME BACK IN ABOUT
AN HOUR AND A HALF AND SEE IF
YOU CAN ENLIGHTEN US THERE- GET.
OKAY AND THEN- AND WE'RE
WAITING FOR US TOGETHER TO COME
BACK. ASSEMBLYMEMBER TING HAD
SOME QUESTIONS AS WELL.
TERMINATING THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN I JUST GOING TO LA- WE
TALKED A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
DEFERRALS AS A TOOL TO- YES
STAVE OFF BUDGET CUTS TO THE
OTHER TOOLS THAT YOU WOULD
RECOMMEND US LOOKING OUT AS WE-
ACTUALLY HAVE TO COME
CONTEMPLATE. CUTS. THE BANK CAN
JUST WALKING THROUGH SOME OF
THE MAJOR THINGS THAT ARE- TOOK
THE FOR ALL THIS IS ONE OF THEM
THAT YOU CAN DO- TRYING TO FIND
PLACES WHERE YOU MIGHT WANT TO
MAKE- BUT CHANGE THE LAW TO
PROVIDE MORE FLEXIBILITY FOR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS IS SOMETHING
THAT HAS BEEN DONE IN THE PAST
AS WELL. IT WAS ALSO KIND OF
HAVE THEIR OWN ISSUES- AND
OFTENTIMES THE COMES THAT AT
SOME TRADE OFFS BUT IT DOES
PROVIDE DISTRICTS MORE
FLEXIBILITY TO. CHOOSE HOW TO
HOW TO MAKE THOSE CUTS SO FOR
EXAMPLE ONE THING THAT. THEY
DID IT DURING THE MIDST OF THE
RECESSION IS TO ALLOW SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO REDUCE THE SCHOOL
YEAR TWO HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
FIVE DAYS- AND- AND THAT. THEY
DID THAT AND MAYBE. REDUCTIONS
TO SALARY TO THE RESULT. THAT
WERE FURLOUGHED- BUT IT SO IT
BECOMES ITS OWN CHALLENGE- BUT
THAT IS ANOTHER- WAY TO PROVIDE
SOME FLEXIBILITY FOR DISTRICTS
IN TERMS OF SOME SPECIFIC RULES
AND- ARM AND- I'M- OBVIOUSLY.
THE ANOTHER BIG QUESTION WILL
BE THAT. AND I WAS TRICKS TO
FINANCES OR TO WHAT EXTENT. DO
WE THINK THERE IS. ACTUALLY
FUNDING FOR. BY THE SCHOOL THE
ON THE MINIMUM COUNTY. AND THAT
IS SOMETHING THAT THAT. WILL BE
PART OF THAT CONVERSATION TO.
THINK ABOUT WHAT OTHER- BLAZER.
MIGHT EXIST- BUT I THINK THE
DEFERRALS IN THE TRYING TO-
FREE UP ADDITIONAL FUNDING
AVAILABLE FOR IT'S KIND OF THE
FIRST. IS THAT. WE THINK IS
GONNA PASS AND I TO PUT. THAT.
FOR THE THAT. CAN BE SOME
ADDITIONAL. OPS ADAM. OF LIKE
THE BIG. WE GOT A SENSE TO NOT
TO LA HEAVY GOT THE SAN. THAT
IT WILL BE A HAVE STARTED TO
QATAR CUTS. IN ALL THE- WE'VE
HAD WITH THEM THEY SEEM TO
KEEP. TALKING ABOUT HOW MUCH
MORE MONEY THEY MIGHT BE
GETTING FROM THE STATE SEEMS
LIKE THEY'RE NOT- THEY'RE NOT
FULLY. SORT OF IN TUNE WITH THE
BUDGET SITUATION. YEAH I AM WE
HAVE BEEN IN COMMUNICATION WITH
SOME SCHOOL DISTRICTS- DIES YOU
CAN IMAGINE IT'S BEEN A LITTLE
BIT MORE- DIFFICULT TO SET UP
THOSE CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THE
FOLKS I DO THINK THAT. IN OUR
CONVERSATIONS THERE'D BEEN SOME
UNDERSTANDING THAT YOU KNOW OUR
REVENUES ARE NOT GONNA BE LIKE
WHAT THEY WERE IN THE AND
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET WHAT I DON'T
THINK I'VE BEEN- IS TOTALLY
CLEAR IS SORT OF THE
EXPECTATIONS AROUND WORKS OF
POPCORN WE'RE GOING TO GO AND I
THINK IT'S- OBVIOUSLY NOT THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT'S BUT I THINK
IT'S- EVERYONE STRUGGLING IN
OUR DUTY AS ARE MEMBERS OF THE
COULD ASK- AWESOME FINANCE TO
KIND OF PROVIDE SOME GREATER
SERBIAN TERMS OF WHAT THE
MAGNITUDE. REDUCTION WILL BE I
THINK IT IS- VERY DIFFICULT TO
SORT OF OUR THE GRAVEL TOOLS
WILL BE AND THE SPEED AT WHICH
THE SORT OF ECONOMIC SITUATION
IS CHANGING VERY FAST- HERE-
BUT WAS FASCINATING IN THE
PREVIOUS RECESSIONS LOCUSTS.
ARE VERY DRASTIC YOU'RE SO I
THINK THAT'S BEEN ONE OF THE
TOWNS THAT THING JUST PIVOTING
TO SORT OF WHAT THE NEW
EXPECTATIONS ARE CAN BE A
CHALLENGE WE DO THINKTHAT ONE
OF THEM IMMEDIATE CONCERNS I
KNOW THAT IT IN SOME
CONVERSATIONS THAT IS JUST SORT
OF EITHER GOING TO BE- MANY
HERE ACTIONS ARE MAJOR CHANGES
SOMETHING MORE IMMEDIATE. LIKE
A REDUCTION IN NINETEEN TWENTY
OR A DEFERRAL OF THE PAYMENT
AND I THINK THERE'S BEEN I'M A
KNOWLEDGE OF THE DISTRICTS
WOULD LIKE SOMETIME TO BE ABLE
TO ADDRESS THAT SO THAT THEY
HAVE- YOU KNOW THE ABILITY FOR
EXAMPLE THIRTY TO GET A
DEFERRAL. I HAVE- THE ABILITY
TO GO OUT AND BORROW FUNDING
FOR THAT PURPOSE SO FULLER SOME
OF THE POSITIONS THAT WE HAD A
WE HAVE NOT I'M SORT OF GONE
MUCH INTO THE DETAILS. WHAT
BUDGET CUTS MIGHT LOOK LIKE AND
WHAT WHAT- OR- WOULD. TO HAVE.
BOASTING THANK YOU ARE JUST TO
DIP OF JUST ON THAT SAY. IS HOW
IT IN YOUR CAN WITH ELEAZAR DO
YOU FEEL THAT THEY ARE STARTING
TO COME UP WITH SOME POTENTIAL
SOLUTIONS AROUND- POTENTIAL
BUDGET CUTS I KNOW THAT ALL THE
LEGISLATORS HAVE BEGINNING A
SLEW OF INCREASE OVER THE LAST-
NUMBER WEEKS FROM THEIR VARIOUS
LOCAL AND LIAISE. BUT THE
CONVERSATION SEEMS TO FOCUS ON
WHAT THAT THE CALL WAS COMING
AND DID NOT REGARDING POTENTIAL
CUTS AND WHETHER THEY ARE
PREPARED TO OFFER SUGGESTIONS
ON WHAT WHAT TO DO SO. IF YOU
COULD COMMENT ON YOUR
COMMUNICATION WITH THE WAY IT
IS AND THEY'RE FISCAL
PREPAREDNESS IN THIS PANDEMIC
SITUATION. THIS IS THE SECOND
STATUE AGAIN I WOULD SAY THAT
RIGHT NOW WE ARE HEARING MORE
FROM THE COUNTY OFFICES-
BECAUSE THEY DO PLAY AN
OVERSIGHT ROLE OR THEIR LOCAL
SCHOOL DISTRICTS OR HEARING
MORE FROM THEM IN TERMS OF THE
CHALLENGES THEY ARE FACING. AND
HOW TO ADVISE THEIR LOCAL
DISTRICTS RIGHT NOW- SO WE KNOW
THAT THERE ARE- ALSO
COMMUNICATING WITH MIKE FINE
AND THICK MATS TO TRY AND GET
SOME SOME ADDITIONAL GUIDANCE
IN TERMS OF FISCAL TOOLS AND
HOW THEY CAN BEST HELP MANAGE
IT- BUT UNTIL WE KNOW MORE
AROUND- AS WE'VE ALL TALKED
ABOUT TODAY WHAT. MAY REVISE
MAY LOOK LIKE- THEY'RE THEY'RE
KIND OF WAITING TO SEE AS WELL
AS CHIU TO WEAR HOW THEY
CONTINUE TO BUDGET AND MOVE
FORWARD. WHAT WHAT ADVICE ARE
YOU GIVING THEM ON HOW TO
PROCEED. WELL IT WAS SO I'M NOT
COUNTY OFFICES ARE ON. HAVE
THAT OVERSIGHT RESPONSIBILITY
UNDER EACH OFF AND RIGHT TO
PROVIDE GUIDANCE AND OVERSIGHT
TO THEIR LOCAL SCHOOL DISTRICTS
AND SO WE DEFERRED TO THOSE
THAT COUNTY OFFICES- AND WE
PROVIDE TECHNICAL SUPPORT AND
ASSISTANCE TO THEM AS THEIR
PRICING. BASED OKAY COULD COULD
YOUR TO THE QUESTION I JUST
ASKED YOU. THE AS IT WAS BUT
JUST MENTION WE DON'T WE AS A
STATE ENTITY DON'T PROVIDE THAT
THE SCHOOL OVERSIGHT SO THE
LOCAL COLONEL OPPOSITE PROVIDED
TODAY TO THE ALLEY ETS- AT THIS
POINT AS- WE DON'T KNOW ANYMORE
AS AS JESSICA'S MENTIONED IN
TERMS OF. THE FINANCES OF THE
STATE WE DON'T KNOW ANY ANY
ADDITIONAL STEPS ON HOW TO
GUIDE THEM- THE LOCALS THE
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION ARE
THE ONES THAT HAVE THAT
RESPONSIBILITY AND ARE THE ONES
THAT ARE BEST IN THE BEST
CONNECTION WITH THEIR LOCAL
SCHOOL DISTRICTS. AS TO BUT THE
PROVIDING THAT OVERSIGHT. THAT
WE PLAY A ROLE MORE IN
PROVIDING TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
WE DON'T PROVIDE THAT LEVEL OF
THE SCHOOL OVERSIGHT
RESPONSIBILITY AND WHAT TOWN
DOT ORG BY USING RIGHT NOW
BASICALLY A LOT OF THE SAME
THINGS THAT HAVE BEEN TALKED
ABOUT ON THIS CALL- RELATED TO.
WHAT HAPPENED DURING THE GREAT
RECESSION AND DEFERRALS THE
OTHER FLEXIBILITY- DOES
FLEXIBILITY TECH TO COME
THROUGH YOU KNOW LEGISLATION
RIGHT NOW NO THEY'RE PLANNING
FOR DEFERRAL RUNNING DIFFERENT
BUDGET SCENARIOS. I'M I'M
DIFFERENT MODELS. ON THE
GUIDANCE THAT THEY'RE RECEIVING
CONTACT ME OFFICE. IN THE TO DO
REPORT WE'RE JUST TO PROVIDE
ANY OTHER GUIDANCE AROUND THE
FEDERAL FLEXIBILITY IS THAT ARE
BEING PROVIDED AS WELL. THANK
YOU FOR THE OUR HOME THEY ARE
LOOKING AT A VARIETY OF
SCENARIOS. INCLUDING CUTS. TO
THE BEST OF YOUR KNOWLEDGE. YES
KELLY OFF ARE IN THEIR TO DO
THAT. AND I THINK HEY GET A
GIVEN THAT I THINK IT WOULD BE
HELPFUL HOUSE WE- GO THROUGH
THIS BUDGET PROCESS WE'D LOVE
TO HEAR OBVIOUSLY FROM YOUR
OFFICES BUT ALSO THE COUNTIES
AS TO WHAT WHAT IDEAS THEY HAVE
I MEAN YOU JUST HEARD LA- TALK
ABOUT POTENTIALLY DEFERRALS
AND- YOU KNOW DIFFERENT IDEAS
AROUND FLEXIBILITY I THINK
THOSE ARE ALL IDEAS TO BE.
TAKEN INTO ACCOUNT BUT IT WOULD
BE HELPFUL IF YOU HAD. OTHER
IDEAS TO SHARE THEM- I THINK
THEY'RE THEY'RE CHALLENGES IS
YOU KNOW THEY THEY'RE THEY'RE
WATCHING THAT THE STATE BUDGET
BUT- YOU YOU HAVE MORE
INTERACTION ON THE STATE BUDGET
AND THEY DO. SO I AS MUCH AS
YOU CAN- SORT OF JUST ENCOURAGE
THE MEASURE GIVE THEM GUIDANCE
I KNOW YOU DON'T HAVE FISCAL
OVER SURPRISE YOU GIVE THEM
GUIDANCE. TO GUIDE THEM TO
ENSURE THAT YOU AE-
ENCOURAGING THEM TO LOOK AT
OPTIMISTIC SCENARIOS BUT ALSO
PESSIMISTIC SCENARIOS. TO
REALLY HELP- YOU KNOW. HELP
TAKE A LOOK AT WHAT ARE SOME
GOOD GET A BETTER CASE
SCENARIOS BUT ALSO SOME WORST
CASE IN OURS TO. HOME TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- I THINK.
BUT MISTER KING I THINK ALL THE
THINGS THAT YOU JUST MENTIONED
ARE INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT AND IN
OUR CONVERSATION. WITH
STAKEHOLDERS BECAUSE WE HAVE
BEEN- TALKING WITH
STAKEHOLDERS- WE HAVE WE HAVE
ENCOURAGE THEM TO DO JUST THAT
TO LOOK AT ALL OF THE DIFFERENT
OPTIONS AND TRY TO. HIT PREPARE
THEMSELVES CAN BE RELATIVELY
FLEXIBLE ON INFORMATION IS
AVAILABLE. I'M I KNOW THAT- THE
EXCELLENT STAFF AT PICK NOT
AND- YOU KNOW THE WONDERFUL AND
COUNTY UP EDUCATION. CBO GROUP
THAT WE SPEAK TO HAVE BEEN
TALKING ON TO SCHOOL DISTRICT
ABOUT AGAIN. LOOKING AT MANY
DIFFERENT OPTIONS TRYING TO BE
FLEXIBLE I DON'T THE DUSTING
OFF THEIR PLAYBOOKS FROM THE
PRIOR RECESSION. I'M
PATHETICALLY AROUND THINGS LIKE
WHETHER OR NOT- BAKING BORROWED
FROM UNRESTRICTED FUNDS AND-
YOU KNOW. WHAT WHAT WHAT
FLEXIBILITY TO DATE THEY TAKE
AN IN DURING THE RECESSION WHAT
ARE THEIR RESERVE LEVELS.
YOU'RE TAKING A LOOK AT ALL THE
THINGS I THINK PROBABLY THE
MOST IMPORTANT PIECE OF
INFORMATION THAT THEY'VE BEEN
SHARING- AND THAT WE'VE
CERTAINLY BEEN ENCOURAGING
PEOPLE TO DO AS WELL. IS TO IN
IN A DIFFERENT- SOCIAL
DISTANCING TIME- AS MUCH AS
POSSIBLE BE REACHING OUT TO
THEIR STAKEHOLDERS AND STARTING
A CONVERSATION NOW- IN ORDER TO
ENSURE THAT THEY'RE NOT. RIGHT
CONVERSELY THAT HAVE AT A LOW
MINUTE IN I THAT THAT PROBABLY.
THE BEST THING THAT PUTS YOU
CAN RIGHT NOW REALLY WORKING
COMMUNICATING MYSTICAL. I THINK
THE MOST COMPLETE AND I JUST
URGE YOU AS YOU HAVE. CONTINUED
CONVERSATIONS TO. REALLY GO
DOUBLE DOWN ON THOSE
CONVERSATIONS IT DOESN'T APPEAR
THAT THE MESSAGES- GETTING
THROUGH I MEAN THE
CONVERSATIONS THAT I GET FED
THROUGH MY- MY COLLEAGUES IT
SEEMS THAT EVERYBODY IS. STILL
ASKING ABOUT POLO AND STILL
ASKING ABOUT A IN ORDER. IN NOT
LOOKING AT SORT OF LOOMING
RECESSION. SCENARIOS WHICH-
FRANKLY THEY SHOULD BE NOT OVER
THE LAST COUPLE YEARS. SO I
WOULD JUST. ON BOTH DO. MISS
HOMES AS WELL AS PART THAT. TO
JUST. MAKE SURE YOU ARE SURE
THAT MAY. WITH ALL THE THEIR
COUNTY OFFICES ALL DALY ETS.
COULD THINK THAT'S VERY
IMPORTANT I DON'T THINK THE
MESSAGES KOPPEL GETTING THROUGH
AT THIS POINT. GO BACK TO
DEPARTMENT ADD- I THINK WE HAVE
TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THE
EDUCATIONAL ENVIRONMENT IN
THIS- DURING THIS PANDEMIC IS
NOT OPTIMAL AYE AYE I LIKE MANY
OF THE- MEMBERS UP HERE HAVE
CHILDREN IN PUBLIC SCHOOLS. ARE
WE KNOW THAT THEIR ELEAZAR THE
TEACHERS ARE REALLY TRYING
THEIR BEST TO. EDUCATE THE
CHILDREN DURING THIS VERY VERY
CHALLENGING TIME AND WE I THINK
WE JUST HAVE TO ADMIT THAT IT'S
JUST NOT UNDER THE MOST OPTIMUM
OF CONDITIONS. SO CURRENT SO
KIND OF GIVEN THAT. SINCE HOW
HOW DO YOU ENSURE. YOU KNOW A
CERTAIN LEVEL OF ACCOUNTABILITY
WITHOUT. MAKING AN OVERLY ABOUT
BEING BEING COUNTING YOU KNOW
WE OBVIOUSLY. HAVE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT THE EQUITY GAP YOU KNOW
COMPETE EVEN IF COMPUTERS. MY
UNDERSTAND IS EVEN DALY UNIFIED
GIVE COMPUTERS ARE BEING GIVEN
OUT AND THEY'VE NEVER BEEN
LOGGED ON TO. YOU KNOW SO I
MEAN THEY WERE TALKING ABOUT
THOUSANDS OF COMPUTERS SO YOU
HAVE SITUATIONS LIKE THAT. YOUR
SITUATIONS WHERE. THERE IS A-
NOT A STANDARD IN TERMS OF. HOW
MANY. ZOOM CLASSROOM HOURS
EVERY TEACHER SUPPOSED TO BE
DOING UNLIKE YOU KNOW UNLIKE-
CLASSROOM HOURS WOULD THERE'S A
STANDARD HOUSE HOW DO YOU.
START TO REALLY GET YOUR HANDS
AROUND DEVELOPING SOME BROADER
STANDARDS OF THE SITUATION THAT
WE COULD BE TALKING ABOUT IT
MORE- FOR THE NEXT PANEL BUT
HOW BUT HOW DO YOU COME TO GET
YOUR HANDS AROUND THIS. ON JUST
TO ENSURE A CERTAIN AMOUNT OF
ACCOUNTABILITY BUT ALSO
UNDERSTAND THAT WE'RE GOING
THROUGH A VERY EXTRAORDINARY
CIRCUMSTANCES. DO WE LIST. YOU
WOMEN FINANCE NO NO THIS
DEPARTMENT THAT AREN'T BAD. NO
WE'RE WE'RE HERE SORRY AND
REACH YOU CUT OUT A LITTLE BIT
CAN YOU REPEAT THAT LAST PART
OF THE QUESTION PLEASE SURE
ABSOLUTELY ON THE JUST JUST
ACKNOWLEDGING THAT THE I'M
CIRCUMSTANCES ARE NOT IDEAL-
THAT WE DO HAVE- MUCH TALKED
ABOUT EQUITY GAPS EVEN IF.
CHILDREN ARE GETTING COMPUTERS
MANY OF THEM ARE NOT EVEN
LOGGING ON BECAUSE WE DON'T
EVEN KNOW WHAT THEIR HOUSEHOLD
ENVIRONMENT IS- KNOWING THAT WE
DON'T HAVE. SET STANDARDS FOR
TEACHERS SOME TEACH THREE HOURS
OF CLASS ON ZOOM SOME TEACH YOU
KNOW HALF AN HOUR OF ZOOM
CLASSES OR- WHATEVER HOW HOW DO
WE- WELL YOU KNOW WHAT ARE YOU
LOOKING AT IN TERMS OF JUST.
DEVELOPING SOME SENSE OF BROAD
STANDARDIZATION JUST KNOWING
THAT AGAIN THIS IS. JUST OF THE
ADEQUATE ABOUT THIS TIME PERIOD
WE UNDERSTAND THAT THIS ISN'T
THIS IS A STATE OF EMERGENCY.
IT'S JUST NOT IDEA FOR ANYBODY
IT AND GOING TO THE TEACHERS
ARE WORKING VERY HARD SO WE'RE
NOT. CAST IN ANY BLAME BUT I
THINK IT'S IN ORDER TO TALK
ABOUT LATER BUT- JUST HOW HOW
ARE YOU DEVELOPING GUIDANCE. TO
ALL THE COUNTY OFFICES AND- YOU
KNOW TO GIVE TO THEIR DISTRICTS
SO THAT THERE IS SOME SENSE OF.
STATE STANDARD AS ZETIAN
BECAUSE THERE SEEMS TO BE
ABSOLUTELY NONE AT THIS POINT.
THANK YOU SO THIS ACTUALLY
SPEAKS TO A LOT OF WHAT WILL BE
DISCUSSED IN UNDER ISSUE TO
WITH DISTANCE LEARNING I CAN
PROVIDE YOU A LITTLE BIT AND
TAKE BITS AROUND WHAT WE'VE
BEEN PROVIDING ON WHAT QUALITY
DISTANCE LEARNING LOOKS LIKE.
AND HOW IT CAN BE ADDRESSED
VERSUS LOW TECH YOU ALL THE WAY
UP THROUGH HIGH TECH OPTIONS
AND SO REALLY QUALITY DISTANCE
LEARNING IS ABOUT. CONNECTING
TEACHERS AND STUDENTS TOGETHER
THERE'S AN INTENTIONAL
CONNECTION THERE THE SECRETS OF
INSTRUCTION IS THOUGHTFUL
RELEVANT TO REAL WORLD
APPLICATION THE PRESENTATION OF
CONTENT USES MULTIPLE OUT.
DALLY THESE THAT THERE IS A
OPPORTUNITIES FOR STUDENTS CUT
TO COLLABORATE AND THERE'S ALSO
A FEEDBACK LOOP FOR STUDENTS ON
THEIR PROGRESS OF LEARNING AND
THAT CAN BE DONE THROUGH.
VARIOUS MODES YOUR PAPER
ASSIGNMENTS THROUGH THE PHONE-
AND THEN ALSO THROUGH AND
DEVICES AND SO. WITH HAVING A
LOCAL CONTROL STATE OUR GOAL
HERE IN THAT DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION IS TO SHOW THE BEST
PRACTICES AND WE'VE BEEN DOING
FROM THE VERY BEGINNING WITH
WEBINARS WHERE FIRST WEAPON ARE
ON INNOVATIONS FOR DISTANCE
LEARNING AND SPECIAL EDUCATION.
HAD OVER EIGHT THOUSAND
PARTICIPANTS AND NOW HAS OVER
SIXTY THOUSAND VIEWS AND THAT
WAS JUST OUR FIRST ONE WE BUILT
OUR CLIENTELE I SHOULD SAY AS
FAR AS I'M PARTICIPATING IN OUR
WEBINARS AND VIEWING THEM.
THROUGHOUT THIS PAST FIVE SIX
WEEKS AND SO WE ARE PROVIDING
DISTINCT TO GUIDANCE ON WHAT
QUALITY DISTANCE LEARNING IT
LOOKS LIKE WE'VE BEEN
PARTNERING WITH DISTRICTS ON
DISTRICTS BEST PRACTICES SO.
GLENDALE UNIFIED TO TELL MISS
UNIFIED SAN DIEGO UNIFIED HAVE
BEEN SHARING THEIR BEST
PRACTICES. SO ALTHOUGH. TO MAY
NOT HAVE THE DEVICE WE ARE
INCREASE SHOWING WAYS TO
CONNECT WITH STUDENTS AND TO
ENGAGE THEM HARDENING EVEN
WITHOUT A DEVICE. THOSE
FAMILIES THAT HAVE DEVICES THAT
I NEED THE TECHNICAL SUPPORT
WORKING WITH DISTRICTS TO
PROVIDE THAT TECHNICAL SUPPORT
TO BE ABLE TO HAVE A COMPANIES
ON WITHIN THE FAMILY AND HOW TO
ACCESS AND- AND YOU REALIZE THE
TECHNOLOGY THAT'S ON THE DEVICE
THAT WAS GIVEN TO THEM. SO WE
HAVE A WIDE RANGE OF GUIDANCE-
STATE SO ARE WE WANT TO ENSURE
THAT WE WHAT GUIDANCE WE
PROVIDE. A HIGHLIGHTS BEST
PRACTICES. AND UNDERSTAND THE
YOUR LOCAL CONTROL STATEMENT
WHAT ONE THING WE- WHAT WHAT
DID WE DO HAVE A STATE
STANDARD- ON IS THE NUMBER OF
HOURS OF SCHOOL. RIGHT IS THAT
IS THAT CORRECT A MAN CORRECT
ON THAT. THAT THAT IS ACTUALLY
THE ONLY MAN DATED TO CONTENT
AREA IS P. E. IT'S TWO HUNDRED
TEN MINUTES I'M EVERY TEN DAYS
WE DO HAVE INSTRUCTIONAL MINUTE
REQUIREMENTS THROUGHOUT THE
INSTRUCTIONAL YEAR BUT THAT WAS
ALL WAVED IT THROUGH THAT
INITIAL EXECUTIVE ORDER FROM
THE GOVERNOR. SO NOW IT'S JUST
TEACHERS ARE ENGAGING DISTANCE
LEARNING LOOKS A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENTLY. AT AT ONE LESSON
YOU COULD BE AN ISSUE WITH A
TEACHER CONNECTING WITH
STUDENTS IN DIFFERENT WAYS FOR
A CERTAIN AMOUNT OF MINUTES AND
THEN GIVING THEM TO SIGN IT TO
CONDUCT AFTER THAT INITIAL
CONNECTION WITH THE TEACHER
CONCLUDES AND THEN RETURNING
BACK AND SHARING THEIR
LEARNING. AND SO INSTRUCTIONAL
MINUTES WILL LOOK VERY
DIFFERENT SAY DIFFERENT AND A
DISTANCE LEARNING ENVIRONMENT.
THE END WE DON'T KNOW IF WE'RE
GONNA HAVE A DISTANCE LEARNING
ENVIRONMENT STARTING IN THE
NEXT FALL HI I HOPE WE DON'T
BUT WE MAY. IN IN GOING INTO
THAT. HI BUT HAVE YOU START TO
GRAPPLE WITH WHAT- WHAT
DISTANCE LEARNING MAY LOOK LIKE
IN THE FALL ON. YOUR SAY
WITHOUT HOURS BEING WAVED HER
WITHOUT YOU KNOW GO GO GOING
BACK TO MORE OF IT YOU DON'T.
HAVING THE MORE TRADITIONAL
GUIDELINES BUT DOING IT MORE
THROUGH DISTANCE LEARNING OR-
MAYBE YOU'RE DOING IT THROUGH
HALF DISTANCE LEARNING SO SOME
OF YOUR KIDS ARE COMING YOU'RE
ONLY HALF THE NUMBER OF KIDS.
IN THE SCHOOL PER DAY I DON'T I
DON'T I DON'T EVEN KNOW WHAT
THE DIFFERENT OPTIONS ARE BUT-
SEC ACTUALLY GETTING INTO A LOT
OF BY WHAT I'LL BE SHARING
UNDER ISSUE TO. AND TALK ABOUT
WE ARE WORKING WITH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WEBERAND CTA PRESIDENT
TO LEAD ON CO CHAIRING A
COMMITTEE THAT WILL FOCUS ON
DEVELOPING A PLAN THAT
ADDRESSES THE CONTINUITY OF
LEARNING. AND ADDRESSES ANY
LEARNING SITE THAT IT HAPPENED
DURING DISTANCE LEARNING WAS
AMPLIFIED DURING THE SUMMERTIME
AND ALL THROUGH THE LENS OF
EQUITY FOR EVERY STUDENTS. OKAY
PERVERT THE KNOWLEDGE NOT JUST
WAIT- FOR ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS
TELL THEM THAT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. OKAY. ANY FURTHER
QUESTIONS FOR THIS PANEL. YES
MISTER O'DONNELL I'VE JUST JUST
WANT ONE QUICK COMMENT WE
TALKED YOU KNOW PEOPLE TALK ON
WHAT CAN WE DO TODAY WELL I
KNOW STARTING NEXT WEEK ONE
THING WE CAN DO AS A BODY IS
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE NOT.
FORWARDING A LOT OF NEW POLICY
A LOT OF NEW LEGISLATION THAT
REQUIRES SCHOOLS TO DO A LOT
MORE THAN THEY ARE IN HERE ARE
DOING EVERY YEAR IS THAT IS THE
SIGNAL MISTER MISTER WHAT'S
NICE IS THAT A SIGNAL MISTER
ENGINEER ON YOUR PILLOW WELL I
MEAN A HUNDRED ABOUT A HUNDRED
FORTY BILLS THIS YEAR RIGHT
OKAY HAD BECAUSE ALREADY VERY
HIGH. AND MAYBE THIS YEAR WE
NEED TO TAKE A STEP BACK AND
REALIZE THAT SCHOOLS ARE UNDER
INTENSE PRESSURE TO PROVIDE
DISTANCE LEARNING EXCEDRIN AND
THERE'S GOING TO BE A SEVERE. I
OTHER BUDGET. PROBABLY GOING TO
BE SIGNIFICANT AND AS A BODY WE
NEED TO REALIZE THAT. SO WHEN
YOU SEE WHAT BILLS WE HEAR THIS
YEAR AND WHAT BILLS WE DON'T. I
JUST KNOW THAT THAT'S- PROBABLY
SOME OF THE THINKING GOING ON
BEHIND THE COMMITTEE. BACK YOU
MISTER CHAIR FAIR ENOUGH FAIR
ENOUGH. OKAY THANK YOU I WILL
NOW GO ON TO OUR NEXT ISSUE OUR
NEXT PANEL. IN THIS- FRANKLY IS
THE MEAT OF TODAY'S
CONVERSATION. AS WE TALK ABOUT
WHAT'S REALLY HAPPENING ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. WITH DISTANCE
LEARNING AND OUR COMMUNITIES
AND IT'S NOT ALWAYS- APPLES.TO
APPLES. AND SPECIFICALLY HOW WE
CAN MITIGATE LEARNING LOS
ACROSS CALIFORNIA. SO WE HAVE
A- PANEL OF- QUITE A FEW
PRESENTERS WE GIVE EVERYBODY A
TIME LIMIT TO. A FIVE MINUTES
IS THAT CORRECT MISS CABLE.
FIVE MINUTES PER PRESENTER.
SELF WEEKEND- LINE UP AND
STARTS. AND START THIS- PANEL
SO WE'LL START OFF WITH
STEPHANIE GREGSON DEPARTMENT OF
ADD LINDA DARLING HAMMOND THE
STATE BOARD OF EDUCATION.
HEATHER HUGH WITH THAT PACE
JESSICA HOLMES DEAL LAUGH
DARRYL CAMP. WITH THE SAN
LORENZO UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
ALSO REPRESENTED ACCESS. TO BE
BUOYED WE HEARD ABOUT EARLIER-
CTA RAP ALSO FROM OUR LOCAL ELK
GROVE SCHOOL DISTRICT- DOCTOR
AT LEAST SHODDY I GOT WITH AT
TRUST WEST AND LEAH. DERA FROM
CALIFORNIA PTA. OKAY THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU
THIS IS STEPHANIE GREAT SINCE
YOU'VE DEPUTY SUPERINTENDENT OF
PUBLIC INSTRUCTION THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN MCCARTY IN ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK AND SHARE WITH YOU TODAY.
WITH ME I HAVE SEEN CO TWO IS
OUR DIRECTOR OF THE CURRICULUM
FRAMEWORKS INSTRUCTIONAL
RESOURCES DIVISION INVESTING
OUR LEAD WITH ME ON ALL
DISTANCE LEARNING. I THINK WE
CAN ALL AGREE RAN AN
UNPRECEDENTED TIME WHERE NOW
MORE THAN EVER WE ONLY-
STRONGER IT FOR WORKING
TOGETHER. MARCH THIRTEENTH
BEGAN A QUICK PIVOT TO
SUPPORTING STUDENTS THROUGH
DISTANCE LEARNING ENVIRONMENT
NOT ONLY FOR LOCAL EDUCATION
AGENCIES BUT FOR THE CD AS
WELL. WE'VE HAD A DISTRACTION A
FORMAL CONTENT DELIVERY BUT THE
LEARNING HASN'T STOPPED.
QUALITY DISTANCE LEARNING AS I
MENTIONED BEFORE IT MEANS
LEARNING AND INSTRUCTION ARE
HAPPENING EVEN WHEN THE STUDENT
AND TEACHER ARE IN DIFFERENT
PLACES LOCATIONS. ALL LEARNING
INCLUDES AN INTENTIONAL TEACHER
AND STUDENT CONNECTIONS.
SEQUENCE INSTRUCTION GROUNDED
IN THE STANDARDS AND PROVIDES
RELEVANT AND MEANINGFUL. REAL
WORLD AT. KIND IS PRETTY USING
MULTIPLE TYPES OF MODALITIES
STUDENTS HAVE OPPORTUNITIES TO
COLLABORATE WITH PEERS AND
THERE'S A FEEDBACK LOOP TO
CHECK FOR LEARNING AND
UNDERSTANDING. WELL THE
DISTANCE LEARNING CAN UTILIZE
ANY DIFFERENT LOW TECH TO HIGH
TECH TOOLS RANGING FROM PAPER
ASSIGNMENTS TO AN ONLINE
LEARNING MANAGEMENT. OR WITH
OVER 95% OF OUR SCHOOLS PIVOTED
TO DISTANCE LEARNING WE HAVE
SOME EXAMPLES OF BEST PRACTICES
INCLUDING A DISTANCE LEARNING
PLAN THE SAN DIEGO UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT A BALLOT AND
YOU CAN SEE THAT ON THEIR
WEBSITE. WE ALSO HAVE TEACHERS
THAT ARE UTILIZING THIS
OPPORTUNITY YOU STUDENTS LIVED
EXPERIENCES AN EXISTING
KNOWLEDGE FURTHER ENHANCE THEIR
DISTANCE LEARNING EXPERIENCES.
FOR EXAMPLES. TEACHERS ARE
ASKING STUDENTS TO CREATIVELY
DOCUMENTS EXPERIENCES DURING
THIS TIME. SHARING WITH THE
CLASSES AND MAKING CONNECTIONS
TO SCIENCE MATH LANGUAGE AND
MUCH MORE. JUST BORDER LOCAL
EDUCATION AGENCIES OVER THE
PAST SIX WEEKS. WEEKS WEEK THIS
CD AIR FOR. INSTANCE PORT SO
BOLD AND- IS WE HAVE A SITE
THAT HOUSES A PLETHORA OF
RESOURCES AND SPECIFIC. ON
DISTANCE LEARNING THAT INCLUDES
KEY ELEMENTS OF WHAT DISTANCE
LEARNING CAN LOOK LIKE READING
BASS BEST PRACTICES AND MUCH
MORE WE ALSO PROVIDED WEAPON.
IN AVERAGE OF THREE A WEEK
RIGHT NOW FOCUSED ON INNOVATION
FOR DISTANCE. NOT ONLY SPECIAL
EDUCATION BUT FOR ENGLISH
LEARNERS. SINCE BEST. AND I
MENTAL. WE UNDERSTANDING THAT
THIS IS NOT AN EASY TIME ANY OF
US AND THE MENTAL HEALTH AND
WELL BEING OF OUR STUDENTS
FAMILIES AND EDUCATORS IS
CRITICAL. WE THEN BATTED SOCIAL
EMOTIONAL ELEMENTS THROUGHOUT
ALL OF OUR GREAT IN SUPPORT AND
THIS WEEK WE ARE BEGINNING A
PARENT SUPPORT CIRCLES WE'LL BE
STARTING EDUCATOR AND STUDENT
SUPPORT CIRCLES IN THE COMING.
WEEKS RESPONSE IN HAVE A TO
DISTANCE ARE HAS A- OUR
EXISTING. INCLUDING THE DIVIDE.
OUR STATE SHE BRINGS UP AND TOM
BERMAN FROM THE BEGINNING HAS
MADE MEETING STUDENTS BASIC
MEANS AND ENSURING EQUITABLE
ACCESS TO LEARNING RESOURCES
PRIORITY. AND NOW THIS INCLUDES
EQUITY IN DISTANCE LEARNING. HE
BEGAN ADDITIONAL TASK FORCE
THAT IS CO CHAIRED. BY SENATOR
CONNIE LEIVA AND INCLUDES
SENATOR MCGUIRE ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS IDR CURRY WOULD
SANTIAGO GARCIA AND BURKE THE
TASK FORCE MEMBERS REFLECT
THOSE COMMUNITIES WITH GREATEST
CONNECTIVITY NEEDS ARE USING
DATA COLLECTED BY THE SEAT TO
PINPOINT CONNECTIVITY ISSUES
ISSUE AREAS AND LOCAL EDUCATION
AGENCIES THAT HAVE STUDENT TO
NEEDED VICES. I'M THIS WORK WE
HAVE IDENTIFIED THE NEED FOR
OVER FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND
DEVICES AT OVER TWO HUNDRED AND
NINETY THOUSAND HOT SPOT. LAST
WEEK THE TASK FORCE HELD A FACT
FINDING SESSIONS WITH THE CEOS
OF INTERNET SERVICE PROVIDERS
TO DISCUSS HOW WE CAN ADDRESS
ACTIVITY HERE. THE TASK FOR
DELIVERED A MESSAGE THE I. S.
P.'S SHOULD BE PROVIDING FREE
WIFI TO LOW INCOME FAMILIES WE
KNOW THAT BROADBAND
CONNECTIVITY NEEDS TO FLOW LIKE
TRISTA ELECTRICITY FOR ALL OUR
STUDENTS. OUR STATE
SUPERINTENDENT HAS AMPLIFIED A
CALL TO ACTION FOR DONATIONS OF
DEVICES AND FUNDS TO PURCHASE
DEVICES EVEN CREATING A
DEDICATED EMAIL DONATE TACK AT
CD E. DOT CA DOC I HAVE WE HAVE
SOME OF OUR DONATIONS THAT WILL
BE DISTRIBUTED TO. DISTRICTS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE THIS WEEK.
OTHER GAP AREAS HAVE ALSO BEEN
INTENSIFIED DURING THIS TIME
AND WE ACKNOWLEDGE A LEARNING
SITE IS INEVITABLE FOR MANY OF
OUR STUDENTS. IN FACT THE AND
W. EA RECENTLY RELEASED
PRODUCTIONS AT THE SUMMER MELT
WILL BE AMPLIFIED AND SUGGESTS
IMPOSSIBLE IMPACTS MAYBE LARGER
IN MATHEMATICS AND IN READING.
THIS MERE IS THE CURRENT STATE
DATA THAT ALREADY SHOW THIS GAP
BETWEEN SUBJECT AREAS. WE ALSO
RECEIVE MANY QUESTIONS
REGARDING STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES AND THE
EFFECTIVENESS LEARNING IS
HAVING ON THEIR LEARNING GROW.
THIS SPEAKS TO THE IMPORTANCE
OF CREATING A PLAN FOR
ADDRESSING ALL STUDENTS NEEDS.
HE MET WHERE THEY ARE AND
EFFECTIVELY HAND ENHANCING
THEIR EARNING AN UNDERSTANDING
TO MOVE THEM FORWARD IT IS WHY
AS I MENTIONED PREVIOUSLY WE'VE
COMMIT DEVELOPED A COMMITTEE
THAT'S CO CHAIRED BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WEBER. AND ARE SEE EACH
YEAR PRESIDENT SHALL BE VOID IT
WILL FOCUS ON DEVELOPING A PLAN
TO ADDRESS THIS LEARNING LAST
REAL LENDS AN EQUITY FOR EVERY
STUDENTS. I'D LIKE TO CONCLUDE
KNOWLEDGE IN THE WHAT ARE LOCAL
EDUCATION AGENCIES HAVE
ACCOMPLISHED INCLUDING TO
DISTANCE LEARNING ON A DIME
NOTHING SHORT OF AMAZING. WE
KNOW THERE ARE CHALLENGES AND
THINGS ARE NOT PERFECT BUT OUR
STUDENTS ARE LEARNING AND OUR
TEACHERS ARE LEARNING AS WELL
WE'RE IN A NEW PLACE TO TAKE
THESE NEW LEARNINGS AND APPLY
THEM TO WHAT SCHOOL CAN LOOK
LIKE IN THE FUTURE. WE
UNDERSTAND THAT WHAT WE ARE
EXPERIENCING IS UNPRECEDENTED
AND IT HAS AMPLIFIED ALREADY
EXISTING GAPS BY LEARNING
TOGETHER PROBLEM SOLVING
TOGETHER AND WORKING TOGETHER%
ALL OUR STUDENTS WILL BENEFIT.
OUR TEAM IS AVAILABLE TO
SUPPORT YOU AND BE THOUGHT
PARTNERS AS WE CAN SEE YOU TO
SERVE OUR STUDENTS ROSS
AVAILABLE TO ANSWER QUESTIONS
TODAY. YOU. OKAY LINDA DARLING
HAMMOND. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THE CHAIR MCCARTY AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE I APPRECIATE
BEING PART OF THIS HEARING
YOU'RE ASKING EXACTLY THE RIGHT
QUESTIONS AT THE RIGHT TIME I
IT IS CRITICAL THAT WE THINK
NOW ABOUT HOW TO MITIGATE
LEARNING LOS UP AND THIS IS A
TIME NOT ONLY CRISIS BUT OF
OPPORTUNITY A BECAUSE IT'S PUT
A FLASHLIGHT ON MANY OF THE
LONG STANDING EQUITY AND
ACHIEVEMENT GAPS AND IT GIVES
US THE URGENCY IN FOCUS. NEEDED
TO PULL TOGETHER SOLUTIONS FOR
CLOSING THOSE GAPS AND RE
IMAGINING OUR SYSTEM OF PUBLIC
EDUCATION SO WE EMERGE WITH THE
MORE INNOVATIVE AND EQUITABLE
SYSTEM I WANTED OF THAT
CALIFORNIA HAS A BETTER START
ON THESE GOALS THE MANY OTHER
STATES THAT CLOSE SCHOOLS DONE
NOTHING TO CONTINUE EDUCATION
FOR THEIR STUDENTS. AND THOSE
OF STATES THAT THE END OF NEW
NAY REPORT THAT'S BEEN
REFERENCED ARE IS REALLY
TALKING ABOUT DISTRICTS OF
COURSE VERY DID HOW THEY MANAGE
TO INITIAL CLOSURES- BUT A 100%
OF THEM ARE NOW ENGAGED IN
FORMAL DISTANCE LEARNING AND
YOU'VE HEARD FROM. THANKS ABOUT
THAT SIGNET IN A- REMAIN AND TO
ADDRESS THOSE. I THINK WE NEED
TO AT LEAST FIVE THINGS. FIRST
AND FOREMOST WE NEED TO CLOSE
THE DIGITAL DIVIDE. WHEN THE
PANDEMIC BEGAN ABOUT ONE IN
FIVE STUDENTS WERE ESTIMATED TO
LACK DEVICES ARE CONNECTIVITY
OF ALL. FOR THE ROAD EFFORTS OF
MANY DISTRICTS LARGE AND SMALL.
FROM LOS ANGELES TO TINY LITTLE
ALL POP. DEEP INTO THEIR
RESERVES TO BY HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF COMPUTERS AND HOT
SPOTS. I THINK THAT IT'S A WE
PROBABLY CUT THE DIGITAL DIVIDE
BY ABOUT HALF. OF ACCORDING TO
THE MOST RECENT TICKET MASTER
SURVEY NINETY SIX PERCENT. OF
DISTRICTS ARE PROVIDING JUST
DEVICES JUST STUDENTS. AND 86%
ARE PROVIDING HOT SPOTS- IN
SOME FASHION. IN ABOUT 7% OF
OUR DISTRICTS VIRTUALLY ALL
STUDENTS HAVE. ACCESS TO THE
CRISIS. IN ABOUT SIXTY. THIRD
DISTRICTS VIRTUALLY ALL
STUDENTS HAVE ACCESS TO
CONNECTIVITY THIS IS MUCH
BETTER THAN IT WAS A COUPLE OF
MONTHS AGO HOWEVER. IN ABOUT
ONE FIVE DISTRICTS AT LEAST 30%
OF STUDENTS. LACK ACCESS TO
CONNECTIVITY YOUR DEVICES.
OFTEN WILL START ALL AND RURAL
DISTRICTS. BUT THE DIGITAL
DIVIDE EXISTS ACROSS ALL KINDS
OF DISTRICTS IN THE STATE. THE
GOVERNOR FIRST PARTNER STATE
SUPERINTENDENT AND I HAVE BEEN
WORKING TO RAISE PRIVATE
DONATIONS. FROM CORPORATIONS OF
FOUNDATIONS TO CLOSE THIS
DIVIDE. WE RECEIVED SOME
IMPRESSIVE CONTRIBUTIONS BUT IT
IS NOT ENOUGH. EVEN WITH THESE
ONGOING EFFORTS WILL NEED AT
LEAST A HUNDRED. DOLLARS TO
ENSURE THAT THE CLOSE THE
DIVIDE AND CHANGE. ACCESS FOR
STUDENTS- AND THAT'S BASED ON
AN ESTIMATE OF YOU KNOW THREE
HUNDRED. DOLLARS TO PROVIDE
THE- CHROMEBOOK AT YOURS. HI
THIS. WE ARE A FEW WEEKS
ALREADY MENTIONED THE THAT
SUMMER EFFORTS JUST OF WORDING
A WILL IN OFFER NEED TO BE WE
TO ADJUST THE PATEL CLOSE AGAIN
I THE FALL WINTER IF ANOTHER
THERE WERE LAW TO SEE THE OF
BLOOD LEARNING EVEN ONE SCHOOLS
ARE OPEN IN ORDER TO SUPPORT
SOCIAL DISTANCING AND STUDENTS
REMAINING WARRANTY AND TO
PRESERVE SAFETY- THERE ARE SOME
THOUGHTS ABOUT. RESERVING
SOCIAL DISTANCING BY HAVING
SOME KIDS ON DIGITAL LEARNING
SOME DAYS A WEEK WHILE OTHERS
ARE IN SCHOOL AND THEN INTO
REVERSING STUFF UP
PARTICIPATIONIN PHYSICAL AND
DIGITAL LEARNING UP FOR
LEARNING TO BE CONTINUES TO
REALLY NEEDS OF ALL STUDENTS
AND FAMILIES FULLY ACTIVE I
JUST WOULD LIKE TO DOUBT THAT
THIS IS ALSO IMPORTANT TO THE
SAME LOW INCOME FAMILIES OKAY
WAS PARTICIPATING TELEHEALTH
SECURE BENEFITS APPLY FOR
EMPLOYMENT OR PROTECT THEIR
HEALTH I SHOPPING ONLINE. AND
WE NEED TO HAVE ALL STUDENTS
TECHNOLOGICALLY PROFICIENT IN A
STATE WHERE TECHNOLOGY IS THE
DRIVER OF THE ENEMY WHEN THEY
TO YOU THE SUMMER WELL SECOND
POINT IN ORDER TO PROVIDE
SUPPORT STUDENTS WERE LIKELY TO
OFFER THIS BEHIND LOS LEARNER
STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES
ALMOST STUDENTS OTHERS WERE NOT
ABLE TO ACCESS INSTRUCTION ON
MANY DISTRICTS ARE MAKING PLANS
TO DO THIS SEVERAL COMPANIES
ARE WORKING WITH EXPERT
TEACHERS. DESIGN CURRICULAR
MATERIALS THAT CAN BE USED
ONLINE IF NEEDED AND
COLLABORATION WITH THE C. C.
SOME ACCEPTS BECAUSE CONTINUE
CONSTRUCTION AS THE ROLE OF THE
SCHOOL YEAR OKAY THE NEXT EARLY
RESPONSE STUDENTS TOOK YOUR
NEED TO MAXIMIZE THEIR PROGRESS
THIRD WE NEED TO HELP
INSTRUCTIONAL CONTINUITY PUT
EVERY DISTRICT THAT PROVIDED
THE HEARING REGULAR ON THAT OF
IS GROUNDED IN OUR CURRICULUM
FRAMEWORKS WITH IN PERSON AND
DISTANCE LEARNING RESOURCES AT
EVERY GRADE. LEVEL FOR ALL
STUDENTS INCLUDING INCORPORATE.
THOSE PLANS ARE YOU FOR
STUDENTS WHO JUST. NOT ONLY
BECAUSE WE HAVE TO TOGGLE
BETWEEN BEING. OPEN AND CLOSE
POTENTIALLY WALK BUT IS ISSUE
BUT ALSO TO SUPPORT LONG TERM
SCHOOL EXPERIENCING. WHAT WE
HAVE OTHER NATURAL DISASTERS
LIKE WILD FIRES THAT MADE FOR
SCHOOL CLOSURES. ARE WITH THE
PROSPECT OF CLIMATE RELATED
CHALLENGES GROWING WE NEED TO
PLAN FOR FLEXIBILITY IN THE
PLACE OF THE MORNING BUT NOT
THE PROSPECTS FOR LEARNING. SO
THAT WE'RE NOT CONFRONTING
LEARNING LOS REGULARLY. WHEN WE
BEGAN TO PULL TOGETHER
RESOURCES. FOR THE- STATE BOARD
AND CDC GUIDANCE TO DISTRICTS
ONE OF THE FIRST I THOUGHT
WHAT'S STRONG RESOURCES AND
CONTINUITY PLANS WAS MIAMI DADE
COUNTY FLORIDA. BECAUSE THEY
HAVE NOW HAD FLOODS AND
HURRICANES REGULARLY AND THEY
ARE NOW PREPARED TO GO IN AND
OUT OF SCHOOL I IN A SEAMLESS
WAY WE NEED THAT SAME. AS THE-
STATE CAN SUPPORT THIS EFFORT
WITH AWFUL CURRICULUM RESOURCES
AND TRAINING- AND WE ALSO NEED
TO MOVE TOWARDS A COMPETENCY
BASED APPROACH THAT IS NOT
FOCUSED ONLY ON STEEP TIME. AS
THE MEASURE OF INSTRUCTIONAL-
ENGAGEMENT. FOR ONE SCHOOL WE
WILL TO TAKE OF STUDENTS
LEARNING NEED BUT THERE'S- MOST
AND ACADEMIC. WE SHOULD WITH
THE IMPORTANCE OF RELATIONSHIPS
SOME EXPERTS HAVE ADVISED THAT
STUDENTS SHOULD RETURNS THE
STUDENTS THAT THEY HAVE THIS
PAST YEAR- WHO KNOW THEM AND
THEIR FAMILIES TO UNDERSTAND
THEIR LEARNING NEEDS AND
APPROACHES. OR BEST POSITIONS
TO WELCOME THEM WITH
UNDERSTANDING AND COMPASSION TO
DIAGNOSE WHERE THEY ARE IN
THEIR LIVES AND THEIR LEARNING
TO CONNECT THEM THE NECESSARY
SOCIAL SERVICES AND MENTAL
HEALTH RESOURCES WHERE THOSE
ARE NEEDED. AND TO HELP THEM
MAKE RAPID PROGRESS WE DO HAVE
RESEARCH THAT CONTINUITY AND
STUDENT TEACHER RELATIONSHIPS
BRINGS SIGNIFICANT GAINS IN
ACHIEVEMENT BECAUSE TEACHERS
CAN TEACH MORE EFFECTIVELY
WOMEN OTHER STUDENTS WELL AND
STUDENTS LEARN MORE
EFFECTIVELY. IN AN ENVIRONMENT
OF TRUST OF THE LONGING- SOME
EXPERTS THINK OF THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT WILL BE DONE FOR
A QUARTER BEFORE PASSING
STUDENTSON TO THE NEXT GRADE
LEVEL TEACHER. OTHER SCHOOLS
MIGHT DECIDE TO DO THAT IN A
LOOPING FASHION FOR THE WHOLE
YEAR WHILE ALSO NATURE EVALUATE
WHERE STUDENTS ARE ACADEMICALLY
A WE WILL NEED TO USE OUR WHAT
WE HAVE AVAILABLE- REGULAR
CLASSROOM DIAGNOSTIC
ASSESSMENTS IN MANY GRADES.
WERE ALSO FORTUNATE TO HAVE
RESOURCES OF. BROWN'S ASSESSED
THAT ARE REALLY WILL. SOLVE
JUST. THESE CAN BE YOU IN. WAYS
AROUND THE CIVIC AREAS OF THE
CURRICULUM OR IN AN ASSESSMENT
THAT. MIRRORS WHAT WOULD HAVE
BEEN DONE THE- END OF YOUR TEST
UP ACROSS THE ENTIRE.
CURRICULUM FOR THAT GRADE LEVEL
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE THINK OF
THIS AS A DIAGNOSTIC PROCESS
NOT AS A WAY TO LABEL STUDENTS-
OR THE FISSION SEIZE OR OR
GRADE RETENTION WHICH HAS.
TYPICALLY BEEN FOUND NOT NOT TO
WORK AND WHEN STUDENTS.
STIGMATIZING LABEL IT ACTUALLY
AFFECTS THEIR FUTURE WORDING SO
WE NEED TO THINK ABOUT BURNING
PROGRESS BEING SUPPORTED. THE
LABELING STUDENTS BEING THE
PRIMARY GOAL OF THOSE
ASSESSMENTS AND FINALLY TO MEET
STUDENT LEARNING NEEDS WE NEED
TO FOCUS ON EXPAND OR LEARNING
TIME AN OPPORTUNE. AS WELL AS
ON SOCIAL EMOTIONAL AND MENTAL
HEALTH SUPPORTS THOSE EXPANDED
LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES MIGHT
INCLUDE INTENSIVE LITERACY AND
MATH INSTRUCTION WITHIN ALL
TEACHERS SYSTEMS OF SUPPORT.
AND EXPADED LEARNING TIME THAT
MAY BE CREATED BY SUMMER SCHOOL
STARTED THIS FOR YOUR EARLIER
ANY AFTER SCHOOL OR SATURDAYS
FULL TIME. OR RETHINKING HOW
SCHEDULES WITH OF THE SCHOOL
YEAR. THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
RETIREMENT INSTRUCTIONAL
APPROACHES THAT USE THAT WE
KNOW ARE EFFECTIVE IN PRODUCING
WRONG LEARNING GAMES QUICKLY IN
THE STATE SHOULD PROVIDE BOTH
INFORMATION ABOUT EFFECTIVE
STRATEGIES ARE RESOURCES TO
ACCESS THEM AND THEN WE NEED TO
BE PREPARED TO SUPPORT STUDENTS
PHYSICAL AND MENTAL HEALTH AND
SOCIAL EMOTIONAL LEARNING WHICH
ARE VERY LARGE FFECTS. ON
ACADEMIC ACHIEVEMENT AS WELL
AND ONE STRATEGY MAY BE
LEVERAGING COMMUNITY PARTNERS
AS SAN FRANCISCO UNIFIED HAS
DONE. WITH TWO HUNDRED
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
AND OTHER DISTRICTS ARE DOING
AS WELL WE'RE SEEING THEIR
PLACES THAT HAVE COMMUNITY
SCHOOL STRATEGY. EXCUSE ME
THAT- DO- IN A GREAT PHYSICAL
AND MENTAL HEALTH SUPPORTS IN.
ARE ABLE TO MEET STUDENTS NEEDS
WERE OFFICIALLY WE MAY WANT TO-
URGE THOSE STRATEGIES IN THE
FUTURE. FIRST CARE SECTOR WILL
BE A SECOND ONE THAT'S
CURRENTLY BEING DRAFTED
WASHINGTON DC. AND WE NEED TO
BE. ABLE TO AFFECT THE
PURPOSEFUL USE THOSE WORDS WAS.
OKAY CHECK IT QUESTIONS LATER
THANK YOU. NEXT PANELIST. HEY
OTHER HELP FIND THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF HEAT HELLO OUR FOR
CALIFORNIA EDUCATION THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR HAVING ME THANK. WE
HAVE LOCAL AGENTS HAD US WERE
IN. I EIGHT SEVEN WILL BE
LOOKING FOR ENTRY AND RECOVERY
AND ALSO MY HERE TODAY BRAND
LOOKING HAVE ALL. AND FOR YOU
TO MAKE THE FOLLOWING REFER.
WHY IS THAT STUDENTS LIKELY
WITH AND LEARN LOS AS A RESULT.
SINCE YOU DID NINETEEN. THE
SECOND IS THAT WE MUST THIS WAY
OF THIS BACK AND YEAH. YEAH MY
NAME BRAND WALL OTHER ON.
MOMENT AND THE THIRD THAT
SCHOOLS WILL BE RESOURCE AND
FLEXIBILITY ME BACK WILL.
ANSWER OKAY. AND IT. ALL START
WHAT THE RESEARCH. STUDENTS AND
SOME GREAT RETURN AND ALL
TWENTY A FULL YEAR I AM. IN
NORMAL ISSUE. AND THAT'S JUST
THE AVERAGE CONTINUING TO. WE
ALL KNOW THAT SO CALLED SUMMER.
IS WORSE FOR LOW INCOME. IF
THEY'RE NOT LIKELY HIGHER
INCOME HERE'S HAVE A GREAT
DENNY HONOR. FURTHERMORE WE
SHOULD EXPECT IT YEAH GROW IS
OR IS IN NINETEEN SIXTY ARE
BEING IMPACT BY THE- VERY TO
WAYS. IT'S NOT PARTICULARLY
EFFECTIVE MEETING THE NEEDS TO
LEARN ENGLISH IT IS WITH THE
LADIES FIRST THAT WERE ALREADY.
AND NEEDING TARGET WORK THIS
CRISIS ALSO MEAN THAT MANY ARE.
VERY DIFFICULT CONDITIONS IN
THEIR HOMES IT DIRE CASES
STUDENTS WILL HAVE EXPERIENCED.
AS ISSUES OF POVERTY HOUSING
ACT. WHAT INSECURITY ARE
COMPOUNDED BY LOSS IN USE AND
WE KNOW BOTH THE HELP AND I CAN
IMPACT THAT WILL GET NINETEEN
HAVE. IF LOW INCOME AFRICAN
AMERICAN AND BLACK AND. IT WILL
BE IN BURIED DO WE NEED A TO
WITH THIS IN A TEACHER PLAN.
ACTION WHICH BRINGS ME TO MY
FACT POINT WE MUST DEVELOP A
SYSTEM WAY OF ASSESSING THE ACT
AND WOMAN NEEDS IT IS WHEN THEY
ENTERS. IT ENOUGH TO KNOW THAT
WILL BE BEHIND GRADE LEVEL
AFTER WE STUDENTS INTEREST WILL
WE NEED ACADEMIC THIS. THAT TO
THE- WHICH EACH OTHER HAS
ACQUIRE. AND WHAT SKILLS
CLINTON EACH STUDENT WILL NEED
TO TALK. ME IS NEED TO MAKE. AT
MULTIPLE. RIGHT NOW. AS YOU
KNOW EACH YEAR THE SMARTER
BALANCED ASSESSMENT CONSORTIUM
I THANK TESTIFIED IF YOU'RE TO
CALIFORNIA STUDENT IN THE- NOT
MINISTER. TEST HAS BEEN
DEVELOPED TO BE TIGHTLY ONLINE
RIGHT CALIFORNIA CONTENT
STANDARDS IT SEEMS LIKE SOME
MODIFICATIONS BUT THE THING I
MEANT. HE USED TO DEVELOP AN F.
DIAGNOSTIC PERHAPS BUILDING
LINE- SOME OF THE SAVINGS THAT
WE NEED IN THE SPRING. AND ALSO
NEED TO BE DEVELOPED TO TAKE
STOCK OF STUDENTS SOCIAL
EMOTIONAL AND ASSESS THEIR
GENERAL WELL BEING I THINK HER
FOOD AND HOUSING SECURITY SENSE
OF LONGING AND YET WHO READY TO
LEARN AND PHYSICAL AND MENTAL
HEALTH NEEDS ONCE YOU CAN
EITHER UNDERSTOOD. SCHOOL EAT
THEM WHICH BRINGS ME TO MY
THERE. ALSO A FREE FOR AND TO
MEET THE HEIGHTENED. CERTAIN
CONTACT INTERNET YEAR NONE OF
US KNOWS AT WHAT SCHOOL LOOK
LIKE A THE FALL THEY THAT'S IT
ALL THAT MUCH BUT WE DO KNOW IT
WILL DIFFERENT IT BEFORE THE.
THE GOVERNOR HAS ANNOUNCED AND
WILL BE ANNOUNCING READER YEAH
I THINK MORE AT SCHOOL BE
PREPARED TO READ DESIGNED TO
SUPPORT SOCIAL THE THING YOU'RE
AT THE- LEARNING. BUT EVEN
BEYOND THIS WILL MAKE ME SHIFT
ME IF I'M- LEVELS. HE.
HEALTHCARE BY PROVIDE GUIDANCE
THE CITY YOUR EXPECTATIONS AS
WELL AS OFFERING BACK IN SCHOOL.
HI RICK. I THANK THE STAFFING
LEVELS WE ALSO NEED THAT HEALTH
AND THEN HEALTH PROFESSIONALS
YOUR SCHOOL OUR STATE. AND I'M
THE ITEMS. HE PERHAPS NO
IMPORTANT WE NEED TO PROTECT
FUNDING FOR. AND THE SURE TERM
THINK THIS FUNDING AT ABOUT.
YEAH LEVEL SHIELDING RIGHT
EDUCATION GRANTS FORGET.
EVERYTHING REFERRAL AND ANYONE
IN FUNDS ON SCHOOL. STUDENTS
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND I
LOOK FORWARD TO ANSWERING ANY.
OKAY THANK YOU CAN. OKAY MINE.
HELLO MY NAME IS TERREL CAMP I
AM CURRENTLY THE SUPERINTENDENT
AND THE SAN LORENZO UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT AND I AM ALSO
VERY ACTIVE WITH THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA%
SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS ATTACK
GIVE YOU AN IDEA ABOUT WHAT
WHAT'S BEEN HAPPENING TO THE
BOOTS ON THE GROUND OUR
DISTRICT HAS BEEN VERY MUCH
INVOLVED IN IN JUST WHAT YOU'VE
HEARD FROM THE OTHER PANELISTS
OUR MAJOR FOCUS HAS BEEN ON
MAIL DISTRIBUTION FOR STUDENTS
DURING THAT FIRST WEEK IN NOW
THAT WE'RE DOING. THERE IN
CONSISTENT BASIS OUR OUR
TRANSITION HAS BEEN WHAT I WHAT
WE NEED TO DO TO MAKE SURE WE
GET DEVICESIN THE HANDS OF OUR
STUDENTS. AND STUFF WE OFTEN
TALK ABOUT HOW STUDENTS NEED
VICE AS WELL WE'VE DISCOVERED
THAT A NUMBER PRESS STAFF
ACTUALLY NEED DEVICES AND CAN
ACTIVITY AS WELL. THAT'S BEEN A
MAJOR FOCUS AND RIGHT ALONG
WITH THAT WE'VE BEEN PROVIDING
A NUMBER OF PROFESSIONAL
LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES- OUR OUR
OUR STAFF IS WE'RE
TRANSITIONING TO. DELIVERING
INSTRUCTION DIFFERENTLY THAN
WHAT WE HAVE BEFORE OBVIOUSLY
RIGHT ALONG WITH THAT
PROFESSIONAL LEARNING AS BEEN
EMPHASIZING THAT OUR OUR STAFF
NEEDS TO CONNECT WITH STUDENTS.
THE PANDEMIC IN IN THE POST
FOCUS OUR FIRST FORMAL SOCIAL
AND EMOTIONAL SIDE OF THINGS. I
RECOGNIZING THAT OUR STUDENTS
ARE IN A PLACE THAT THEY
HAVEN'T BEEN. BEEN BEFORE AND
WE JUST RECENTLY DEVELOPED-
IMHO YOU WITH OUR TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION THAT FURTHER
CLARIFIED TO EXPECTATIONS FOR
STAFF. AND STUDENTS AND WHAT
WILL GRADING LOOK LIKE FOR THE
FOURTH QUARTER. IN ORDER OF OUR
SCHOOL. SO IT'S BEEN A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF JEFF THAT
IS JUST WORKING WITH
PROFESSIONAL SO SHE THINK.
EXPECT ALL RIGHT ALONG WITH
THAT WE'RE STARTING AS WE WIND
DOWN THIS SCHOOL YEAR WHERE
SPENDING SOME TIME NOW THINKING
ABOUT THE POSSIBILITIES FOR THE
FALL WHEN OR IF SCHOOL IS RE
OPENING OBVIOUSLY SOME. THAT
YOU'VE HEARD ABOUT OUR WHT WE
HAVE TO DO TO YOU PROVIDED
DESKTOP RUSHED A STRUCTURE FOR
LEARNING TO OCCUR I THAT MIGHT
MEAN AND PROBABLY WILL BE IN A
DEVELOPING STRUCTURES WHERE
WE'RE PRACTICING PHYSICAL
DISTANCE THING. HAVING NO MORE
THAN A CERTAIN AMOUNT OF
STUDENTS IN A CLASSROOM IF
YOU'RE TRYING TO KEEP STUDENTS
SIX FEET APART AS STUDENTS
ATTENDING SCHOOL- MAYBE NET
FIVE TIMES A WEEK BUT MAYBE ONE
TO THREE TIMES A WEEK.
DEPENDING ON THE STUDENTS AND
THEIR ARRANGEMENT SO IN IN
SUMMARY IT'S ONLY IT'S- LOOKING
TO HAVE AN EIGHTY ONE FEATHER
ONE RID THE KIDS OUT OF OUR
STUDENTS ON CAMPUS OR IN
CLASSES AT ANY PARTICULAR TIME
ALSO EXPLORING CONCEPTS LIKE
BLENDED MODELS THAT WE ARE.
IT'S PART THE TIME THAT
STUDENTS BEEN WITH THOSE WILL
BE ACTUALLY IN THE SCHOOLS AND
IN THE CLASSES IN PART OF IT
WILL CONTINUE TO BE ONLINE. AND
THEN JUST PREPARING FOR WHAT
WOULD IT UNEXPECTED CLOSURES
LOOK LIKE IN THE EVENT THAT WE
HAVE EIGHT COMMUNITIES SPREAD
HER SCHOOL WIDE CASES OF. OF
CONFIRMED CASES OF KOBE
NINETEEN SO WHAT WOULD THAT
LOOK. LIKE FOR OUR SCHOOL
SYSTEM WERE NET USED OPERATING
IN THAT MANNER I SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES FOR TWENTY TWENTY
ONE THAT WE'RE ANTICIPATING
WILL BE ON STUDENT WILL BE WITH
STUDENT ATTENDANCE. OBVIOUSLY
OUR MODEL AND I'LL GET BETTER
RECOMMENDATIONS ALSO OUR MODEL
OF A CATHOLIC YOUR STUDENT
ATTENDANCE I CAN THAT IT REALLY
DOESN'T TRANSLATE WELL TO OUR
CURRENT DISTANCE LEARNING
FORMAT. I WILL ALSO HAVE TO
CONSIDER WHAT WOULD IT BE LIKE
IF WE HAVE. STAFF THAT THE NEED
OF LEAVE ALSO. THE SERVER SO
STAPP BETTER OVER SIXTY FIVE
WORK HAVE COMPROMISED IMMUNE
SYSTEM OR THEY HAVE ELDERLY AT
HOME THAT THEY'RE WORRIED
ABOUT. THEIR WORD ABOUT
INFECTING WHAT WOULD LOOK LIKE
FOR STAFF THAT WILL BE GONE
PROBABLY MORE THAN WHAT WE'VE
BEEN USED TO IN THE PAST. I WE
WILL OBVIOUSLY THERE'S A LOT OF
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT MITIGATING
SCHOOL CLOSURE. I IN THIS.
MITIGATING THAT. CLOSES THE
PATTERN THAT HAVE OCCURRED THIS
SPRING. AND THE LEARNING LOST
SO WE'RE WE'RE THERE'S
CONVERSATIONS YOU HEARD IT FROM
THE PREVIOUS PANELIST. AND THEN
THE REALITY IS WE HAD A FISCAL
CRISIS BEFORE THE PANDEMIC
CRISIS WHERE I WOULD SAY
PROBABLY ABOUT 4260% OF THE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS. ALREADY WAR
HAVING STAFF REDUCTION
CONVERSATION I KNOW IN MY
PERSONAL SITUATION IN FEBRUARY
WE HAD A RESOLUTION TO THE
BOARD WHERE WE WERE ELIMINATING
YOU. BETWEEN OUT FORTY FIVE
FULL TIME EQUIVALENT POSITIONS
ON THE CERTIFICATED SIDE OF
THINGS AND I WAS ONCE AGAIN THE
CRISIS BEFORE THE CRISIS.
INDEED THIS THAT HAS DECLINED
ENROLLMENT. IT'S BEEN. IT'S IT
WILL PROBABLY BE PROBABLY BEEN
HAVING CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
REDUCING EXPENDITURES AND WHEN
EIGHTY FIVE PERCENT. ROUGHLY
85% OF YOUR EXPENDITURES OR
STAFF THAT MEANS REDUCING
STAFF. SO THOSE CONVERSATIONS
WERE IN THE WORKS BEFORE THE
CRISIS. AND SOMETIMES THE
CHALLENGES WITH MITIGATING THE
LEARNING LOS THAT'S OCCURRING
RIGHT NOW WILL BE DIFFICULT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT EXPANDING
TIME WHICH MEANS ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES THAT'S ONE OF THE
CHALLENGES. THAT THE
RECOMMENDATIONS I WOULD LIKE TO
FOCUS ON. A REALLY THREE YOU'VE
HEARD IT. YOU'VE HEARD IT A IN
TERMS OF- WE HAVE TO LOOK AT.
SOME FLEXIBILITY WITH
INSTRUCTIONAL MINUTES AND
SCHOOL DAYS FOR STUDENTS ARE
HAD EVEN QUANTIFY SCHOOL DAY
FOR STUDENTS IN THIS
ENVIRONMENT. THE FISCAL
CONSIDERATIONS ARE MAJOR THOSE
ARE MAJOR I WHATEVER AWFULLY
THE GOVERNOR. I HAD THE TWO
POINT TWO NINE COLA AT- JANUARY
BUDGET PROPOSAL I THAT WAS DOWN
FROM A THREE POINT OH- COLA
THAT WE ARE UTILIZING THE
PREVIOUS PROJECTIONS. ARE SO
WHATEVER MAINTENANCE OF A COLOR
AT LEAST A STATUTORY COLA WOULD
BE IMPORTANT FOR US TO SCHOOL
DISTRICT. AS WELL AS THE
DOLLARS THAT WE'RE GOING TOWARD
SPECIAL EDUCATION AND
PARTICULARLY THAT. THE PRE
FORMAL OR OR THE PRESCHOOL
STUDENTS THAT WEEK AT FUNDING
FOR LAST YEAR. THAT WAS HELPFUL
AND IF THAT WOULD CONTINUE THAT
WOULD BE TREMENDOUS AND MAYBE
EVEN INCLUDE IN THAT THAT OUR
REGULAR FUNDING FORMULA- THE
MONEY BECAUSE PRIOR TO THAT WE
DID NOT GET DOLLARS. THE SERVER
THE SCHOOL STUDENTS AND THAT
WAS INCLUDED IN LAST YEAR'S
BUDGET. ARE YOU PARTY TO ABOUT
THE PENSION OBLIGATIONS
WHATEVER COULD BE DONE IN ORDER
TO. TO I WOULD SAY ALLEVIATE
BUT MITIGATE THE IMPACT OF THE
PENSION OBLIGATIONS WOULD BE
TREMENDOUS THE JUST THE COLA.
EDUCATION AND THE PENSIONS
WOULD BE WILL BE BENEFICIAL FOR
OUR SCHOOL DISTRICT AND THEN
LASTLY ON THE FUNDING OR FISCAL
CONSIDERATIONS. A DIFFICULT
ROLES WERE UTILIZED AS A
STRATEGY ABOUT THAT TEN TWELVE
YEARS AGO DURING THE- READ THE
GREAT RECESSION. I WHILE THE
DEFERRALS WAS A WA OF MANAGING
THE STATE'S CAST IT LEAVE
DISTRICTS IN A DIFFICULT
POSITION. OR TWENTY SOME OF US
HAVE. A RESERVE THEN I KNOW
RESERVES ARE POP POPULAR TOPIC
ABED MITIGATING EVERY NARAL
ASKING AROUND THE NOT. DARRYL
THANK YOU AND GOD THAT WE WILL
YEAH THANK YOU I THAT WILL
CONCLUDE THAT WILL COMPLETE MY
ESTIMATES AND I WELCOME ANY
QUESTIONS THANK OKAY THANK YOU.
TOBY VOID. ALL RIGHT GOOD
MORNING AND I WANT TO SAY THANK
YOU FOR ALLOWING ME THIS
pAM HERE TO REPRESENT THE THREE
HUNDRED AND TEN THOUSAND
EDUCATORS THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION. THE
STUDENTS THEY TEACH MORE THAN
SIX MILLION. STUDENTS A LOVING
OR MISSING DEARLY RIGHT NOW
EDUCATORS ARE WANT TO BE
PHYSICALLY BACK AT SCHOOL THIS
YEAR STUDENTS MORE THAN ANYBODY
ELSE. THANK YOU FOR GIVING ME
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH
YOU TODAY I WANT TO THANK YOU
PERSONALLY FOR VOTING TO
SUPPORT FUNDING. FOR PUBLIC
SCHOOLS THAT WE CONTINUE.
STUDENTS TO DOESN'T FIRING
PROVIDING SCHOOL MILLS AND
SUPERVISE STUDENTS ESSENTIAL
WORKERS. WE THANK THE GOVERNOR
AND THE SUIT ADMINISTRATION
FROM MAKING THE SAFETY OF OUR
STATE COMMUNITIES HIS NUMBER
ONE PRIORITY. TODAY I'M GOING
TO TALK ABOUT THREE THINGS
FIRST DISTANCE LEARNING DURING
A WORLDWIDE PANDEMIC SECOND
VULNERABLE STUDENTS IN LEARNING
LOSS IN THIRD HOW WE MAKE PLAN
TOGETHER TO OPEN SCHOOLS.
SAFELY AND RESPONSIBLY WHEN THE
TIME IS RIGHT. MANY OF YOU ARE
BOTH POLICY MAKERS AND PARENTS
I RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT YOU
HEAR AYE COMMENTS TO THE LENS
OF THAT'D BE. NOW WE YOU
REPRESENTING YOUR DISTRICT. THE
FIRST DAY OF SCHOOL. GIVE ME
THE FIRST DAY YOU BOUGHT YOUR
CHILDREN TO OUR PRESCHOOLS IN
KINDERGARTEN CLASSROOMS WE
TALKED ABOUT PARTNERSHIPS
BETWEEN PARENTS AND EDUCATORS
WE ARE PARTNERS IN THIS MISSION
ENSURE THE END GOAL OF HELPING
YOUR CHILDREN AND OUR STUDENTS
THRIVING GROW AND SUCCEED AS
PRODUCTIVE MEMBERS OF SOCIETY.
THAT PARTNERSHIP IS THE MORE
IMPORTANT NOW AS THE WAY THIS
PANDEMIC IN THE WEEKS AND
MONTHS AND POSSIBLY YEARS AHEAD.
WE KNOW PARENTS FAMILIES AND
CAREGIVERS ARE STRESSED SOME OF
THEM ARE WORKING FROM HOME MANY
ARE UNEMPLOYED AND WONDERING IF
THEY HAVE A JOB. TO GO TO BACK
WHEN THE ECONOMY OPENS UP AGAIN
UNDER THE NEW HEALTH
GUIDELINES. UNTIL WE HAVE A
VACCINE FOR THE COLBERT
NINETEEN. I UP TO THE MINUTE
EDUCATORS ARE WORRIED TO. LIKE
WHAT SIX GREAT TEACHER AND
PRESIDENT ABA NEGERI THE
KAESONG WHO WAS FEATURED IN AN
APRIL TWENTY FOURTH ARTICLE IN
THE LA TIMES. THEY'RE WORRIED
ABOUT STUDENTS WHOM THEY'D BEEN
UNABLE TO REACH SINCE THIS WAS
GO CLOSURE OF SCHOOLS. THEY'RE
WORRIED ABOUT THE BIBLE
STUDENTS WHO HAVE HEALTH ISSUES
AND ALREADY COMPROMISED.
THEY'RE WORRIED ABOUT THE
MENTAL HEALTH OF THEIR STUDENTS
IN THE SINK INTEREST IN
UNCERTAIN TIMES. TEACHERS
UNDERSTAND COMMUNITIES AND
THEIR FAMILIES ARE GOING
THROUGH DIFFICULT TIMES RIGHT
NOW SOME OF OUR FAMILIES ARE
STRUGGLING ASSEMBLY AND ABLE TO
HANDLE BOTH. STRESS OF THIS
CRISIS AND THEIR CHILDREN
LEARNING. EDUCATORS ARE
LOOSENING AND WE ARE HERE FOR
YOU. WE ARE HERE IN THIS
TOGETHER. EDUCATING STUDENTS.
AT HOME IS COMPLICATED
RESTRAINING EXHAUSTING AND HARD
SO HEAR ME NOW BECAUSE NINE IN
PATIENTS WITH YOURSELF AND YOUR
CHILDREN. THIS IS A MOMENT OF
TIME AS EXHAUST EVEN TRYING AS
IT IS RIGHT NOW IT WILL GET
BETTER AND WILL IT WILL
EVENTUALLY BE. ONLY SIXTEEN
ECHO PROTECT OUR IMMUNITIES
AGAIN. DO NOT STRESS IF YOU CAN
HELP YOUR CHILD MASTER
FRACTIONS WHERE TO STAND UP FOR
SALE PEOPLE LEARNING
APPROPRIATE USE OF THIS CYNICAL.
IT WILL BE OKAY. WE WILL BE
YOUR PARTISAN AND DRESSING ANY
LEARNING LOSS AS YOU HEARD I
WILL BE A CULTURE OF THE
SUPERINTENDENTS TASK FORCE. WE
CAN MUSICALLY OPEN SCHOOLS
AGAIN TEACHERS WILL LOOK AT.
WHAT EACH CHILD NEEDS AND WORK
WITH YOU TO DETERMINE HOW BEST
TO HELP STUDENTS ESPECIALLY
THOSE WERE STRUGGLING WE HAVE
TO MAKE SURE THAT THEIR SAFETY.
IS LOOKED AT FIRST THAT COULD
NOT BE COMPROMISED. AS WE
EXPLAIN FIRST PASSED ME AS WAS
EXPLAINING THE FIRST PANEL
WE'RE FACING A LOT OF
UNCERTAINTY IN THE STATE BUDGET
AND FUNDING FOR LOCAL PUBLIC
SCHOOLS. THIS IS THE PERFECT
STORM AND WHICH REVENUES ARE
DECLINING DRAMATICALLY WHILE
EXPENDITURES CONTINUE INCREASE
AS WE FIGHT TO PROTECT OUR
STUDENTS AND COMMUNITIES. IT IS
HARD TO SEE ANY BUDGET SOLUTION
THAT DOES NOT REQUIRE MONEY
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
OUR TEACHER LEADERS FROM ACROSS
THE STATE HAVE ALREADY BEEN
LOBBYING THE MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS WERE JUST NOT DOLLARS
FOR CALIFORNIA. WE APPRECIATE
THE DOLLARS WE HAVE RECEIVED SO
FAR IT'S SO MUCH NEEDED. WHEN
WE RETURN TO SCHOOL CAMPUSES IT
NEEDS TO BE PLANNED AND
DELIBERATE WHAT PUBLIC HEALTH
AT THE FOREFRONT ALL DECISION
MAKING. SOME DECISIONS OUR
STATE DECISIONS AND DIRECTIVES
WITH WHILE OTHER DISTANCE
DECISIONS WILL BE BEST LEFT TO
LOCAL SCHOOL DISTRICTS WORKING
WITH THEIR PARENTS. EDUCATORS
AND CLASSIFIED PERSONNEL. IN
FACT THE EDUCATION COOL
COALITION SUBMITTED A LETTER OF
LEGISLATURE ON APRIL FIFTEENTH
OUTLINING SOME OF THE ESSENTIAL
SERVICES THAT ARE NEEDED TO RE
OPEN THE SCHOOLS. ALWAYS
SCHOOLS ARE A CLEAR ECONOMIC
DRIVER IN THE STATE'S ECONOMY.
OPENING PUBLIC SCHOOL SAFELY
RESPONSE WAIT WILL PROVIDE
PARENTS AND COMMUNITIES WITH
THE CONFIDENCE THAT'S NEEDED TO
GO BACK TO WORK. WHAT DOES
OPENING SCHOOLS LOOK LIKE DOING
A PANDEMIC. WE UNDERSTAND A
LARGE SCALE TESTING IS KEY AND
APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR'S
LEADERSHIP OF PUSHING MORE
TESTING IN THE WEEK AND MONTHS
AHEAD. HOWEVER ABSENT OF
INDEXING AND THE POTENTIAL NEXT
WAVE OF THE VIRUS AND FALL IN
THE FALL. PUBLIC SCHOOLS NEEDS
TO BE A SAFE RE OPENING WHILE
ALSO PLANNING FOR FUTURE
CLOSURES. YES AND WHEN THE
RESURGENCE OF THE VIRUS A CURSE.
WELL THE SCHOOLS NEED TO MAKE
CERTAIN ASSUMPTIONS ABOUT HOW
TO PROTECT STUDENTS EDUCATORS
FACULTY IN COMMUNITIES. WE NEED
TO ASSUME THAT ALL PERSONS THAT
COME ON CAMPUS OR SCHOOL BUSES
ARE POTENTIAL CAMERAS ON THE
VIRUS. THAT PREMISE VERY
CENTRAL MEASURES THAT WE NEED
POLICYMAKERSTO CONSIDER THAT
INCLUDE BUT IT BUT IS NOT
LIMITED TO THE FOLLOWING. DEEP
CLEANING A CONTINUES QUEEN OF
OUR CAMPUSES AND BUSES. THIS
CALL DOESN'T SEEM IN CLASSROOMS
AND OTHER SHARED SPACES. BASED
COVERING GLOVES AND HAND
SANITIZERS. RUSSELL
CONSIDERATION TO PROTECT
STUDENTS AND STAFF WHAT
COMPROMISED UNDERLYING MEDICAL
CONDITIONS. SCHOOL HEALTH
SERVICES INCLUDING SCHOOL
NURSES FOR ENHANCE STUDENTS
FAMILIES AND EDUCATORS SAFETY.
MENTAL HEALTH COUNSELLING AND
SUPPORT FOR THOSE SUFFERING
FROM THIS THE IMPACT OF THIS
PANDEMIC. THIS IS NOT A WISH
LIST OF LUXURY ITEMS THIS IS
WHAT IS NEEDED TO KEEP OUR
STUDENTS AND SCHOOL SAY. TWENTY
FOUR POTENTIAL CERTAIN
RESURGENCE OF THE VIRUS WE ALSO
NEED TO WORK COLLABORATIVELY
WITH ERRANDS IN SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ON LOCAL SCHOOL
MODELS THAT CAN AND WILL
FACILITATE. JUST OF SEE OUR
pMODELS CAN IN AN INTEGRATE BOTH
IN PERSON AND DISTANCE
LEARNING. POSSIBLE SOLUTIONS
COULD BE RETURNED TO A MULTI
YEAR TRACK SYSTEM AM PM
SESSIONS AND WALKS SCHEDULING.
ALL THESE MODELS REQUIRE
SMALLER CLASS SIZES AND MORE
TEACHERS. IT WILL ALSO REQUIRE
MORE PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
FOR EDUCATORS AND DISTANCE
LEARNING AS SAFE RELIABLE
PLATFORMS IN WHICH TO ENGAGE
STUDENTS DIGITALLY AND
CONTINUES SUPPORT FOR STUDENTS
WITH DEVICES IN INTERNET ACCESS.
YOUR CREATIVE SOLUTIONS OUT
THERE BUT WE WILL NEED THE
SUPPORT OF THE LEGISLATURE TO
PRIORITIZE SCHOOLS. FOR MORE
FUNDING AT A TIME WHEN THE
BUDGET MAYBE STREAKING. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
LATER ADMINISTRATION AS A
PARTNER THE NEXT WEEKS AND
MONTHS AHEAD TO ENSURE WE'RE
MAKING THE BEST DECISIONS FOR
STUDENTS AND COMMUNITY. I THANK
YOU FOR LISTENING TO ME AND
I'LL BE AROUND FOR QUESTIONS
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH TO
BE VOID NEXT WILL HAVE DOCTOR
ID AGA WITH THE EDUCATION
TRUST. WEST PLEASE PROCEED.
EIGHT GOOD MORNING I'M SO
GRATEFUL FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK WITH YOU TODAY BECAUSE WE
ARE AT A CROSSROADS MOMENT FOR
EDUCATIONAL JUSTICE IN
CALIFORNIA. LONG BEFORE THE RUN
A VIRUS CAN THEY MAKE CAME TO
OUR SHORES CALIFORNIA FACED AN
EPIDEMIC OF EDUCATIONAL
INEQUALITY. FOR DECADES WE HAVE
GIVEN THE LEAST ACCESS TO
OPPORTUNITY TO THE STUDENTS
NEED IT MOST. WE HAVE STUDENTS
OF COLOR AND LOW INCOME
STUDENTS POLICE ACCESS COURSE
WORK. HIGHLY QUALIFIED TEACHERS
CRUCIAL TECHNOLOGY AND MOST OF
OTHER RESOURCES. AND WE'VE
GOTTEN EXACTLY THE RESULTS YOU
WOULD EXPECT FROM THE SYSTEM
WE'VE CREATED FOR EXAMPLE THE
RECENT CALIFORNIA SCIENCE SAYS
SHOW THE LESS THAN ONE IN FIVE
AFRICAN AMERICAN LAND NEXT LOW
INCOME STUDENTS AND JUST 3% OF
ENGLISH LEARNERS MEETING
STANDARDS. THE DECISIONS
CALIFORNIA MAKES RIGHT NOW WILL
DETERMINE WHETHER WE BOUNCE
BACK STRONGER POSITION TO BUILD
A BETTER FAIRER FUTURE ARE
WHETHER WE ALLOW THE PANDEMIC
TO TURN CRACKS IN OUR
FOUNDATION INTO CREVICES. WILL
MOVE- THAT THE BEST SOLUTIONS
COME FROM THE PEOPLE CLOSEST TO
THE PROBLEM. THAT'S WHY ADDRESS
WEST CONDUCTED A STATEWIDE POLL
IN PARIS EXPERIENCES AMID THE
OUTBREAK. WHAT WE HEARD WAS
WHAT WE'VE BEEN CALLING A TALE
OF TWO CITIES. THE IMMEDIATE
CRISIS KEEPING STUDENTS SAFE
HEALTHY FED AND HOW. SHUTTING
SCHOOLS DOWNTURN IN AN ORDERLY
WAY GETTING EVERY. AND THERE'S
CALIFORNIA'S LONGSTANDING
EDUCATION EQUITY CRISIS. ON THE
FIRST COUNT THE IMMEDIATE
CRISIS. PARENTS GIVE THEIR
SCHOOLS AND DISTRICTS HIGH
MARKS MOST PARENTS SAID THEY
GENERALLY THEIR SCHOOL OR
DISTRICT IS DOING AN EXCELLENT
OR GOOD JOB MANAGING SCHOOL
CLOSURES AND SHARING
INSTRUCTIONAL MATERIALS.
HOWEVER THEY ARE ALSO SCARED
ABOUT THE FUTURE AND THEY
OFFERED WARNING SIGNS ABOUT HOW
THIS PANDEMIC THREATENS TO
EXACERBATE THE EQUITY PRICES.
THE MAJORITY OF AFRICAN
AMERICAN AND LATIN EXPERIENCE
IN THE SURVEY WORRIED THAT THEY
LACK THE RESOURCES TO HELP YOUR
CHILD STAY ON TRACK. LOW INCOME
FAMILIES AND FAMILIES OF COLOR
ARE ALSO CONCERNED THAT IN
ADEQUATE ACCESS TO THE INTERNET
IN DEVICES. WILL HINDER THEIR
CHILDREN'S DISTANCE LEARNING.
UNABLE STUDENT ACCESS TO
TECHNOLOGY THE DIGITAL DIVIDE
IS NOT A NEW PHENOMENON BUT
THIS CRISIS HAS CAST IN UNDER A
HARSH SPOTLIGHT. WITH SCHOOLS
FORCED INTO REMOTE INSTRUCTION
GAPS IN DIGITAL ACCESS WILL
BECOME GAPS IN STUDENT LEARNING.
THERE ARE SOME THINGS SCHOOLS
DISTRICTS AND POLICY MAKERS CAN
DO RIGHT NOW TO CLOSE THE
DIVIDE. FIRST EVALUATE DIGITAL
ACCESS NEEDS IN SCHOOLS AND
DISTRICTS SECOND ADVOCATE FOR
PUBLIC PRIVATE PARTNERSHIPS AND
INCENTIVIZE PROVIDERS TO
SUPPORT HIGH NEED COMMUNITIES.
THIRD TARGET TRAINING
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT IN
ADDITIONAL IT SUPPORT AND
FOURTH REQUIRE LOCAL EDUCATION
AGENCIES TO SHARE THEIR
DISTANCE LEARNING LIKE. EVEN IF
WE EXPAND DIGITAL ACCESS THERE
IS SIMPLY NO WAY TO CLOSE
SCHOOL FOR MONTHS WITHOUT
LEARNING LOSS FOR STUDENTS
ESPECIALLY THE MOST VULNERABLE.
OUR JOB NOW IS TO EQUIP
EDUCATORS WITH THE TOOLS THEY
NEED TO REVERSE THAT LOSS WHEN
SCHOOLS REOPEN. THE REASON IN
W. E. A STUDY THAT WAS
MENTIONED EARLY EARLIER WHICH
EVALUATED THE ANALYSIS OF DATA
FROM MORE THAN FIVE MILLION
STUDENTS ACROSS THE COUNTRY
OFFER SCARY PROJECTIONS ABOUT
WHAT SCHOOL CLOSURES WILL MEAN
FOR STUDENT LEARNING ESPECIALLY
WHEN IT COMES TO MATCH.
STUDENTS ARE LIKELY TO LOSE
HALF OF THEIR USUAL MATH
LEARNING GAMES AND IN SOME
GRADES WILL FALL NEARLY A FULL
YEAR BEHIND. READING IMPACTS
ARE SOMEWHAT LESS PRONOUNCED
BUT IN W. E. A. STILL PROJECTS
STUDENTS WILLIAMS 30% OF A
TYPICAL YEAR. THE STEPS WE TAKE
NOW TO REVERSE LEARNING LOSS
WILL DEFINE WHAT KIND OF STATE
EMERGES. WILL WE ALLOW THE
CRISIS TO FURTHER DIVIDE US OR
WILL WE BAND TOGETHER TO GIVE
EVERY CHILD REGARDLESS OF
BACKGROUND IN EQUAL SHOT AT
SUCCESS. THE PEOPLE IN THIS
ROOM TODAY CAN HELP ENSURE THE
LATTER. BY FIRST DIRECTING
SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO RELEASE
DISTANCE LEARNING PLANS. AND
ALSO BY PROVIDING FLEXIBILITY
FOR DISTRICTS TO ADDRESS
LEARNING. AIR REQUIRING HIGH
QUALITY DISTANCE LEARNING FOR
ALL STUDENTS. AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY AS MENTIONED-
EARLIER DEFINING HOW SCHOOLS
SHOULD MEASURE STUDENT LEARNING
DURING THIS CRISIS AND HOW THIS
INFORMATION TO HELP STUDENTS
CATCH UP ON MISSED MATERIAL. SO
IN CONCLUSION ACROSS ALL OUR
RECOVERY EFFORTS ONE
COMMONSENSE PRINCIPLE MUST
APPLY. AT THE MOST RESOURCES TO
THE FAMILIES AND COMMUNITIES IT
THE HARDEST. YOU HEAR A LOT
TODAY YOU MAY BE WONDERING WHAT
ARE THE MOST IMPORTANT THINGS
YOU CAN DO TO ADDRESS LEARNING
LOS. FIRST YOU CAN WORK TO
INVEST INVOLUNTARY MULTI WEEK
SUMMER SCHOOL THIS YEAR ONLINE
OR IN PERSON BASED ON PUBLIC
HEALTH GUIDELINES. AND SECONDLY
YOU CAN PARTNER WITH TEACHERS
ACROSS THE STATE. TO IDENTIFY
OTHER FORMS OF EXTENDED
REQUIRE FINANCIAL RESOURCES SO
WE WILL NEED TO LEVERAGE
FEDERAL DOLLARS AND PROTECT
STATE EDUCATION FUNDING. ROUTE
THE PROCESS ADDRESS LESS IS
HERE TO HELP THANK YOU. OKAY
THANK YOU OUR LAST ANALYST WILL
BE LEAH THERE I'M FROM THE
CALIFORNIA HE'S BEEN JOKING
MYSELF LEE AT THE ERROR WITH
pAFTERNOON ASSEMBLY MEMBERS AND
FELLOW PANELISTS CALIFORNIA
STATE PTA IS WORKING HARD
ACROSS THE STATE TO HELP
FAMILIES AND STUDENTS STILL
CONNECTED FOR IT DURING THIS
PANDEMIC. AND SHELTER ORDER HE
OFTEN PLAYS A ROLE IN BUILDING
COMMUNITY ADVOCATING FOR
STUDENTS AT ALL ASPECTS OF
THEIR LIVES AND CONNECTING
PARENTS AND CAREGIVERS TO
RESOURCES TO SUPPORT THEIR
CHILDREN. WE JUST RELEASED A
FREE RESOURCE LIBRARY ON OUR CA
PTA DOT ORG WEBSITE. I WOULD
LEARNING ACTIVITIES THAT
PARENTS CARE GIVERS AND
STUDENTS CAN ACCESS TO SUPPORT
LEARNING AT HOME. DURING THIS
CRISIS WE'RE ESPECIALLY
CONCERNED WITH STUDENTS SOCIAL
AND EMOTIONAL WELL BEING. WELL
DISTRICTS ARE DOING THEIR BEST
TO PROVIDE DISTANCE LEARNING WE
KNOW THERE ARE GAPS IN THE
SYSTEM IN WHICH STUDENTS MAY
NOT HAVE ACCESS TO ADEQUATE
TECHNOLOGY TECHNOLOGY DEVICES.
INTERNET ACCESS OR QUIET PLACE
TO LEARN. WE SUPPORT EDUCATORS
AND BELIEVE THEY NEED AND
DESERVE PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT FOR DISTANCE
LEARNING. I THINK MORE THAN
EVER WE REALIZE THE VALUE OF
OUR TEACHERS IN CALIFORNIA. I
FOR THE- FIRST. WILL NEED.
ENGLISH LEARNERS STUDENTS WITH
ID PEAS FIVE ABOARD AND SPECIAL
EDUCATION STUDENTS NEED
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT AND SERVICES
TO SUCCEED IN THIS NEW LEARNING
ENVIRONMENT. WE HEARD FROM
PARENTS WHO ARE CONCERNED ABOUT
ENSURING THEIR STUDENTS ST
GRADE LEVEL I DID NOT
EXPERIENCE LEARNING OFFICE. OUT
WAY I'M THE PARENT OF A HIGH
SCHOOLER AND I'M OBSERVING THE
CHALLENGES PARENTS ARE FACING
BOUNCING WORKING FROM HOME
CHILDREN IN PLACE AND
SUPPORTING MY DAUGHTER'S
LEARNING AT HOME EVERYTHING
FROM BALANCING USE WIFI.
DEVICES AT A QUIET PLACE IN OUR
OWN HOME AND I ONLY MANAGING
ONE STUDENT AND THREE ADULTS
WORKING FROM HOME. MOST
PROFOUNDLY I AM SEEING IMPACTS
OF THE SOCIAL ISOLATION AND
LACK OF GENUINE CONNECTION THAT
THIS NEW NORMAL REQUIRES. MOST
OF MOST OF ALL OUR STUDENTS AND
FAMILIES NEED TO FEEL SAFE. AND
SECURE THE FACE THE CHALLENGES
THIS CURRENT PANDEMIC REQUIRES
ABOUT. AND IT IS MY SINCERE
HOPE THAT THE LEGISLATURE MAKE
THE DECISION TO INVEST IN C. D.
MENTAL HEALTH. EDUCATION
SERVICES AND SOCIAL SERVICES TO
PROTECT OUR MOST VALUED ASSET
IN THE STATE OUR CHILDREN. OKAY
THANK YOU THAT. NOW WE HAVE THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE JESSICA
HOMES AND MAYBE YOU CAN
ENLIGHTEN US ON THE
ANNOUNCEMENT THE GOVERNOR JUST
MADE ABOUT SCHOOLS REAL OPENING
THIS SUMMER SO WE DON'T WANT TO
STEAL HIS THUNDER BUT NOW IT'S
ALL ACROSS THE- TWITTER WORLD.
SO YOU CAN YOU CAN SHARE WITH
US WHAT WHAT HE SAID AS WELL.
THANK YOU- SO I DIDN'T HAVE I'M
JUST HERE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS ON ANY FISCAL AT THE
SCHOOL CONCERNS FOLKS HAD
ABOUT- THE TOPIC OF THIS PANEL
BUT I WILL SAY THAT THE
GOVERNOR DID JUST ANNOUNCE
THAT- WE ARE. LOOKING WE ARE
CONSIDERING- OPTIONS TO
MITIGATE LEARNING LOSS-
SPECIFICALLY CONSIDERING- AN
EARLY. START OF THE NEW SCHOOL
YEAR NO DECISIONS HAVE BEEN
MADE BUT IT IS- A TOPIC OF.
DISCUSSION WITHIN THE
ADMINISTRATION SOMETHING WE
CERTAINLY INTERESTED IN
ENGAGING WITH THE LEGISLATURE
ON- BUT THAT'S GOING TO REQUIRE
QUITE A BIT OF PREPARATION TO
BEGIN TO PREPARE FOR THE
PHYSICAL. AND ENVIRONMENTAL
CHANGES NECESSARY- FOR BOTH
SCHOOLS AND CHILDCARE CENTERS
TO OPEN SAFELY- SO I NO
ADDITIONAL DETAILS ON THAT
RIGHT NOW BUT IT'S- TRYING TO
LET PEOPLE KNOW THAT WORK. I'M
LOOKING AT MOVING IN THAT
DIRECTION AND- EXPLORING WITH
WITH YOU ALL IN A COLLABORATIVE
WAY WHAT THAT MEANS. ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU SO I THINK THAT KIND
OF ELUDES TO WHAT WE TALKED
ABOUT EARLIER THERE'S WAY MORE
QUESTIONS THAN ANSWERS. RELATED
TO THIS PIECE- I REGARDLESS
WHETHER OR NOT THAT SCHOOLS CAN
START EARLIER IN THE YEAR WE
HAVE A THOUSAND SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND THEY'RE NOT ALL.
ON THE ON THE SAME PATH- BUT
THE LEARNING LAS ISSUES. ARE
ARE REAL IF YOU START IN JULY
OR THE TRADITIONAL AUGUST OR
AFTER LABOR DAY ESPECIALLY WAS
HAPPEN THE LAST. TWO MONTHS- SO
WITH THAT WILL NOW GET INTO-
QUESTIONS AND ANSWERS AND WE DO
WANT TO NOTE FOR OUR MEMBERS
THAT- LINDA DARLING HAMMOND
FROM THE TO STATE PARK- BOARD
OF ED. THESE LEAVE A LITTLE BIT
SO IF YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
FOR HER. WE CAN PLEASE ADDRESS
THOSE QUESTIONS TO HER AT THE
OUTSET. I KNOW MISTER GALLAGHER
WE LOST YOU- LAST TIME IN YOUR
QUESTION SO YOU YOU CAN GO
AHEAD WITH THOSE RIGHT NOW IF
YOU'D LIKE. WELL I THINK SINCE
WE HAVE HE NEED TO GO PRETTY
SOON MAYBE WE CAN START THE.
NOT TAKE MORE THAN THAT SORRY.
I MEAN FIRST I THIS ONE I THINK
WE GOT A SET THE TONE HERE A
LITTLE BIT AND WE'VE KIND OF
ALLUDED TO IT IN SOME OF THE
QUESTIONS AND WE HAVEN'T GOTTEN
SPECIFIC ANSWERS- DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE YOU KNOW I UNDERSTAND
YOU'RE STILL ASSESSING THE
SITUATION BUT OTHERS HAVE
ACTUALLY ALREADY ASSESSED WHAT
WE'RE LOOKING AT INCLUDING THE
LA JOH. AND ESTIMATES FOR JUST
THIS YEAR THIS BUDGET YEAR-
COULD BE ANYWHERE FROM FIVE
BILLION TO TWENTY FIVE. TWENTY
POINT FOUR BILLION DOLLARS AN
ESTIMATED GENERAL FUND REVENUE
DECLINE. IN NEXT YEAR THE LA-
IS PROJECTED JUST LOOKING AT
CAPITAL GAINS REDUCTIONS WERE
LOOKING AT A THIRTY FIVE
BILLION DOLLAR. A GENERAL FUND
A KLEIN- PROBABLY THE PROP
NINETY EIGHT GUARANTEE IS GONNA
BE MEASURED USING TEST ONE.
WHICH REALLY MEANS FOR EVERY
FUND REVENUE FORTY CENTS IS
GONNA COME OUT OF. THE PROP
NINETY EIGHT GUARANTEE THAT'S
THE REALITY- SO WE ARE FACING
IN. YOU KNOW HUGE BUDGET
SHORTFALLS- IN TERMS OF THE
MONEY AVAILABLE- THERE'S
DIFFERENT ME OBVIOUSLY THERE'S
FEDERAL MONEY THAT'S COMING
THROUGH THERE'S SOME OF THESE
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS BUT- I DON'T
THINK UNDER ANY SCENARIO. ARE
WE GONNA BE ABLE TO SAY THAT
WE'RE GONNA BE ABLE TO DO THE
EXACT SAME FUNDING THAT WE WERE
PLANNING ON AND- AND TO SAY
WE'RE GOING TO INCREASE FUNDING
IN ADDIS I'D HAVE TO SAY WHERE
WE GONNA GET THAT FROM. IN HERE.
AND THIS IS THE OTHER THING WE
NEED TO TALK ABOUT. THE LONGER
THAT WE STAY CLOSE DOWN ON A
STATE WIDE ORDER. AND I AND I
UNDERSTAND WE NEED TO LOOK AT
THE PUBLIC HEALTH CONCERNS WE
TAKE THOSE VERY SERIOUSLY BUT
THERE IS A PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS
ON THE OTHER SIDE OF THIS AS
WELL. AND IT'S IN OUR EDUCATION
SYSTEM IT'S IN OUR SOCIAL
SAFETY NET ALL OF WHICH YOU'RE
LOOKING A HUGE CUTS- AND SO THE
LONGER THAT WE STAY UNDER. A
BLANKET ORDER AND WE DON'T HAVE
ANY PLANS FREE OPENING THIS
PROBLEM JUST GETS WORSE THE AT
THE AMOUNT OF REVENUE. COMING
INTO. OUR PUBLIC COFFERS TO
PROVIDE ALL THESE DIFFERENT
THINGS. IS GOING TO THAT
PICTURE IS JUST GOING TO GET.
WORSE SO I THINK WE DO ON THE
ONE HAND HE TO BE LOOKING AT
HOW CAN WE SAFELY RE OPEN AS
MUCH OF THE ECONOMY. SAFELY
OPEN AS MUCH OF THE ECONOMY AS
POSSIBLE SO THAT WE CAN GET.
OUR REVENUES BACK A. AND I ALSO
THINK WE SHOULD BE LOOKING AT
HE WAS MY COLLEAGUE. FROM SANTA
BARBARA JUST MENTIONED HOW. IT
YOU KNOW I DON'T THINK WE
SHOULD BE PLAN ON DISTANCE
LEARNING ME IN THE LONG TERM WE
NEED TO FIGURE OUT HOW CAN WE
GET. THE BEST WAY TO DEAL WITH
SO MANY OF THESE ISSUES THAT
WERE IDENTIFIED IN THIS PANEL
IS TO GET KIDS BACK IN SCHOOL-
YEAH I REALIZE IS GONNA BE
DIFFERENT DYNAMICS AND INVOLVED
WITH THAT- BUT IF YOU LOOK AT A
LOT OF THE PUBLIC HEALTH
INFORMATION THAT'S COMING OUT
INCLUDING A REPORT THAT CAME
OUT FROM AMERICAN ENTERPRISE
INSTITUTE. ONCE YOU GET TO A AT
A PERIOD WHERE YOU'VE HAD
FOURTEEN DAYS OF DECLINING
CASES THEY RECOMMEND THAT YOU
CAN OPEN FACILITIES INCLUDING
SCHOOLS SO I THINK WE CAN LOOK
AT THAT IN DIFFERENT PARTS OF
THE STATE. AND SEE WHERE IT SAY
TO DO SO WITH PROTOCOLS- TO GET
KIDS BACK IN SCHOOL BECAUSE
THAT'S GOING TO DO MORE THAN
ANYTHING. TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
MITIGATE THE LEARNING LOS
THAT'S GOING ON- AND WE
CERTAINLY DON'T I MEAN I THINK
THE FISCAL PICTURE. WE CAN'T
MAKE PROMISES- YEAH THAT WE'RE
GONNA BE ABLE TO INVEST IN ALL
KINDS OF STUFF TO HELP MAKE
DISTANCE LEARNING WORK. I DO I
DON'TSEE WHERE THE MONEY IS.
TO MAKE THAT HAPPEN- CERTAINLY
WANT TO TRY AND MITIGATE THAT
AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE IN THE
INTERIM BUT WE NEED TO GET DO
WHAT WE CAN TO GET PEOPLE BACK
IN SCHOOL- WHERE WE CAN.
CONTINUE THE EDUCATION THAT
THESE KIDS. YOU KNOW SO
DESPERATELY NEED. YOU KNOW THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. I MEAN
YEAH YOU WOULD ANSWER THE
QUESTION ABOUT COLA I WAS
ANSWER FOR YOU I DON'T SEE HOW
WE CAN POSSIBLY DO A CALL
INCREASE WITH THESE KIND OF
NUMBERS SO IF. I'M JUST GONNA
ASSUME THE ANSWER IS NO UNLESS
YOU TELL ME DIFFERENT. IN TERMS
OF THE PROP NINETY EIGHT
GUARANTEE I WOULD ASK IS IT
STILL YOUR PLAN TO KEEP IT AT.
IS IT STILL YOUR PLAN TO KEEP
IT AT THE THAN THE PROP NINETY
EIGHT LEVELS THAT WAS
IDENTIFIED IN THE BUDGET WHICH
MIGHT BE ABOVE THE PROP NINETY
A MINIMUM GUARANTEE UNDER TEST
ONE- BUT TO BE GOOD TO KNOW
THAT IS THAT IS THAT YOUR PLAN
TO DO THAT. THANK YOU SO MUCH I
MISTER GALLAGHER SO. AGAIN AS I
MENTIONED BEFORE WE'RE STILL
ANALYZING WHAT RESOURCES WE DO
HAVE AVAILABLE- ONCE WE-
IDENTIFY THAT AMOUNT WE PUT
TOGETHER PLAN WHICH OF COURSE
WE PROVIDE TO YOU AS THE ME
REVISION- AND THAT WILL
INCLUDE- OUR DECISIONS AROUND.
HOW WE'RE FINDING THE
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GUARANTEE- I KNOW IT'S
FRUSTRATING- THAT I'M NOT ABLE
TO PROVIDE YOU AN EXACT ANSWER
RIGHT NOW BUT- IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT THAT. WERE ABLE TO
PUT TOGETHER THE ENTIRE PACKAGE
AND HAVE THAT HOLISTIC LOOK AS
ROOMMATE JUST SIT INS AND I
DON'T WANT TO PUT OUT ANY
INCORRECT INFORMATION- THAT
WILL CONFUSE- THE PUBLIC SO-
YOU KNOW WE'RE WORKING VERY
HARD I TO GET YOU GUYS AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE- BUT WE'RE
NOT SURE- WHAT THE GUARANTEES
GONNA LOOK LIKE AT THIS POINT.
BUT DEFINITELY LOOKING FORWARD
TO ENGAGING IN THAT
CONVERSATION ON THE REVISION. I
UNDERSTAND THAT BUT UNTIL THEN
I MEAN SINCE WE DON'T HAVE AN
ANSWER I HAVE TO ASSUME THAT
PROP NINETY IT'S GONNA GET
CALCULATED USING TEST ONE AND
THAT MEANS YOU KNOW EVEN IF
IT'S A FIVE BILLION DOLLAR
DECLINE IN REVENUE. A GENERAL
FUND REVENUE THAT MEANS A TWO
BILLION DOLLAR DECREASE IN- THE
PROP NINETY EIGHT MINIMUM
FUNDING GUARANTEE. I FEEL LIKE
THAT'S WHAT I HAVE TO ASSUME
UNTIL I HEAR SOMETHING
SOMETHING DIFFERENT YEAH WELL
LET ME JUST INTERJECT THERE
MISTER TAYLOR I THINK AS YOU
SAID JUST NOW IS IT AS CHAIR
BUDGET CHAIRMAN TING LUTES
EARLIER WE NEED TO BE REALISTIC
AND CAN'T BE. YOU KNOW HI THIS
GUY IN HAVE A REALITY CHECK
CONVERSATION. THEY CAN BE NEW
MONEY ABOVE THE COAL THAT WE
CAME OUT IN JANUARY PROBABLY
NOT THE CAN WE KEEP THE COAL IS
THE AMOUNT THAT WE HAD THERE IN
JANUARY. THAT I THINK IS
REALISTIC EVEN WITH THOSE.
THOSE NUMBERS YOU TALK ABOUT IN
LESS REVENUE WHEN YOU LOOK AT
THE THREE. TOOLS A THREE LEGGED
STOOL IT'S FEDERAL MONEY WE GOT
ONE. A LOT IN THE FIRST FEDERAL
CARES. SCHOOL CARES RIGHT YEAH
THE CARES ALLOCATION WE'RE
TRYING TO GET AROUND TO WE HAVE
CERTAINLY ONE TIME MONEY THAT
WE- STATE RESPONSIBLY PUT AWAY.
NORTH OF TWENTY BILLION DOLLARS
AND POTENTIALLY ARE THINGS WE
CAN DO LIKE DEFERRAL SO. I
THINK WE SHOULD BE OPTIMISTIC
AND TALK ABOUT HOW THAT SHOULD
BE OUR TOP GOAL IS TO ADOPT A
BUDGET WITH NO CUTS. NO CUTS
AND EVEN WHEN THEY HAVE THIS
DID THIS DRASTIC IMPACT GOING
FROM THE ECONOMY. THAT'S WHY WE
HAVE THESE ARE THINGS IN PLACE.
TO MITIGATE THE DAMAGE TO OUR
KIDS INTO OUR SCHOOLS. RIGHT
AND I'M ANGRY I WANT TO TRY AND
KEEP THINGS AS EVEN. KILLED AS
POSSIBLE. BUT I ALSO NEED TO
UNDERSTAND YOU KNOW WHAT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S IN TENNIS WITH
THE MAY REVISE AND. REAL QUICK-
EVEN GET TO THE BUDGET
STABILIZATION ACCOUNT. YOU KNOW
WHICH- RIGHT NOW HAS SIXTEEN
BILLION DOLLARS IN IT. I THINK
IN REALITY IT'S CLOSER TO
FOURTEEN BILLION. YOU WHEN YOU
TAKE INTO ACCOUNT WHAT'S GONNA
HAPPEN THIS YEAR- IN TERMS OF
THE BALANCE. WHAT WE CAN'T WE
PROBABLY CAN'T USE ALL OF THAT
IN ONE YEAR BECAUSE WE ARE
PROBABLY LOOKING AT A CONTINUED
RECESSION. AND THE FUTURE YEARS
BUT WHAT IS THE GOT WHAT IS THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PLAN DO YOU
BELIEVE THAT THERE WILL BE
CONDITIONS OR LIMITS. OPERATIVE
FOR THE WITHDRAWAL OF THE
OPTIONAL DEPOSIT BALANCES IN
THE BUDGET STABILIZATION
ACCOUNT. AND YOU CONSIDER ANY
FUNDS IN THE BSA TO BE
AVAILABLE RIGHT NOW TO SUPPORT
REVENUES. SO AGAIN AND I
APOLOGIZE FOR BEING A BROKEN
RECORD HERE BUT THAT'S NOT
SOMETHING THAT WE CAN SPEAK TO
RIGHT NOW- DEFINITELY SOMETHING
THAT WILL COVER WITHIN THE NAY
REVISION. WELL LOOK I MEAN IT'S
I MEAN IT'S JUST FRUSTRATING
BECAUSE YOU GUYS ARE OBVIOUSLY
PLANNING. YOU HAVE TO PLAN FOR
THIS YOU HAVE TO HAVE SOME
IDEA. AND IT IS CONTINUED
FRUSTRATION TO ME THAT YOU
WON'T SHARE THAT PLAN YOU WON'T
SHARE THAT THOUGHT HE WON'T
SHARE ANYTHING. PRETTY MUCH
ANYTHING WITH THE LEGISLATURE.
ABOUT WHAT'S GOING ON HERE WE
ARE PART OF THIS DECISION
MAKING PROCESS OBVIOUSLY. WE
HAVE TO START THINKING ABOUT
HOW WE CAN DO EXACTLY WHAT THE
CHAIRMAN JUST SAID HOW CAN WE
TRY TO KEEP THIS AS STABLE AS
POSSIBLE- YOU OVER THE NEXT
YEAR. BUT IT'S REALLY HARD WHEN
WE'RE NOT GETTING ANY
COOPERATION- SO. I DON'T KNOW I
MEAN AS SOON AS WE CAN GET SOME
ANSWERS THAT BE GREAT. OKAY
THANK YOU MISTER GALLAGHER.
AGAIN THIS PANEL. WE WENT A LOT
OF THOSE ISSUES AT AT IN
GREATER DETAIL EARLIER I KNOW.
YOU WANTED TO GET THOSE
QUESTIONS ANSWERED HERE BUT
HERE WE HAVE OUR PANELISTS
FOCUSING ON THE- LEARNING LAS
WHAT CALIFORNIA CAN DO TO
MITIGATE THE LEARNING LOS ONE
PROPOSAL THAT THE GOVERNOR'S
ANNOUNCED LAST HALF OUR IS
THAT. POSSIBILITY NOT A
GUARANTEED THAT WE COULD START
SCHOOL EARLIER TO MITIGATE THAT
LOST BUT EVEN IF WE DID. THAT
THEY'RE STILL THE LOSSES
HAPPENED IN THE LAST FEW MONTHS
AND SO. ON I WANTED TO START%
OUT IN ASKING- LINDA DARLING
HAMMOND AND ANY OF THAT- SCHOOL
DISTRICT REPRESENTS OR ANYBODY
WHO WANTS TO- TO PIPE IN HERE-
WHAT WHAT IT LOOK LIKE AND I
KNOW WE HAVE A THOUSAND
DISTRICTS ACROSS. CALIFORNIA
VERY DIFFERENT RURAL URBAN AND
SUBURBAN WHAT HAVE YOU- SO ONE
SIZE DOESN'T FIT ALL BUT ONE
THING THAT WE'VE BEEN TOSSING
AROUND AS HAVING- A BLOCK GRANT
WHICH COULD BE. A UNIVERSAL FOR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS ON KIDS THAT
ARE VERY. IT VERY FAR BEHIND OR
IT- MISTER O'DONNELL MENTIONED
TO ME EARLIER THIS MORNING-
KIDS THAT ARE JUST RIGHT THERE
BUT THEY HAD A LOSS I LEARNING
LAS WE'RE TRYING TO GET THEM UP
TO SPEED THING GRADUATE GOING
TO COLLEGE AND SO. WHAT WHAT
CAN WE DO TO PROVIDE RESOURCES
RIGHT NOW TO DEAL WITH WHAT WE
ARE FACING. THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA. ALL I THINK YOU
WERE ANTICIPATING- I THINK
FIRST OF ALL A LOT OF DISTRICTS
ARE IN THE GROOVE ON THE
DISTANCE LEARNING THAT THEY'RE
DOING AT HE MOMENT I AM
PICKING UP STEAM AND WE WANT TO
ENCOURAGE THAT TO CONTINUE AS
SOON AS IT IS SAFE IN DIFFERENT
PARTS OF THE STATE TO BEGIN TO
OPEN UP FACILITIES THAT I KNOW
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE IS
LOOKING VERY CAREFULLY AT THE
CRITERIA FOR THAT AND I THINK
THE NEXT THING THAT WE CAN DO
IS SUPPORT. OF BOTH THROUGH THE
CARES ACT WHICH ALLOWS FOR
THEIR SEND IN WHATEVER OTHER
WAYS ARE POSSIBLE- FUNDING FOR
SUMMER SCHOOL AS WE HAVE DONE
IN THE PAST IN THE STATE TO
ENABLE A VARIETY OF STRATEGIES-
DISTRICTS MAY BRING TOGETHER
SMALL GROUPS OF STUDENTS OF FOR
TARGETED WORK ON YOU KNOW
PARTICULAR- AREAS OF THE
CURRICULUM MORE SKILLS AND THEY
MAY DO A COMBINATION OF A
DISTANCE LEARNING AND- IN
PERSON LEARNING THERE ARE SOME
COUNTY OFFICES DEVELOPING A
STRONG. RESOURCES FOR OUR
ONLINE OF SUMMER SCHOOL
LEARNING AS WELL AS FOR IN
PERSON. THERE ARE CERTAIN KINDS
OF- STRATEGIES SPECIFIC TO
LITERACY DEVELOPMENT. SPECIFIC
TO- MATH. DEVELOPMENTS THAT ARE
WELL BEDDED AND CAN BE- MADE
AVAILABLE TO. YOUR DISTRICTS
AND SCHOOLS THAT WANT TO USE
THEM. I THINK IF THERE BE A
VARIETY OF WAYS THAT PEOPLE CAN
APPROACH IT THAT. IT
DIFFERENTLY IN DIFFERENT PLACES
WHATEVER WE DO IN PERSON WILL
HAVE TO HAVE SOCIAL DISTANCING
ASSOCIATED WITH THAT WE'VE BEEN
STUDYING WHAT OTHER COUNTRIES
DO OF WHO HAVE SUCCESSFULLY. A
RE OPENED SCHOOLS OR MAINTAINED
SCHOOLS OPEN THAT WILL- WE ALSO
CHILD CARE FACILITIES ARE USING
SOME OF THOSE STRATEGIES
ALREADY AND SO THAT MAY MEAN
THAT WE CAN'T. ACCOMMODATE.
CLASSROOMS FOR FOLKS SITTING
CLOSE TOGETHER BUT OF TYPICALLY
IN SUMMER SCHOOL THERE ARE
SMALLER GROUPS. AS PART OF IT
SO WILL BE A GOOD TEST CASE FOR
THE HYGIENE AND SPACING AND-
CLEANING STRATEGIES THAT WILL
BE NEEDED IN THE SCHOOL YEAR
ASSUMING WE CAN MOVE FORWARD BY
THEN TO FULL SCHOOL OPENING.
ANYBODY ELSE WANT. QUESTION IS
IF WE DID HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
IN THIS BUDGET TO PROVIDE OF
COURSE WANT TO COVER THE BASIC
FUNDING INCLUDING. THE PROPOSE
COLA FOR SCHOOL DISTRICTS IF WE
HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO DO A- OUT
LEARNING LAS BLOCK GRANTS.
THROUGH THE THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA. WHAT WOULD THAT
LOOK LIKE TO HELP THE DEAL WITH
THAT THE ISSUES THAT WE HAVE
NOW SO YOU KNOW USUALLY WE
PASSED THE BUDGET WE GIVE
RESOURCE THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION NO OFFENSE DEPARTMENT
OF THAT IT TAKES FOUR MONTHS TO
GET THE R. P. TOGETHER. SENATE
OUT IN NOVEMBER APPLICATIONS
COMMAND WE'RE LOOKING AT THE
SEVENTH EIGHTH MONTH AT THE
FISCAL YEAR BEFORE WE STARTED
SO THE IDEA HERE IS WE- PUT
SOME MONEY TOGETHER AND WE WANT
TO START RIGHT DAYS AFTER THE
JULY ONE FISCAL YEAR TO DEAL
WITH THE FACT THAT. LOOK THERE
I'VE TALKED SO MY COLLEAGUES
AND THEY SAY. 50% THE KIDS
HAVING FOUND THEM HAVEN'T THEY
BEEN CALL ON THE OTHER OVER
THERE AT THAT CAN GIVE THEM
CHROMEBOOKS AND HOT SPOTS AND
SO FOR THAT I AM IN AROUND AND
SO. WE HAVE TO DEAL WITH THAT
REALITY AS WELL SO. IF WE WHAT
WOULD IT LOOK LIKE AND HOW CAN
WE CREATE SOMETHING THAT WE
COULD START. JULY ONE RIGHT
AWAY TO HELP DEALING WITH- BUT
WE'VE SEEN WITH THIS LEARNING
LOS THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIANS SO
MANY OF OUR COMMUNITIES. I
DON'T WANT TO OUR PREEMPTS THE
CD RESPONSE ON HOW THEY WOULD
GET THE MONEY AT THE DOOR BUT
I'LL JUST NOTE THAT- SOME YEARS
AGO WE HAD A SUMMER SCHOOL OF
EXPECTATION IN PART OF MONEY.
IT WAS VERY EASY FOR DISTRICTS
TO SAY WE'RE GOING TO PROVIDE
YOU KNOW THIS KIND OF EDUCATION
FOR THIS MANY KIDS APPLICATION
WAS SIMPLE THE FUNDING WAS CUED
UP AND READY TO GO SO OBVIOUSLY
DOESN'T NEED TO- TAKE. A LONG
TIME TO DO THAT IF THERE IS A
FRAMEWORK IN PLACE THAT PEOPLE
AND- SIMPLY FEED INTO. AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY THIS IS
STERILE CAMP AGAIN I'M NOT MY
SUGGESTION WOULD BE FLEXIBILITY
IF THEY'RE GOING TO BE SOME
TYPE OF A BLOCK GRANT TO
MITIGATE THAT LEARNING OFFICE
HAPPENING NOW I WOULD JUST
EMPHASIZE FLEXIBILITY AS YOU
MENTIONED THAT THOUSAND SCHOOL
DISTRICTS CALIFORNIA ALL OF US
ARE AT DIFFERENT PLACES SOME OF
US PROBABLY HAVE PLANS THAT
HAVE THE WHOLE SUMMER SCHOOL
DURING STOP WHEN HE TWENTY I
SOME OF US WERE REDUCING SUMMER
SCHOOL FOR TWENTY TWENTY DUE TO
THAT THE FISCAL CRISIS BEFORE
THE PANDEMIC CRISIS. AND SO I
WOULD LIKE IT'S THE IF THERE'S
A BLACK GRANT SOME TYPE OF
FLEXIBILITY WHERE WE GETNOT
JUST THINK ABOUT SUMMER OF
TWENTY TWENTY I MANY OF OUR
STUDENTS WILL BE WITH US FOR
MULTIPLE SCHOOL YEARS AND
THAT'S WHERE SETTING THEIR
LEARNING NEEDS A MOVING FORWARD
I WE DON'T HAVE TO THINK ABOUT
CATCHING UP IN IN MITIGATING
SUMMER LAW YES CURRENT ART IT
AGAIN IN THE LEARNING LOS JUST
DURING THE SUMMER AS MUCH
FLEXIBILITY WOULD BE HURTS YOU
CAN YOU KNOW WE'VE BEEN TRYING
TO MITIGATE SUMMER LEARNING
LOSS FOR YEARS DURING THE
SCHOOL YEAR. AND I DON'T WANT
TO TAKE SOME OF THOSE AND IT IS
AN OPPORTUNITY TO OFF THE TABLE
AS WE ADJUST TO OUR OUR NEW NOR
THE ONCE AGAIN FLEXIBILITY I
THINK WOULD BE. WOULD BE. OKAY
PARTY THIS. TO BORED ALL. OUT
WE HAVE SOME THAT ARE STARTING
THAT ARE YEAR ROUND SCHOOLS. IN
THEY ACTUALLY START MIDDLE JULY
SO THAT FLEXIBILITY WOULD BE
VERY IMPORTANT BECAUSE- DURING
A TIME WHEN THEY HAVE THEIR
BREAKS THROUGHOUT THE YEAR.
THEY'RE ABLE TO ACTUALLY OFFER
EXTRA LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES
FOR THE STUDENTS DURING THAT
MONTH OP WHEN THEY HAVE THAT
TIME. SO WE WERE JUST TO SAY
IT'S GOING TO BE JUST OVER. THE
SUMMER TIME. THAT WOULD NOT
HELP THOSE STUDENTS THAT ARE IN
THE YEAR ROUND SETTING ARE
READY. AND WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
STARTING UP THE SCHOOL YEAR
EARLIER. IF WE START SOME
SCHOOLS START ALREADY IN JULY.
YOU'RE TALKING JUNE IN JUNE IS
A SOMEWHAT THE WAY AND THEY AND
SCHOOLS JUST DON'T HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PLAN. AND THE
EDUCATORS CAN'T PUT THE INPUT
AND THAT'S- NOR TO MAKE IT
SUCCESSFUL. SO THE FLEXIBLE IS
GONNA BE VERY IMPORTANT. AND
YOU KNOW WHATEVER WE DO YOU
JUST MAKE SURE THE EDUCATORS
PARENTS ARE AT THE TABLE MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE DOING THE- BEST
FOR STUDENTS. HEATHER HELP WITH
A I THINK IT ANOTHER REALLY
IMPORTANT THING TO HIGHLIGHT.
SO YOU THE SAME ACTION. ANY AND
AT RIGHT RIGHT I'M NOT HERE I
KNOW I THINK MOST ANECDOTAL AT
A WIDE. A EIGHT WHAT RIGHT YOUR-
AND YOU OFFER A- ON YOU NEED
BETTER ARTICLE THANK YOU BOTH
AND THEIR IN. THERE ARE GREAT
OF WHAT YOU HAVE OVER MONTHS
RIGHT NOW AT HOW. BEEN ABLE I
ACCESS. SO THAT THAT IN MONEY
IN REALLY REACHING WARMER. YEAH
AND HOW LONG HAVE A THIS IS
ALICIA I THINK ONE OF THE IS
GOING TO AND WITH BLACK GRANTS
TO MAKE SURE THE ALLOCATIONS
ARE WAITED TO ENSURE TO
HEATHER'S POINT THAT THE
STUDENTS WHO NEED THE SUPPORT
AND THE DISTRICTS SENDING THE
MOST SUPPORT ARE GETTING THOSE
RESOURCES- AND ENSURING THAT
THOSE ALLOCATIONS ARE WAITED IN
SUCH A WAY THAT THAT HAPPENS.
OKAY THANK YOU I'M GONNA TURN
IT OVER TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
O'DONNELL OUR EDUCATION SHARED
TALK ABOUT AS WELL BUT JUST. I
SAID EARLIER AND I'LL SAY IT
AGAIN THIS IS AT A TOP PRIORITY
AT THIS SUBCOMMITTEE ALSO. THE
ASSEMBLY IS TRYING TO. COME UP
WITH A BUDGET THAT KEEPS US
RECALL BUT RECOGNIZE EVEN HOLE
WE'VE HAD SOME DAMAGE ACROSS
CALIFORNIA SOME STUDENTS ARE
REALLY BEHIND. AND AS WE SEE
FROM THEIR RESEARCH FROM THAT
TRUST WES IT'S- CERTAINLY IN
CERTAIN COMMUNITIES WE KNOW
THAT IT'S EVEN WORSE AND SO WE
NEED TO BE MINDFUL THAT AND TRY
TO PROVIDE. FLEXIBILITY AS WE
HEARD JUST NOW FOR DISTRICTS
AND SCHOOLS TO ADDRESS THIS-
BEFORE KIDS GET BACK AT IT THIS
FALL ASSEMBLYMEMBER O'DONNELL.
YES AT THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN JUST WITH REGARD TO
YOUR YOUR DISCUSSION OF SUMMER
SCHOOL FROM MY PERSPECTIVE JUST
SITTING HERE TODAY ESPECIALLY
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT THE HIGH
SCHOOL LEVEL- SUMMER SCHOOL IS
MUCH MORE IMPORTANT THAN JUST
STARTING THE SCHOOL YEAR EARLY-
WHY. BECAUSE A HIGH SCHOOL
TEACHER I THINK OF CREDITS I
THINK OF CREDIT. DEFICIENCY AND
I THINK OF GPA. SO I KNOW WE
TALKED ABOUT SUMMER SCHOOL SOME
FOLKS ARE JUST WORRIED ABOUT
THOSE KIDS WHO ARE MAYBE CREDIT
DEFICIENT AND WE SHOULD BE
WORRIED ABOUT THOSE KIDS. BUT
WE SHOULD ALSO- FOCUS ON THOSE
STUDENTS AND A KIND OF THE
WATER. THEY MIGHT NEED TO BUMP
UP THEIR GPA A BET TO GET INTO
COLLEGE NEXT YEAR. OR THE YEAR
AFTER- SOME SCHOOL DISTRICTS
HAVE GONE TO CREDIT NO CREDIT-
THAT'S OKAY FROM MY PERSPECTIVE
I OWN LOCAL DISTRICT AT THAT
BUT NEXT DOOR DOWNEY. I THINK
THEY HAVE IT WHAT THEY DID WAS
THEY WANT TO CREDIT NO CREDIT
AND THEN STUDENT CAN CHOOSE TO
BE GRADED. IF THEY SO DESIRE
BUT WHY IS IT SO IMPORTANT FOR
SOME OF THOSE STUDENTS WHO ARE.
ARE REALLY YOU DON'T TRY TO
PUSH THEIR GPA UP AND GET INTO
A CERTAIN COLLEGE THEY NEED.
THE GPA NUMBERS THEY DON'T NEED
A CREDIT NO CREDIT THEY'RE
GOING TO PASS. BUT THEY NEED
THE GPA NUMBER SO I REALLY
ENCOURAGE SCHOOL DISTRICTS
ACROSS THE STATE OF ENCOURAGE
MY OWN. QUITE FRANKLY TO- TO
TAKE A LOOK AT THAT WELL WHAT
I'LL CALL THE DOWNEY MODEL SOME
DISTRICTS ALREADY MIGHT BE
IMPLYING THAT MODEL AS WELL. IN
FACT I THINK THEY ARE WITH
REGARD TO ACCESS AND
CONNECTIVITY. I THOUGHT I HEARD
THE NUMBERS REFLECTED THAT YOU
KNOW FOR HER THOUSAND STUDENTS
DIDN'T HAVE ACCESS TO ONLINE
LEARNING BECAUSE THEY MIGHT NOT
HAVE THE DEVICE THEY MIGHT NOT
HAVE- THE- THE HOT SPOT
WHATEVER IT MAY BE THOSE
NUMBERS ARE LARGE BUT REMEMBER
WE DO HAVE SIX WHAT SIX POINT
TWO MILLION STUDENTS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. SO I WE
CERTAINLY NEED TO FOCUS ON
THOSE THOSE FOUR HUNDRED
THOUSAND WE HAVE ANOTHER
PROBLEM IS REALLY A SOCIAL
PROBLEM BEYOND- CONNECTIVITY IS
NOT SUCH A TANGIBLE PROBLEM
AGAIN AS IT IS A SOCIAL PROBLEM
AS SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE.
HANDING OUT DEVICES AND THEN
THE KIDS NEVER GET ON THEM-
BECAUSE OF SITUATIONS AT HOME
SO WE NEED TO THINK ABOUT HOW
WE THE ADDRESS US WE JUST CAN'T
POINT IT HANDING OUT COMPUTERS
AS THE SOLE SOLUTION THAT
SEEMED LIKE PART OF THE
SOLUTION FOR SURE. AND THAT'S
HAPPENED BECAUSE I CAN TELL YOU
I ONE BY ONE OF OUR HIGH
SCHOOLS THERE WAS THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE IN LINE AND THEY WERE
ALL GETTING COMPUTERS. BUT THE
NEXT STEP IS THEY NEED TO
ACCESS THE ONLINE LEARNING FROM
FROM HOME AND I REALIZE OUR
SITUATIONS OR THAT CAN BE VERY
DIFFICULT AND THAT IS WHAT HOW
IDENTIFY THE SOCIAL PROBLEM OF
THAT- WHAT ELSE DID I WANT TO
TALK ABOUT HERE- AND THEN RE
OPENING SCHOOLS WE TALK ABOUT
RE OPEN THE SCHOOLS I HOPE WE
PAY ATTENTION THE DIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA. CERTAINLY IN PEOPLE
BUT ALSO IN GEOGRAPHY- IT MIGHT
BE APPROPRIATE FOR SOME SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO RE OPEN AND NOT
SOMEOTHERS WE SHOULDN'T JUST
HAVE A ONE SIZE FITS ALL
APPROACH NO I'M NOT OUT OF THE
ON BOARD WITH MR GALLAGHER'S
APPROACH GOD LOVE HIM. BUT WE
APPRECIATE YOUR THOUGHTS ON
THAT BUT I DO THINK WE NEED TO
THINK ABOUT YOU THERE SO SCHOOL
WORK DRIVE THEY GET THE BUST ON
A BUS OR TO A- TO GET SCHOOL.
AND SO. IN OF THE JUSTICE THERE
THEY THEIR THEY'RE IN PLACE FOR
THE SCHOOLS ARE VERY LARGE AND
THEY MIGHT NOT HAVE- YOU KNOW
ITREAL DENSE POPULATION WERE
MIGHT BE APPROPRIATE FOR THE
SCHOOLS TO RE OPEN. EVERY DAY-
AND IT MIGHT NOT BE APPROPRIATE
IN A MORE URBAN AREA I DON'T
HAVE. THE SCIENTIFIC EXPERTISE
TO SAY WHETHER OR NOT THAT'S
ACTOR BUT I THINK THAT'S REALLY
SOMETHING WE OUGHT TO THINK
ABOUT IT SHOULDN'T BE JUST
AGAIN. A ONE SIZE FITS ALL AND
JUST ONE QUESTION MAYBE FOR THE
TO. THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
DEPARTMENTS CATION ARE WE GOING
TO PROVIDE A SCHOOL MEALS
THROUGH THE SUMMER IS THEIR
PLAN TO DO THAT NOW. MAYBE
SOMEONE COULD COMMENT ON THAT.
AND THE CHAIRS IN HERE SO IF
YOU COULD WEIGH IN. THE OTHER
CHAIRS. THIS IS JUST GOT HOME
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE-
I WILL DEFER TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION TO- DISCUSS THE
SUMMER NUTRITION PROGRAMS THAT.
ARE AVAILABLE TO SCHOOL
DISTRICTS. SO WE'RE DEFERRING
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION ARE
THEY STILL ON. YES THIS IS A CD
EVEN YOU HAVE A SUMMER EMAIL
PROGRAMS AND SO ON YES WE ARE
WE ARE PLANNING TO CONTINUE OUR
CURRENT. OUR GRANT. AND ALONG
THOSE LINES WITH REGARD TO THE
SERVER MEALS PROGRAM. DO YOU
KNOW HOW MANY DISTRICTS HAVE
NOT SIGNED UP FOR THAT AND
MAYBE WE SHOULD PAY ATTENTION
TO THOSE DISTRICTS BECAUSE I.
DID HAVE A SITUATION NEAR MY
OWN ASSEMBLY DISTRICT IN A
SCHOOL DISTRICT WHERE IN THE
THEY OPTED NOT TO PROVIDE THE
MEALS AND THAT BECAME A REAL
ISSUE FOR THE COMMUNITY THE
KIDS WERE ACTUALLY GOING. DO
YOU HAVE ANY NUMBERS RELATED TO
THAT. WHAT WILL DEFINITELY GET
BACK TO YOU WITH THOSE FIGURES
AND AGAIN I WHEN I'D LIKE TO
KNOW IT'S JUST SO YOU KNOW WHAT
I'M AND YOU MAY NOT HAVE IT YOU
MAY HAVE IT IS G. WHAT
DISTRICTS HAVEN'T SIGNED UP MY
UNDERSTANDING TO THE SUMMER
MEALS PROGRAM IT COULD BE A
LOCAL YMCA. THAT PROVIDES THOSE
MEALS FROM MY UNDERSTANDING IN
OTHER WORDS CAN BE NON ELEAZAR
DO PROVIDE MEALS AS WELL SO
THAT MAY BE THE OUTLET FOR THE
MALES IN THAT COMMUNITY I WANNA
BE SENSITIVE TO THAT FACT AS
WELL SO WITH THAT IF YOU GIVE
ME THAT INFORMATION TO BE MOST
APPRECIATIVE I THINK I'M-
TURNING BACK TO MISTER CHAIR. I
GUESS I'M NOT. ONE SOMETHING
FROM. MCCARTY ON. A REAL
APPRECIATE. THE PANEL FOR.
THEIR PRESENTATION IS THE FOR
WHAT THE TO THAT WE BECAUSE-
YEAH LET'S JUST CAUCUS HAVE
PROBABLY SO OF THE- MOST BOY.
CONVERSATION IS NOT HARD TO SEE
WHY I'M NOT LOOKING AT THE
DíAS I SEE LOT OF PARENTS A
SCHOOL KIDS I THINK WE'VE- THIS.
HAD THEM BECAUSE IN EVERY
PARENT WITH CHILDREN IN SCHOOL
WERE ALL. JUGGLING IT TO WHAT'S
BEST FOR KIDS AND ALL THE AND
INCOME. I'M I THINK WHAT'S
WHAT'S- IS HI I SEE IF. YOU
KNOW THE SUPER DOT CAN. SORT OF.
SORT OF WAY. WHAT HIS WISH LIST
IS THE NIGHT I'M HERE FROM MR
BOARD SORT OF WHAT. WITH THIS A
WHICH WAS IS IN A LOT OF.
FINANCIAL FOR. IT'S IS WHICH
ARE WHICH I THINK IS A- TO ASK
FOR BUT WHAT I DON'T HE SEE ANY
ANY OF THE- RECOMMENDATION ARE
SOME OF. RECOMMENDED THAT A
TRUST WORTH PUSH FOR WHICH IS
SORT OF YOU KNOW HAVING SOME
SOME SAY. HAVING SOME ACCOUNT
OF HAVING SO. SPECIFIC
PROTOCOLS AND I AND I WAS EVEN
MORE BY THE OF IT RESPONSE OF
WELL YOU KNOW WE YOU KNOW
GUIDELINE AWAY BUT GOVERNOR'S
IT'S KINDA LIKE EVERY PERSON
FOR THEMSELVES. AND NOT.
UNDERSTAND ITS GREAT THAT- YOUR
HOST AND WEBINARS BUT WEBINARS
ARE NOT. VERY BASIC- GUIDELINES
ARE IN FACT. YOUR RESPONSE WAS
SO CONCERNING DOCTOR WEBER TEXT
ME FROM SAN DIEGO BECAUSE SHE'S
WATCHING THE HEARING RIGHT NOW
YOUR YOUR TASK FORCE CULTURE.
SO OF A SINCE WE COULDN'T WITH
TALK ABOUT PANELIST LIST GO
BACK TALK TO DEPARTMENT OF ED
IS SORT OF LIKE. YOU KNOW
YOU'RE OFFER GUY TO THEIR-
DEPARTMENTS. AT WHAT POINT DO
YOU DEVELOP SOME BASS LINES OF.
INSTRUCTION UNDER. THIS TYPE OF
ENVIRONMENT. AND OFFER GUIDANCE
DAHLE YOUR COUNTIES.
THIS IS
JULIE WELL AS DIRECTOR OF
GOVERNMENT THE CALIFORNIA
EDUCATE YET THEY YOU FOR YOUR
QUESTION WEEK WE HEAR YOU SIR
AND YOU KNOW WE ARE WITH THE
SUPERINTENDENT IS WORKING AS
FAR AS I'M WORKING WITH DOCTOR
WEBER AND OTHERS TO FIGURE OUT
HOW WE CAN FIGHT BETTER
GUIDANCE AS OUR DOCTOR
STEPHANIE GRAYSON MENTIONED
BEFORE. WE ARE LOW CONSOLE
STATE AND OF TRYING TO WORK
CLOSE WITH THE KIND OFFICES
EDUCATION TO PROVIDE THEM WITH
GUIDANCE THAT THEY CAN BETTER
SERVE CONCORD COPY THERE ARE
YOUR WORLD LOCAL STATE THE
WHITE WE HAVE THIS DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION. OUR OUR OUR- HERE
IN OUR POP YEARS AGO LITTLE
SUPPLY. OUR SCHOOL AND OUR
DISTRICT IN OUR COUNTY. OF THE
STATUTE INTO. THAT WE ARE YOU
WE ARE ABLE TO RUN UNDER
SUPPORT. ARE YOU OFFERING THEM
DURING THIS. PANDEMIC AND I
UNDERSTAND YOU KNOW WE'RE ALL
WE'RE ALL WORKING. UNDER A VERY
DIFFERENT SITUATION THAN WE
WERE WORKING UNDER AN UNDER
FEDERAL OUR SITE TO I TOTALLY
UNDERSTAND THIS IS NEW
TERRITORY. MY CONCERN. IS I
DIDN'T HEAR HEY WE'RE
DEVELOPING GUIDELINES HEY WE'RE
DEVELOPING BASS LINES HEY
WE'RE- DEVELOPING NEW
ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURES WERE
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND. YOU KNOW
WHAT. WHAT IS THE DEPARTMENT
DEVELOPING TO OFFER BECAUSE THE
COUNTIES DON'T HAVE. THE
STAFFING THAT YOU DO TO DEVELOP
THESE GUIDELINES THAT YOUR JOB.
SO WHAT ARE YOU DOING. TO OFFER
AND I'M NOT CONCERNED I HAVE
THE GOVERNMENT RELATIONS PERSON
HERE AFTER HAVING TO BE EDUCATE
WHERE WHERE DID ALL THE
EDUCATION EXPERTS GO. THAT
HELPS. DEPARTMENT IS WORKING
COLLABORATIVELY ACROSS VARIETY
OF AREAS INCLUDING THE MOST
TASK FORCE THAT. I LOOK AT YOU
GOT HOUSE CAN BE A VARIETY OF
ISSUE INCLUDING AS WE KNOW
EARLIER THE LAW ISSUE WE THE
DIGITAL. DIVIDE AS AS A MOBILE
ISSUE WERE NOT AT WHAT GUY
DISTRICTS AND SCHOOLS WILL BE
TO ENTER I RE OPEN OR EVEN
SUMMER WELL SO WE ARE BE AND WE
ARE WITH THE STATE OR ABOUT. I
ALL THOSE BAD IN THOSE OF AREAS
ALL A PART. EXPANDED LEARNING
OUR EARLY EDUCATION CURRICULUM
FRAMEWORKS AND INSTRUCTIONAL
RESOURCES DIVISION FISCAL THERE
AS YOU KNOW IT IS A
MULTIFACETED ISSUE SO EACH
DECISION THAT REQUIRES US TO
WORK IN CANADA SO WE ARE DOING
THAT YOU'RE ALSO WORKING WITH.
THE FINANCE THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE I WE HAVE CHAMPIONS
STABBING ON THE RIGHT BASIS
WHAT THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE THE
PARTS. AND AGAIN WE'RE AND IT
OUR EXTRA I PARTNERS. SO YOU WE
ARE TO GUIDED WE DO HAVE GUIDED
POSTED OUR WEBSITE THAT IS AS
AS THEY ARE ELLIE EIGHTIES IN
GETTING THROUGH WHAT YOU CALL
THE E. IT NEEDS INCLUDING THAT
SOME OF THE STATE AND WORK. AND
WORK AND TO WORK A LOT OF OUR
TO AS WELL TO US AND LIGHTED SO
YES ANSWER YOUR WE ARE WORKING
ON THAT AND I THINK THE IT'S A
MARK AND WE'RE WORSE MISS GRAY.
FOR ME FOR DISCUSSION FOR SO.
AGAIN MY AND MY CONCERN IS I
UNDERSTAND THE NEW NORM. IS
ZOOM MEETINGS BUT LET'S NOT.
LET'S NOT REPLACE ZOO MEETINGS
WITH GUIDELINES OR
ACCOUNTABILITY METRICS WHICH I
BELIEVE THE DEPARTMENT IS IN
CHARGE OF. IT IN ADDITION- I
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE IS A LOT
OF DISCUSSION LOT OF
STAKEHOLDERS LOT OF TALK. BUT
LET US NOT CONFUSE THEIR FROM
WE NEED SOME. GUIDELINES AND
SOME ACTION SORT OF IMMEDIATELY
BECAUSE- RIGHT RIGHT NOW HERE'S
WHAT'S HAPPENING YOU YOU CAN
NOT. NOT ONLY IS THERE A LACK
OF GUIDELINES. ACROSS DISTRICT
THERE'S A LACK OF GUIDELINES
WITHIN A DISTRICT. YOU KNOW
THIRD THE THIRD GRADE IS NOT
BEING TAUGHT THE SAME WAY BY
EVERY THIRD GRADE TEACHER MY
DISTRICT. I AM SURE THAT'S THE
WAY IT IS AND DISTRICTS ALL.
AROUND THE STATE AND I
UNDERSTAND THAT THIS MAY BE
OKAY FOR THE NEXT MONTH OR TWO
JUST BECAUSE- THIS IS THE
SITUATION THAT WE HAVE TO DEAL
WITH. BUT IT SHOULD IT SURE AS
HECK CAN'T BE OKAY IF WE START
SCHOOL IN JULY. AND A BETTER
NOT BE OKAY FOR AUGUST OR
SEPTEMBER- BECAUSE IT THIS IS
THE- IF THIS IS THE WAY THAT
THINGS ARE GOING BY WHAT IT
WOULD JUST TAKE OFF. JUST DO A
REGISTER YOUR LET'S JUST TAKE
OFF YOUR- LET'S JUST LET'S JUST
LET'S JUST. CALL WHAT IT IS. IF
THEY'RE NO GUIDELINES IN EVERY
EVERY EVERY TEACHER FOR HIM OR
HERSELF. SO AGAIN THIS IS THIS
IS SOME YOU KNOW. THIS IS EVEN
MORE CONCERNING BECAUSE WHAT
I'D HOPE IS AS A PARENT I WOULD
FEEL REASSURED AFTER THIS PANEL
AND I AM EVEN MORE. CONCERNED
AFTERWARDS AND KNOWING THAT
AGAIN THE STATE HAS DONE ITS
JOB WE HELD DISTRICTS HARMLESS
AND WE THINK WE KNOW WE HEARD
THE WHOLE HATE TRUST US AND WE
AND WE SAID YES WE TRUST YOU.
WANNA HOLD EVERYBODY HARMLESS
WE WANT TO KEEP EVERYONE GOING
BUT THIS IS EXTRAORDINARILY
CONCERNING THAT IT'S LIKE WE'RE
GOING INTO THE WILD WEST. AND
SO EVERYBODY JUST GETS TO DO
WHATEVER THE WHATEVER THE HECK
THEY WANT AND I DON'T I DON'T
THINK THAT'S OKAY BECAUSE IF
THAT IF THAT'S THE CASE THEN
YOU KNOW WHY DON'T WHY DON'T WE
ALL JUST TAKE A YEAR OFF IN THE
LIST LET'S COME BACK. LET'S
COME BACK FOR THE FALL OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TO REGROUP.
IS THAT IS THAT WERE. SEC
AFTERNOON- THE SUSPECT A GREAT
SIN REJOINING IN MY APOLOGIES
WE HAD A VERY ANOTHER MEETING
SCHEDULED IN FACT INTERVIEW
SCHEDULED WORK IN AND IT'S
YEARS HE- PRIOR TO KNOWING
ABOUT THIS HEARING SO THAT'S
THE REASON WHY WE HAD TO I HAD
TO LEAVE AT NOON SO I AM
GETTING BRIEFED VERY QUICKLY
CAUGHT UP ON THE CONVERSATION I
UNDERSTAND ASSEMBLY MEMBER TEAM
THERE'S CONCERNS AROUND THE
ROLE OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION WHEN WE HAVE A- LOCAL
CONTROL AND THAT YOU HAVE
QUESTIONS AROUND TWO GUIDELINES
FOR ACROSS THE STATE- ARE
BASICALLY A STANDARD IS CHEN
ACROSS THE STATE. FORCED YOU
LEARNING IN ACCOUNTABILITY FOR
THAT IS THAT CORRECT ABSOLUTELY
SALAS AGAIN JUST TO JUST TO BE
CLEAR I KNOW WE HAVE- FINANCIAL
FLEXIBILITY IN TERMS LOCAL
CONTROL THOSE PEOPLE LOCAL
CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA I AM
NOT AROUND FINANCIAL
FLEXIBILITY- YOU KNOW I DIDN'T
REALIZE THAT WE HAD- YOU KNOW
EVERY EVERY. DISTRIBUTOR JUST
DO WHATEVER THE- WHAT WHATEVER
THEY WANT TO THAT WAS A MY JUST
OF THE SYSTEM WE HAVE IN THE
STATE. SO IS A GHETTO. MY
QUESTION WAS JUST JUST TO
REITERATE IT WAS. WHAT WHAT
GUIDELINES IS THE DEPARTMENT
PUTTING FORWARD TO REALLY GIVE.
GUIDANCE TO THE DISTRICTS WITH
THE GIVE GUIDANCE TO THE
COUNTIES. BECAUSE RIGHT NOW
HERE'S WHAT'S HAPPENING WHICH
WHICH I UNDERSTAND BECAUSE
WE'RE IN A PANDEMIC THIS IS A
STATE OF EMERGENCY. IS NOT ONLY
IS THERE NOT CONSISTENCY.
ACROSS DISTRICT THERE'S NOT
EVEN A DECIDED BECAUSE THIS IS
THE WITHIN DISTRICTS AND HOW
TEACHERS ARE TEACHING THIRD
GRADE OR- A TEACHER TO TEACHER
FOURTH GRADE. SO AT SOME POINT
YOUR DEPARTMENT IN CHARGE OF.
CREATING GUIDELINES
ACCOUNTABILITY. INCONSISTENCIES
SO WHAT WHAT WHAT ARE YOU GOING
TO BE PUTTING OUT GUIDELINES SO
IF IN FACT WE DO. START IN JULY
OR AUGUST BECAUSE WE'RE
SUPPOSED TO START SCHOOL IN
AUGUST IN SAN FRANCISCO. THAT
WE'RE GONNA HAVE SOME. ACROSS
THE STATE ACCOUNTABILITY. THIS
IS MULTI FACETED WE DO HAVE AN
ACCOUNTABILITY SYSTEM WE'VE HAD
ACCOUNTABILITY SYSTEM ACROSS
THE STATE OR SEVERAL YEARS YOU
CAN SEE THAT ON OUR CALIFORNIA
SHOOL DASHBOARDS. AND WE HAVE
A STANDARDIZATION A LONG. MON
AROUND WHAT STUDENTS SHOULD BE
LEARNING AT THE END OF EACH
GRADE LEVEL AND THE AT THE END
OF THEIR SCHOOL CAREER WE HAVE.
SINCE WE HAVE BEEN ON HOW TO
HELP TEACHERS OF STUDENTS MEET
THE STANDARDS WITH OUR
CURRICULUM FRAMEWORKS WE ALSO
HAVE OUR ASSESSMENTS THAT SHOW
US YOU WHERE STUDENTS. AND
THEIR LEARNING AND WHAT WE NEED
TO DO MORE TO ENHANCE THEIR
LEARNING AND MAKE SURE THEY'RE
PROGRESSING TOWARDS THEIR-
DOUBLE STANDARDS SO WE DO HAVE
THE CAPABILITY ACROSS THE
STATE. DURING THIS TIME I I'D
LIKE TO REMIND US IS ONLY SIX
WEEKS. AND DO WE ASKED TO OVER
TEN THOUSAND SCHOOLS TO PIVOT
TO DISTANCE LEARNING. WE A VERY
SHORT TIME FRAME THAT ALSO
MEANS THAT WE'VE HAD TO ADAPT.
OUR ASSESSMENT PIECE ARE YOU
ARE ACCOUNTABILITY PIECE- WHILE
ALSO ENSURING THAT STUDENTS ARE
SAFE. AND SO DURING THIS TIME
WE HAVE BEEN PROVIDING THAT
GUIDANCE YOU'VE TALKED ABOUT
AROUND WHAT QUALITY DISTANCE
LEARNING LOOKS LIKE FOR EVERY
STUDENTS. WE HAVE BEEN WORKING
WITH THE COUNTY OFFICES AND
WITHDISTRICTS SUPERINTENDENTS
THROUGHOUT THIS ENTIRE SIX
WEEKS TO FIGURE OUT WHAT THEIR
NEEDS ARE HOW WE CAN BEST
SUPPORT THEM AND GET THEIR
NEEDS MET. ONE EXAMPLE OF THAT
IS THE DIGITAL DIVIDE TASK
FORCE AND THE DONATIONS FOR
DEVICES THAT HAVE BEEN COMING
IN. AND SO WE HAVE BEEN DOING
OUR DUE DILIGENCE. OR THAT
EVERY DISTRICTS NOW EVERY
STUDENT IS GETTING WHAT THEIR
NEEDS. NOW IT'S DIFFERENT. YEAH
WE HAVE A TEN THOUSAND SCHOOLS
ACROSS THE STATE. WITH A- AXE.
AS A AND SO THAT THE- TO DO AS-
BUT WE HAVE BEEN WORKING WITH
ALL OF OUR PARTNERS AT THE
COUNTY IS THAT WITH THE
DISTRICT LEVELS WITH OUR LABOR
AND MANAGEMENT PARTNERS. TO
ENSURE THAT WE ARE ALL WORKING
TOGETHER AND I THINK THAT'S ONE
THING THAT- I WOULD WE NEED TO
REMIND OURSELVES THAT WE ALL
HAVE A COLLECTIVE
RESPONSIBILITY OR WHERE WERE
ADDS IN THIS TIME. WE ALL HAVE
A COLLECTIVE RESPONSIBILITY FOR
OUR EDUCATION SYSTEM AS A
WHOLE. AND SO WHEN WE'RE
WORKING TOGETHER TO INSURE THAT
WE ARE PROVIDING THAT QUALITY
GUIDANCE AND EVERY STUDENTS
BENEFITS. SO WITHOUT FOR A
MISSING ON. THE FULL PICTURE
MAYBE YOU CAN OFFER ME WHAT IS
YOUR- DIGITAL LEARNING GUIDANCE
THAT YOU ARE OFFERING IN TERMS
OF YOUR YOUR- PRACTICE THAT
YOU'RE ENCOURAGING. DISTRICTS
TUB THOR COUNTIES TO LOOK AT.
WE HAVE WEBINARS SEVERAL OF IN
OUR CENTER WEBSITE THAT YOU CAN
WATCH- ONE OF THEM IS
SPECIFICALLY AROUND THE KEY
PRINCIPLES IN DISTANCE LEARNING
AND SHINNING COATS AND I DID
THAT OURSELVES- WE DOING
RESEARCH WITH OUR TEACHER
PARTNERS ARE DISTRICT PARTNERS
AND DISTANCE LEARNING EXPERTS
AT FROM HARVARD AND YOU HAVE. A
SEAT. AND SO THAT IS RESEARCH
BASED IN AB IS EVIDENCE BASED
SO ALL OF OUR GUIDANCE IS
RESEARCH AND EVIDENCE BASED.
AND THEN HOW DO HOW DO YOU
ENSURE ASSUMING THAT- PERHAPS
WE WILL BE DOING. THIS TYPE OF
LEARNING WHEN THE SCHOOL YEAR
STARTS IN THE FALL. OR MAYBE
SOME HYBRID HOW DO YOU ENSURE
SOME CONTINUITY. BETWEEN
DISTRICTS. AND THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE WORKING ON CURRENTLY NOW
AS DEVELOPING THAT CONTINUITY
PLAN OF WHAT THAT HYBRID
SITUATION COULD LOOK LIKE YEAH
THIS REALLY SPEAKS TO THE
PUBLIC SAFETY POWER SHUT DOWN-
AS WELL AND WILDFIRES SO WE
KNOW THAT WHAT WE ARE LEARNING
FROM THIS PANDEMIC CAN.
TRANSLATE INTO HOW WE SERVE
STUDENTS DURING WILDFIRES IN
PUBLIC SAFETY HOW ARE SHOT
SHUTDOWNS SO WE ARE TAKING THE
KNOWLEDGE THAT WE LEARNED FROM
WILDFIRES AND FROM THIS
PANDEMIC AND WE WILL BE
CREATING THAT PLAN OF
CONTINUITY FOR SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
WHEN DO YOU PLAN ON RELEASING
THAT PLAN. I WILL BE WORKING
WITH THE FAMILY MEMBER WEBER
AND OUR PARTNERS AT C. T. EIGHT
TOBY BLADE AND ARDS STAFF HERE
AT C. D. E. AMONG OTHER TASK
FORCE MEMBERS TO CREATE THAT
PLAN WE'RE HOPING THAT WE CAN
HAVE THAT OUT THE BEGINNING OF
SUMMER. IF NOT SOONER WHAT I'M
SORRY WHAT DO YOU RIGHTS. SO
SUMMER TECHNICALLY BEGINS WHAT
THE THIRD WEEK OF JUNE IS THAT
WHAT YOU'RE- SAYING IS A TIME
ONE. I NORMALLY SCHOOL
DISTRICTS THAT AND THEIR SCHOOL
YEARS SECOND OR THIRD WEEK AS
OF JUNE WE DO HAVE SOME SCHOOL
DISTRICTS THAT GOT OUT AT THE
END OF MAY. SO WHEN YOU SAY
BEGINNING OF SUMMER WHAT DO YOU
MEAN I'M SORRY. BEGINNING IN
pTHEIR LOOK THE REASON THIS IS
VERY CONCERNING IS AGAIN I KNOW
WE'VE HAD TO ADAPT VERY
QUICKLY- I APPLAUD EVERYBODY
FOR BEING VERY VERY FLEXIBLE.
BUT AGAIN- THAT CONCERN IS- THE-
COMPLETE LACK OF ACCOUNTABILITY
ACROSS- ACROSS THE STATE AND
IT'S VERY CONCERNING BECAUSE
AGAIN- FOR ALL OF THIS COULD
HAVE BEEN VERY FOCUSED ON THE
CHEAP GAS. THERE'S A CONCERT.
FURTHER EXACERBATED WE WERE
SEEING THE EQUITY GAP BE
EXACERBATED IN TERMS OF WHO'S
DYING FROM THIS DISEASE BECAUSE
THEY YOU KNOW CERTAIN PEOPLE
HAVE TO GO TO WORK. AND THEY'RE
NOT GETTING THE KIND OF
PROTECTION- IN SEOUL THERE IS A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF CONCERN
THAT IF THE DEPARTMENT IT IS
NOT SHOWING. THE SET OF
GUIDELINES TO REALLY OFFER A
BASELINE IN EVERYBODY CAN JUST
KINDA DO WHATEVER THEY WANT
WILL BE FULLY AWAITING YOUR
GUARD BEGIN OF CHEN. I'M JUST
GONNA GO BACK TO. SORT OF
DOCTOR CAMP IN THEN TO THE
DOCTOR ARE IAGO FOR SECOND IF I
COULD MISTER CHAIR. AND JUST
GOING TO THE DOCTOR CAMPAñA ME
WHAT WE HAVE HERE. YOU KNOW
WAIT WAIVERS ON MINIMUM SCHOOL
DAYS WAIVERS ON MINUTES YOU
KNOW ALL ALL THESE VERY THAT
YOU KNOW THE FEW- BASELINE SORT
OF EDUCATION GUIDELINES THAT WE
HAVE TO HAVE CONSISTENCY IS
MIKE'S DISTRICT HOW HOW IF WE
IF WE DID WAIVE THESE HOW COULD
WE BE AS A SURE OF THAT- YOU.
STUDENTS WOULD BE GET. ORDER
VIA A PROPER. QUALITY EDUCATION
IN YOUR IN YOUR DISTRICT. WHERE
ARE THE OTHER DISTRICTS ACROSS
THE STATE. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER I REALLY APPRECIATE THE
QUESTION- I WHAT I'M FINDING
RIGHT NOW IS THAT- NUMBER
SCHOOL DISTRICT YOU JUST
ADJUSTING TO OUR NEW DOOR.
OBVIOUSLY THERE'S BEEN A HUGE
FOCUS WITH MANY SCHOOL
DISTRICTS US GETTING THAT COULD
THE CONNECTIVITY AND THE DEVICE
IN THE HANDS OF THE STUDENT.
I'M JUST PATCHING IN THE NEXT
YEAR SO- WHAT I'M HEARD FROM A
NUMBER OF SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE
THAT IF WE'RE EXPECTED TO.
SUPPORT THE EFFORT. L.
STANDPOINT GONNA HAVE YOUR
STUDENTS IN THE BUILDING AND AS
WELL AS THAT WE HAVE TO GET
SOME FLEXIBILITY AS AFGHAN
STUDENTS I WILL NEED
OPPORTUNITIES TO THE QUARANTINE
I IF THEY TEST POSITIVE FOR
COVERT NINETEEN OR IF THEY HAVE
INTERACTIONS- SO GIVEN THAT I
WHAT I'VE HEARD FROM THE FIELD
IS THAT IT'S NOT SET UP A
SYSTEM SIMILAR TO THE
INDEPENDENT STUDY SYSTEM. IT'S
A VERY- WAS BIRD AT SOME TRYING
TO TRACK OR QUALITY OUR WANNA
FIGHT STUDENT WORK REDUCTIONS
IN DAYS IN SCHOOL I JUST THINK
GIVEN OUR OUR CIRCUMSTANCES. I
HEAR FROM EDUCATED EVERY DAY
THEY THEY'RE STRESSED ABOUT THE
STUDENTS THAT THEY HAVE NOT
BEEN OVER THE CONTACT. THEIR
ALSO STRESSED ABOUT CONTACT AND-
HAVING A PRODUCTIVE USE OF TIME
FOR THE STUDENTS THAT WE ARE IN
CONTACT WITH. US SO MY- I GUESS
MY WARNING WOULD BE LET'S NOT
CREATE ANOTHER SYSTEM WHERE YOU
HAVE TO WEAR IS UP
ACCOUNTABILITY AND THAT THAT AT
THIS GOOD THIS IS ARE AFRAID OF
ACCOUNTABILITY BUT WE'RE WE'RE
REALLY ADJUSTING. AND IT'S
GONNA BE HARD TO THE DESIGN A
SYSTEM ON PAPER THAT SAY THIS
IS WHAT WE CLEARLY. EXPECT NOT
ONLY FOR THE SCHOOL SYSTEM BUT
FOR THE FAMILIES IF YOU'RE A
FAN STILL HAVING A DIFFICULT
TIME WITH COMPLETING WORK OR
TENDING. TO THE OTHER
OBLIGATIONS THAT THEY HAPPEN TO
MEMBERS THAT THEY HAVE BEEN
HOME ARE WE AT THE SCHOOL
SYSTEM GOING TO HOLD THE
STUDENT FAMILY ACCOUNTABLE TO
THE TRADITIONAL SYSTEMS LIKE
THE STUDENT ATTENDANCE REVIEW
BOARD. AND I WHICH IS A VERY
COMPETENT IN THEIR DOES ALL
THESE QUESTIONS AND I THINK WE
NEED TO ERR ON THE SIDE OF
REYES. AS WE TO SUPPORT OUR
FAMILIES. BOB WE'RE GOING WE'RE
GOING TO HELP CRISIS AN
ECONOMIC CRISIS FOR MANY OF OUR
FAMILIES. AND I THINK WE'RE
GONNA HAVE TO LOOK OUTSIDE OF
OUR TRADITIONAL WAYS OF
ACCOUNTABILITY. IN ORDER TO
SUPPORT OUR COMMUNITY DURING
THIS TIME- WE'RE GONNA LEARN.
AT MY LAST. BE I THINK WE YOU
LEARN A LOT WHEN THERE IS A
SIGNIFICANT NUMBER
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE I ALWAYS
MENTION ACCESS BECAUSE ACT THAT
HAS THE- THE ABILITIES TO
CONVENE. WE'RE OF. SCHOOL
MANAGE DATERS VERY RAPID LEAD
TO HAVE CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
THIS. OP THE I KNOW MY JOB AS A
SUPERINTENDENT BUT I DON'T KNOW
EVERY SINGLE ASPECT OF SCHOOLS.
AND A CANNOT. BE WITH INTENDED
AND ALL THAT. ACCESO WITHOUT
ABILITY TO COMPETE IN A GROUP
THAT WOULD GO ON THESE ISSUES
ON A DAY TO. I'M IN. I TO
BEFORE WE- WHAT WHAT. TO BE
GREAT I THINK IT I THINK LAW. I
I'M DEFINITELY NOT ADVOCATE.
MEASUREMENTS FOR TAPE SAY ON
NOT LOOKING AT THAT. ALL WERE I
AM CONCERNED AS YOU HEARD MY
COMMENTS EARLIER IS. AGAIN I
LOVE YOU TO ANSWER THIS YOU
KNOW HOW HOW DO YOU INSURE FOR.
FOURTH GRADE MATH IS TAUGHT.
OBVIOUSLY NOT EXACTLY THE SAME
BECAUSE YOU KNOW EVERY TEACHERS
DIFFERENT AND YOU KNOW TEACHERS
HAVE DIFFERENT STYLES I'M NOT
SAYING THAT YOU KNOW ONE SIZE
FITS ALL BUT HOW DO YOU ENSURE
SOME CONSISTENCY SAY FOR FOURTH
GRADE MATH ACROSS OUR DISTRICT
OR FOR WHATEVER. WHAT WHATEVER
SUBJECT HAVING SAID THIS
KNOWING THAT WE HAVE- AS-
DOCTOR HAMMOND SORT OF TALKED
ABOUT WE HAVE A LOT OF SOCIAL
EMOTIONAL HEALTH ISSUE. WE HAVE
OVER THE LAST FEW DECADES PAST.
SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO PICK UP SO
MANY SOCIAL SERVICES. THAT
TRADITIONALLY I COUNTIES OR
OTHER GOVERNMENT AGENCIES
REALLY LED NIGHTIN THE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO AN AMAZING JOB
TOTALLY. FINE TO ADD THOSE AS
PART OF YOUR- SORT OF FROM THE
DELIVERABLES OR NOT MISTER
ACCOUNTABILITY METRICS BUT JUST
TO SAY HEY. WE'RE TAKING TIME
OUT TO MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE.
ARE IN THE SOCIAL MENTAL SPACE
TO LEARNING IT IS FOR THEIR
FAMILIES OKAY I THINK THAT'S-
THAT'S TOTALLY FINE TO SAY HEY
WE'RE TAKING TIME OUT. FOR THAT
AND WE ARE. MAKING SURE WE'RE
TAKING CARE FAMILIES THAT WAY.
THE QUESTION IS HOW DO YOU.
INSURER A CERTAIN LEVEL OF-
CONTINUITY ACROSS PETER
SUBJECTS GRADES TEACHERS WITH
THE IN YOUR DISTRICTS THE FEW
THESE THAT I GET A FEW
REQUIREMENTS WE ALREADY I MEAN
WE HAVE CURRICULA AND THAT
THAT- TRUTH DRIVES THAT THE HOW
DO YOU- SORT OF A SURE. SURE
THAT IF YOU'RE WAVING ALL THE
GUIDELINES THAT YOU'RE ASKING
US TO CONSIDER WHETHER. YEAH
THAT'S A INTERESTING AND I
DON'T WANT TO MIX THE TWO I'M
SAYING ACCOUNTING OR-
INSTRUCTIONAL DAYS OR
INSTRUCTIONAL MINUTES IT'S AN
ACCOUNTABILITY SYSTEM THAT WAS.
SORTED EASILY DEFINED YOU KNOW
STUDENT THE SCHOOL GET CREDIT
FOR TEN OR ATTENDING SCHOOL
SCHOOL DISTRICTS GET A CERTAIN
AMOUNT OF REVENUE EACH TIME
MAKE A STUDENT. THE TEN SCHOOL
THAT THAT IN SOME SENSE IS A
VERY EASY ACCOUNTABILITY SYSTEM
THE MORE- CONVERSATION IS. IT'S
REALLY IT'S NOT A CONVERSATION
THAT ABSENT OF THE OPTICAL BIT
NINETEEN CONVERSATION. THE
REALITY IS WE'VE BEEN
STRUGGLING WITH THAT AND
DEVELOPING SYSTEMS I HAVING
CURRICULUM GUIDES HAVING
MONITORING SYSTEM DEVELOPING
LOCUSTS. MINOR STUDENT.
LEARNING THROUGHOUT THE SCHOOL
YEAR AND OBVIOUSLY WE HAVE OR
WE STILL HAVE THE CALIFORNIA
ASSESSMENT OF STUDENT PROGRESS
A PERFORMANCE IN PROGRESS SO
THOSE. THOSE WITH STILL BE IN
EXISTENCE. ONE OF THE STRUGGLE
THAT A SCHOOL DISTRICT MIGHT
HAVE IS IF YOU WERE LOCALLY AS
THINGS DO YOUR OFFICE THAT
MESSAGE. IS BETTER AND THE
STANDARDS IN THE- AND OF A
STUDENT PROGRESS AND. AT THE
WHAT WOULD THAT LOOK LIKE AND I
DISTANCED OF OUR WE'RE WE'RE
WE'RE STILL HAVEN'T IS A ABOUT
U. S. STUDENT. I IF YOU'RE A TO
DO. OR IF YOU HAVE TO CHEN YOUR
ASSESSMENT MEN. SO ONCE AGAIN
THE OLDER TWO DIFFERENT
CONVERSATIONS AND BOTH ARE
IMPORTANT. BUT I HEAR FROM
TEACHERS I HAVE A- TREMENDOUS
RESPECT FOR OUR OUR TEACHERS
AND THE CONVERSATIONS THAT I'M
HEARING ARE A AS A PERTAINS TO
THIS YEAR THE NINETEEN TWENTY
SCHOOL YEAR IS. A WHAT WHAT
WHAT WERE THOSE ESSENTIAL
STANDARDS THAT WE INTENDED TO
TEACH DURING THE LATTER PART OF
THIS YEAR AND IS IT WAY THAT WE
CAN. STONE THAT UP ALREADY BEEN
TAUGHT AND MAYBE IT I GIVE
ANOTHER OPPORTUNITY FOR
STUDENTS TO LEARN THAT. THAT
DIDN'T AT. IF THE STUDENT DID
NOT LEARN THOSE STANDARDS
DURING THE FIRST THREE QUARTERS
OF THE SCHOOL YEAR. SO THOSE
ARE THE CONVERSATION THAT I
HEAR TEACHERS HAVE BEEN RIGHT
NOW THERE'S AN EXTREME INTEREST
IN. MAKING SURE THAT STUDENTS
ARE LEARNING RELEASED EXPOSED
TO AT THE VERY LEAST TO THE
STANDARDS THAT THEY WERE
SUPPOSED TO BE EXPOSED TO. THE
PARTICULAR YEAR THAT THEY'RE IN
SCHOOL. SO ONCE AGAIN-
DIFFERENT THE ACCOUNTABILITY I
JUST I DON'T WANT TO DEVELOP A
WHOLE DIFFERENT. WAY OF A
COUNTY FOR UNITS BEING THERE IN
THE MIDST OF THIS PANDEMIC
BECAUSE WE KNOW IT'S GONNA BE A
DISJOINTED. CATION LEAVE WELL
HE DID IT COMMON THIS GOAL DAYS
A WEEK. AND A YOU KNOW IT OR IF
THEY DO THEY WON'T BE THERE
DURING THE THIS FIVE OR SIX
HOURS THAT THEY THEY ARGUE
EVERY SCHOOL DAY. THAT WAS MY
MAIN POINT IN IN.
RECOMMENDATIONS GOT A GUN THAT
AND THAT'S A POINT WELL TAKEN
BUT JUST GOING BACK TO MY
QUESTION SO. HOW HOW DO YOU
ENSURE CONSISTENCY. ACROSS TWO
DIFFERENT SCHOOLS IN YOUR
DISTRICT. YET TYPICALLY WHAT
HAPPENS IS YOU HAVE A
CURRICULUM GUIDE AND WE HAVE A
CURRICULUM GUIDE IN IN THE
TEACHERS ARE MEETING- MULTIPLE
YEARS- HAND THERE. THEY HAVE AN
AGREEMENT ABOUT WHETHER THOSE
STANDARDS THAT ARE TAUGHT
THROUGHOUT THE SCHOOL YEAR
BECAUSE OF THEIR DESIRE TO
DEVELOP PROFESSIONAL LEARNING
COMMUNITIES MANY SCHOOLS AND
DISTRICTS HAVE A SCOPE IN A
SEQUENCE. THAT'S ATTACHED TO
THOSE STANDARDS SO THINK WHAT
THE WHICH WE'RE GONNA TEACH A
PARTICULAR IS ENTERED AND- SIX
SIX TO NINE WEEKS TEACHERS IN
THE SAME GREAT LEVEL OR
TEACHING THE SAME SUBJECT AREA
CAN COLLABORATE. THIS TO LOOK
AT STUDENT ASSESSMENT DATA AND
GET IT. BERMAN WHAT IT STUDENTS
LEARN AND WHAT DO WE STILL NEED
TO REVISIT AT SCHOOL OR AS A
GRADE LEVEL TEAM. AND THOSE
SYSTEMS. I THINK THE QUESTION
BE TO WHAT EXTENT ARE THOSE
SYSTEM STILL IN PLACE I KNOW. I
KNOW WE HAD SEVERAL
CONVERSATIONS AGAIN WITH OUR
OUR TEACHERS ASSOCIATION ABOUT
WHAT WILL BE THE DIFFERENT WORK
EXPECTATIONS WITH THIS. AND
PART OF THAT DISTANCE LEARNING
PLAN THAT WE DEVELOP ONCE AGAIN
I SAY WE DEVELOPED BUT THERE'S
A TREMENDOUS NETWORK OF
EDUCATOR THAT ASSURING FORCES I
SAY WE- BORROWED. LOOKED AT
THEIR FRAMES FROM A NUMBER OF
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND DECIDED
WHAT WILL WORK IN OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICT BUT EVEN THOUGH I
THINK THAT THAT THAT TOOK A FEW
WEEKS THAT SIT DOWN WITH. OUR
TEACHERS UNION THAT SAY WHAT
ARE THE EXPECTATIONS SO AND-
THE WITHIN THAT I MENTIONED THE
STUDENT LEARNING PART BUT THE
TEACHER LEARNING AS A RESULT OF
STUDENT LEARNING. IN OTHER
WORDS USING THE RESULTS OF
ASSESSMENT TO DETERMINE YOUR
NEXT STEP DOWN AS THE AT THE
TEACHER. THAT'S BEEN PART OF
OUR CONVERSATION WITH THEM THAT
WE HAVE TO SAY ALL CAME. WE
USED TO HAVE A WYNNSTAY
COLLABORATION TIME FOR
TEACHERS. WEDNESDAY
COLLABORATION TO ACT WHAT'S
THAT LOOK LIKE NOW IS THAT
STILL EXPRESS THEIR KERR. OUT I
DIDN'T EXPECT TO OCCUR. WE
TYPICALLY IT WOULD HAPPEN IN
MANY CASES THEY WILL YOUR TO
COME UP. WHAT WOULD BE THE END
AND- THOSE FACT. WHEN ARE THE
GREAT TEAMS CONTAIN TO MEET.
AND TRANSFERRED INTO THIS NEW
SYSTEM THAT WE'RE APPROACHING
FOR THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
SCHOOL YEAR BUT SOME OF IT'S
REALLY JUST DECIDING
LOGISTICALLY WHAT WILL WORK
WITHIN OUR PARTICULAR
ORGANIZATION I MIX AND- MENTION
THE WINDS THAT COLLABORATION.
DISTRICTS THOSE OPPORTUNITY DO
SOME DON'T SO THOSE SAME
SYSTEMS THAT WERE IN PLACE
BEFORE SOME OF THOSE WILL BE
JUST- ADJUSTED TO IT INTO OUR
NEW NORM. SO I'LL JUST AS YOU
LAST QUESTION THAT I KNOW WE
GOT TO MOVE ON TO SOME OF THE
OTHER. MY OTHER COLLEAGUES
READING OF CHANCE TO HAVE SOME
OF THE OTHER FOLKS QUESTIONS.
I'M THEN YOU. SO AS AS YOU'RE
DEVELOPING THIS- WITH YOUR
TEACHERS LET'S HAVE THE
ASSUMPTION ON HOW THE TEACHERS
WEREN'T ABLE TO GET- GIVE THE
KIND OF INSTRUCTION THEY WANTED
TO THE LAST ONE THIRD OF THE
SCHOOL YEAR WHAT PLANS DO YOU
HAVE INTO THE NEXT SCHOOL YEAR
IN TERMS OF CATCHING A LOT.
THAT'S A THAT'S A REALLY GOOD
QUESTION FOR OUR PARTICULAR
SYSTEM ONCE AGAIN WE JUST
SIGNED A MEMORANDUM OF
UNDERSTANDING- MO YOU WITH
THERE ARE TEACHERS ABOUT SEVEN
EIGHT EIGHT DAYS AGO. SO WE'RE
WE'RE REALLY WELL DONE GETTING
THE END OF THIS SCHOOL YEAR
WE'RE HAVING CONGRESS ABOUT.
THE COLLECTION OF MATERIALS AT
THE END OF THE SCHOOL YEAR WE
HAVE A CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
GRADUATION THAT PROMOTION-
WHERE TESTING WHAT OUR SUMMER
SCHOOL MAY LOOK LIKE- I THINK
RIGHT AROUND THE CORNER WHEN
I'M STARTING TO HEAR FROM THE
FIELD IS THAT ARE ACCOMPLISHED.
ABOUT YOU YOU HEARD EARLIER
ASSESSING STUDENTS. AS WE WERE
TO SCHOOL. AND TO SEE WHERE
THERE MIGHT BE LEARNING GAPS.
OUT SO THAT'S WHERE WE ARE THE
EDUCATIONAL COMMUNITY IS JUST
THE BOBBING INTO THAT.
CONVERSATION RECOGNIZING. THAT
THIS IS WHERE WE'RE GOING NEXT
YEAR BUT I CAN SAY. WHAT'S THE
DATE WAS MARCH STEP EITHER
SIXTEEN WHERE MANY OF THE
SCHOOL STARTED. CLOSING THE IN
SCHOOL INSTRUCTION WE'VE COME A
LONG WAY IN A VERY SHORT TIME.
AND I KNOW THERE ARE COMMERCE
ABOUT WHAT CAN WE DO TO
MITIGATE THE LEARNING LOSS. AND
IT LEAVES THOSE CONVERSATIONS
THOUGH IT ONLY WE ARE WE'RE
ALWAYS INVOLVED IN THOSE
CONVERSATIONS. AND SOME WHERE
EVERYBODY GETS SAYING WE COULD
DO BETTER AND I THINK WE COULD
DO BETTER AND I SAY WE TOTAL
SCHOOL SYSTEM. EVERYTHING
IMPACTS THEIR BEING RIGHT.
AFTER OUR PARTICULAR. WE
ALREADY TASK CUTTING CERTAIN
MILLIONS ABOUT FIVE MILLION.
GOING NEXT. SO WHAT THAT MEANT
FOR US WELL. PRIOR TO NINE. WE
HAD OUR LIMóN SOME OUR SUMMER
LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES FOR
STUDENTS WE DECIDED THAT WE'RE
GOING TO KEEP A CREDIT RECOVERY
COMPONENT. MAINLY FOR SECONDARY
STUDENTS THAT WERE TRYING TO
OUT AS WE GET TO. THEIR
GRADUATION.BUT THAT MEANS WE
HAD ELIMINATED SUMMER LEARNING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR GRADES K.
THROUGH EIGHT. AT THE END OF
THAT AND THE WAY OF RESPONDING
TO AN I'M A CONCERN. FOR SO.
NOW HAVE THE CODE AT NIGHT IN.
IN A DAY GROUP STUDENTS ARE
THAT WOULD HAVE LEARNING NEED.
I WE NEED TO LOOK AT OUR FOR.
FUNDING IN OUR RESOURCE THAT
AVAIL. AT THAT ARE. DECIDE ON
WHAT ARE NEXT STEP. WE DON'T
KNOW AND THEN I HAVE TO I CAN'T
SAY THAT WE HAVE IT ALL FIGURED
OUT IT'S PART OF THE EQUATION.
AND THE DOLLARS AND CENTS ARE
PART OF THAT. THAT
CONVERSATION- WE'RE- WE'RE LIKE
I SAID MY GOOD. IS THAT 4260%
OF THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS. ARE
HAD EXTREME FISCAL. WORRIES IN
CONSIDERATION BEFORE COVE IT
NINETEEN. AND THIS IS JUST
GONNA EXACERBATED. SO THAT I
KNOW THAT DOESN'T FULLY ANSWER
THE QUESTION BUT I KNOW I HAVE
FAITH AND- EDUCATE. BECAUSE WE
ARE HAVING THOSE CONVERSATIONS-
AND THEY'RE GONNA XCELERATED
NOW THAT WE'VE- I'M GONNA SAY
WE HAVEN'T DEALT WITH BUT
WE'RE- WE GOT A PRETTY CLEAR
DIRECTIONS FOR THIS SCHOOL
YEAR. AND NOW WE'RE STARTING
THAT HAVE CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
WHAT WOULD NEXT SCHOOL YEAR
LOOK LIKE. THE THANK YOU ARE
PRE. SIR OF. OKAY Q. JUST A
LITTLE OUT CHECK IN HERE ABOUT
ONE TWENTY. WE HAVE TWO MORE
STE THEM WHO LIKE TO SPEAK TO A
MEMBER MOUNT. AND THEN IT'S
MAYOR MARZI AND HOW MAY PEOPLE
DO WE ON MY FOR PER COMMENT.
WHEN WE LOOK AT HAVE PUBLIC.
AND WE'RE HAVE A TIME SIR
PUBLIC BE WE HAVEN'T HEARING.
AT THREE O'CLOCK WE NEED A
LITTLE BIT OF A BREAK BEFORE
THEN. SO WITH THAT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WE MONTH. I THINK YOU
AND I REALLY WANT TO THINK THAT
ARE BUT FOR. COMMENT AND YOU
KNOW I TO ECHO WITH YOU THING
AND THEN I A QUESTION. SO ONE
EIGHT THAT WAY HAS BEEN SAID
AND- OF THINKING ABOUT GRADES
FOR K. TWELVE STUDENTS- IS VERY
IMPORTANT CERTAINLY RIGHT NOW-
THERE IS A DIFFERENT IN TERMS
OF HOW DISTRICTS ARE. BEING A
IN WITH IT I ASSEMBLY IT UP NOT
ALL. CAN THE GREAT CITY I AND
THESE GRAY. ARE IN. TO US IN
HIGH LEVEL I'M IMPACT UP WITH.
BUT ALSO DO WRONG THAT SOME
I'VE I'VE NOT HEARD- THERE
THERE SHOULD BE SOME
CONSIDERATION ON- WHAT THE
CONSISTENCY- MIGHT NEED TO BE
ADD THE LONGER WE GO INTO THIS-
THE OTHER PIECE I WANTED TO
ECHO WAS AT RELATED TO
GEOGRAPHY. I STARTED IN THIS
HEARING TALKING ABOUT HOW
IMPORTANT IT'S GOING TO BE FOR
SCHOOLS TO OPEN UP TO BE PART
OF ECONOMIC RECOVERY- AND
HAVING SAID THAT RECOGNIZE THAT
NOT ALL COMMUNITIES ARE THE
SAME RIGHT NOW WHEN I THINK OF
LOS ANGELES COUNTY. AND HAVING
NOT ONLY THE LARGEST SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN OUR STATE BUT ALSO
HAVING KOBE CASES THAT ARE
GOING UP- AND STILL SEEN A
NUMBER OF REALLY DIFFICULT
HEALTH SITUATE IN A LOS ANGELES
COUNTY I CAN'T IMAGINE- THAT. A
COUNTY- LIKE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
WOULD BE ABLE TO DO THE SAME
THING AS A DIFFERENT COUNTY AND
I THINK THAT WE HAVE TO HAVE-
ACCEPTANCE FOR AND THE IDEA
THAT. COUNTIES MIGHT BE IN AND
SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT POSITION AND
I WANT US TO LOOK AT THE
DIFFERENCES IN AUGUST AND SEE
WHAT WE ARE AND ABLE TO YOU.
THAT I MEAN. WE'RE OUT EXT.
OUTCOME IN THE LONG TERM OUR
STUDENTS I EIGHT MEANS WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO IT SOMEWHAT TO
ADDITIONALLY I ACT THAT THE-
REAL TO SO BILLS IT WOULD VERY.
TO KNOW HOW THE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS PARTICIPATING ARE NOT
FULLY PART. I KNOW AND SOME OF
DISTRICTS. READ THAT
PARTICIPATE. BUT THE SAME.
FAMILIES THAT ARE. A SENSE
WORKER THIS FOR THAT WERE
ALREADY LIVING ON THE ACT. MORE%
ARE THE SAME ONES THAT ARE
HAVING AHARD TIME GETTING
THEIR CHILDREN AND STUDENTS TO
SOME OF THIS FEEDING KIDS HAS
NEVER BEEN SO DIFFICULT- IT IS
A VERY BIG CHALLENGE IN A AND I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR US TO
KNOW. AND THIS RELATES NOT JUST
TO THEIR LEARNING BUT ALSO
RELATES TO THEIR HEALTH. AND SO
I THINK THAT THAT'S AN
IMPORTANT PIECE UP I WANT TO
ASK WE WE'VE IN THIS
CONVERSATION TODAY WE HAVE.
IDENTIFIED MULTIPLE TASK FORCE
WHETHER IT'S THE SUPERINTENDENT
OF PUBLIC INSTRUCTION OR THE
GOVERNOR OR JUST A GENERAL TASK
FORCE I'M NOT CLEAR ABOUT THEIR
TIME LINES I THINK I NOW KNOW.
WHAT TO OUTCOMES THEY WERE UP
THE WE THE LET SLEEP YOUR START
TO WHAT SOME OF. SPORTS
RECOMMEND ARE. E. HERE IN. I
FIRST. MEN ON MAN WHILST BEING.
MOVE BILLS FOR WHETHER IT'S ONE
OR WHY IT'S AN MORE THAN BUT
HAVE MOVED CONVERSE AND BILLS
FAR AND PA OVER ALL AND IT
EIGHT YOU KNOW I TO MAKE THAT
THE TASK REC AND IDEAS ARE LINE
I DON'T EXPECT FOR THEM TO BE-
RESULTS THAT WE GET OVERNIGHT
BUT CERTAINLY THERE IS A SENSE
OF URGENCY AND ALL OF THIS AND
I THINK IT WOULD BE REALLY
IMPORTANT FOR THOSE FIRST TO
IDENTIFY SOME TIME IN STATE WE
ARE A LEGISLATIVE. I'M A KEY IN
IT TO WHEN MIGHT BE RECEIVING
SOME THESE RIGHT AND WHEN WE
MIGHT IT DOESN'T MEAN WE WILL
OR WON'T DO AND NOW MIGHT BE
QUESTION FOLLOWING WHEN I DID
THE TIME OF THIS. IS AT THIS
PARTICULAR PANEL IT WAS ABOUT
LEARNING WE- HAVE A WAY TO.
LEARN DID YOU OR DID YOU KNOW
LEARN SOMETHING FOR STUDENTS-
AND THAT WASTE TYPICALLY I AM
VERY MUCH MODELS FOR A SCHOOL
PROGRAM WHERE YOU SEE KIDS IN
PERSON. BUT THIS IS ABOUT LOS.
HOW ARE WE MEASURING LEARNING
LOS HOW AS WE HOW ARE WE AS
LEGISLATORS ACTUALLY GOING TO
KNOW WHAT STUDENTS ARE LOSING
AND ALL OF THIS AND- THAT I
HOPE WILL INFLUENCE HOW WE
THINK. ABOUT AND THAT SOME OF
THE RECOMMENDATIONS BUT WHAT
ARE THE METRICS THAT ARE BEING
USED WHEN WILL WE HAVE
INFORMATION ABOUT WHAT THE LOS
TRULY IS FOR STUDENTS I'M AND
IF YOU COULD DIG A LITTLE BIT
DEEPER AND PROVIDE SPECIFIC.
CAN WE WHAT IS THE LOOK. AT
NINETEEN JUST LEARNING IS THAT
A ONE ON ONE I'M THE AS SOO IS
THAT A PHONE CALL IS THAT- YOU
KNOW CLASSROOM ASSESSMENT WHAT
IS THAT LOOK LIKE HOW DO YOU
MEASURE LEARNING LOS. THAT'S
FOR ANY OF THE EDUCATORS PLEASE.
THIS HEATHER HAVE ALL DON'T BET
ON THAT I THINK THAT THERE IS
NO WAIT THINK ABOUT HOW WE
MEASURE A LOT AND ONE IN THE
WAY THEY YOU ACT WHICH IS WHY.
ARE THEY NOT. BUT I THAT
ANOTHER WAY WE ADDRESS IT YEAH.
ANDREA HOW CAN YES THAT WHAT
THEY AND WHAT THEY NEED. OUR
AND LOOKING AT IT THAT WAY I
IT'S MORE HELPFUL FOR THE
SYSTEM BUT ALL FOR A- WHO YOU
THAT AND FOR. WITH JUST HOW FAR
BEHIND OUR- IF I A PARTICULAR
STOOD IN MY- WHAT MAKES YOUR-
THEY NEED TO TAUGHT. AND HOW
CAN WE WORKING OUR- AROUND
THINKING OUT I THANK YOU. AND
PERFECT REASON WHY RECKON IN MY
COMMENTS THAT WE CAN. HE EIGHT
LEVEL AND THERE'S MANY YEARS
RESEARCH EVIDENCE THAT DOC WHAT
SOME OF THESE MIGHT BE. SO IF
WE ASK TEAM IN EVERY CLASSROOM
FIRST EVERY DISTRICT LEVEL UP
THEIR OWN ASSESSMENT. I YOU'RE
MISSING AN OPPORTUNITY. TO FIND
IN A IF HERE HEALTH. AND SOME
THAT RIGHT. I THINK AND OF
THOSE THAT ARE WERE IN A MORE
CENTRAL WAY SO I DON'T KNOW
THAT'S THE STATE DEPARTMENT OF
ADD OR- YOU KNOW EVEN FROM A IN
FIRST CAN YOU. DESCRIBE WHAT
THAT SENT PROCESS IS LIKE IS
THAT BEGINNING IS THERE A WAY
TO THIS OUR DOING IT. I LIKE TO
JUST A- THIS IS WONDER GIRL
HAMMOND ST BOARD OF ED. WE DO
ALREADY. HAVE THE SMALL BELLS
JUST SISTER IN THIS. OF WHICH-
AN- ASSESSED. OF THAT IS TIED
TO OUR STAND IT'S NOT AND ALL
HAS. ENORMOUS THAT ARE YOU THEY
CAN BE YOU TO READ. A VERSION
OF THE COMPLETE ANNUAL
ASSESSMENT. OR CAN BE TAILORED
TO SPECIFIC. AREAS IN THE
CURRICULUM. HAVING TO DO WITH-
FOR EXAMPLE YOU KNOW A READING
LITERACY. MATHEMATICS THOSE
TOOLS ARE AVAILABLE- AND CAN BE
USED AT THE DISTRICT LEVEL. BUT
ALSO BE. UNDERSTOOD AT THIS OF
AND ACTIVATE AND NOW WAY THERE
ALSO. SHE KINDS OF TOOLS THE
DISTRICTS USE FOR STUDENTS WHO
ARE YOUNGER THAN THAT A BECAUSE
THAT ASSISTANCE IN THIRD GRADE
SOME DISTRICTS USE THINGS LIKE
THE- DEVELOPMENTAL READING
ASSESSMENT WHICH HAS A
CONTINUING THE TEACHERS CAN USE
TO WATCH GROWTH AND UPRIGHT
ALONG THE LITERACY CONTINUUM. I
AND OTHER TOOLS THAT SO AT THE
DISTRICT THERE MANY SUCH TOOLS
AVAILABLE AT THE STATE LEVEL WE
ALSO HAVE RESOURCES THAT ARE
AVAILABLE FOR LOOKING AT WHERE
STUDENTS ARE AND AS THEIR SAID
WHAT NEED TO LEARN NEXT. AND
JUST FOR. FROM THE C. AGES
ADDING. WHAT LOW DOES THE ALL
OF. ARE TO ARE T. ACROSS THE
STATE. AND FOR FREE AT WE- HAVE
QUITE OF. OTHER TEACHERS THAT
ARE YOU THEM THE STATE WE HAVE
OVER MILLIONS OF THOSE ASSESSED
BEING. I'M ON A DAY BASIS. AND
SO THEY ARE ACCESSIBLE AND FREE
AND THEY SHOW THE TEACHERS
WHERE THE STUDENTS ARE ACTS.
AND ANY HOLES THAT THEY MAY
HAVE BASED ON OUR CALIFORNIA
STATE STANDARDS. SO THEN LET ME
ASK YOU THIS BOTH FOR DR LINDA
DARLING HAMMOND AND FOR THE CD.
IS OUR BELIEF THAT THE SAME
TOOLS WE WERE USING TO MEASURE
STUDENT LEARNING BEFORE COVERT
NINETEEN. SHOULD BE IN PLACE.
POST COVERT NINETEEN OR ARE
THOSE GOING TO HAVE TO CHANGE.
OUR STANDARDS HAVE NOT CHANGED.
RIGHT SO THAT'S MENTAL'S SO I
THAT RIGHT STANDARD HAVEN'T BUT
THE A TOOLS BECAUSE NOT MEASURE
LEARN WERE ALSO MEASURING
LEARNING LOS NOW AT LEAST
THAT'S HOW I UNDERSTAND THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE WANT TO KNOW.
THE ASSESSMENT TOOLS CAN'T
STILL YOU. WE WOULD ACTUALLY
WORK ON AND I BELIEVE. LINK
THAT STARTING ALREADY SPENT TO
THE RUN TO TIE. AND STUFF HE-
TO HELP FURTHER INTO. I FOR OUR-
FIRST AND SO GRADE. WHERE THERE
LEARNING AS TO BEEN OUR READ.
AND BECAUSE THAT WOULD BE A
REALLY A- DYING. AND
INFORMATION TO HAVE FOR
TEACHERS OF WHAT GAPS ARE THERE
AND THERE READINGS. DO YOU KNOW
THE TIME AWAY AND TRY WITH THE
DISTANCE LEARNING RIGHT AND
JUST I TO THE QUESTION LEARNING
WHEN PEOPLE ARE TAUGHT ABOUT
THAT IN THE- RICHER. THERE CHOI
ABOUT WHERE STUDENTS ARE IN
AGGREGATEDANALYSIS. HE'S A BIT
WORK IT IN. YEAR AS WE OF X.
THEM TO BE ANOTHER WAS THEY FOR
EXAMPLE LOOKS. IN SORT OF A
YEAR WORTH OF GROW OVER THE
COURSE OF THE YEAR BUT WITH
THESE. OF WITH THE THAT WERE
TALK ABOUT YOU CAN OF SEE WORST
WERE AND DISTRICT DO THIS
REGULAR. WHERE WERE STUDENTS
STAND. OF TWO TWO AND WHERE ARE
IN. YOU KNOW JIM WHERE ARE THEY-
SO. I YOU CAN PROGRESS
INDIVIDUALS WHEN YOU'RE USING
THESE KINDS OF DIAGNOSTIC TOOLS
I'M SO IT IS POSSIBLE TO KNOW.
STUDENTS ACT. GET DUMBER.
LEARNING WAS REAL BIG CONTINUE
LEARN BUT THEY CAN LOOK. UP
FACILITY AT A FULL ONCE IN SOME
SO AND YOU WEIGH YOUR TO. LIKE
NAS ASSESSMENTS OR TIME BUT
STILL ARE WAYS TO DO THE TWO
NOT. IS A MANAGED WITH LARGE
SCALE SOME TELL THAT ARE NOT.
CHEERED AND TRACK TO SEE.
SKILLS THE YOU AND- I GUESS IT
I'M THINKING IF I'M A PARENT
AND I'M TO MAKE IT TO. AND THIS
IS GOES ON FOR WEAR DO YOU KNOW
EACH IS THIS IS AT HOME WE STE
MOVING THE MODEL THAT A LOT OF
YOU HAVE TO WHICH IS A OF
BLENDER LEARNING A SATURDAY A.
M. P. BLOCKS. HOLIDAY SHIPS ALL
THAT GOOD STUFF AT WHAT POINT
DO I HAVE SOME INFORMATION TO
HELP ME DECIDE WHETHER OR NOT
WHAT THAT CHILD HAS OR HAS NOT
LEARNED SHOULD BE SOMETHING
THAT THE CHILD HOULD- SHOULD
THAT A PARENT AND A TEACHER
SHOULD CONSIDER ON WHETHER THE
CHILD MOVES FORWARD. I THINK
YOU MISSED IT YOU KNOW TANG
MENTIONED IT JUST DO WE READ
SURE FREE I MEAN. THAT'S A
COMMENT THAT IS IT YOU KNOW.
I'M SURE. YOU KNOW. HOW SERIOUS
HE WAS BUT AT SOME POINT WE DO
ACT HAVE TO CAN THAT AT WHAT
POINT DO WE HAVE ENOUGH
INFORMATION ABOUT WHAT STUDENTS
ARE OR ARE NOT LEARNING TO HELP
US DETERMINE WHETHER AN
INDIVIDUAL STUDENT OR YOU KNOW
A GROUP OF STUDENTS ARE GOING
TO HAVE TO REPEAT A YEAR
BECAUSE THE LEARNING WASN'T
SUCH BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT IT'S
NOT JUST ABOUT MISSING ONE OR
TWO STANDARDS. AND I DON'T
BELIEVE THAT THE STATE HAS EVER
SEEN ANYTHING LIKE THIS BUT I
COULD BE WRONG I MEAN I CAN I
WAS IN A DISTRICT THAT HAD WILD
FIRES AND DEBRIS FLOWS AND
CERTAINLY SHUT DOWN MUCH LONG
BUT THIS IS. WHAT WE WENT
THROUGH THEN IT'S NOTHING LIKE
WHAT HAPPENING NOW- AND AT
EIGHT AND THEN YOU KNOW PERHAPS
WE DON'T KNOW THE ANSWERS BUT
IT'S CERTAINLY THAT'S ON OUR MY-
I'M FIGHT EVERY. VERY GOOD
EFFORTS. AT BEEN MADE YOU KNOW
BY. I TEACHERS IN PARENTS I TO
THIS. MY FOR THIS TO AND THEIR
YOU KNOW INTO THE ASSN TO LOG
ON AT SOME POINT. NOW EVERY
STUDENT ISN'T A AND WHEN DO WE
FACE THAT OUT AND DO WE DECIDE.
WHAT KINDS OF DECISIONS ARE
MADE FOR FUTURE YEARS. WELL I
JUST LIKE TO OFFER A COUPLE OF
COMMENTS AND THEN UNFORTUNATELY
I HAVE TO. LEAVE BECAUSE I'M
MISSING ANOTHER MEETING THAT I
CAN'T RESCHEDULE. FIRST THERE
WOULD JUST SAY IS THAT LARGE
SCALE GRADE RETENTION HAS BEEN
DONE IT HAS BEEN EXPERIENCED
AND STUDIED OVER THE COURSE OF
THE LAST FORTY YEARS THERE ARE.
HUNDREDS OF STUDIES ON THAT AND
ONLY NOT TO WORK IN TERMS OF
ACHIEVEMENT GAINS. BUT ALSO TO
CREATE A HIGHER RATES OF
ACHIEVEMENT LOS AND- DROP OUT
SO WE WILL NOT BE RECOMMENDING
THAT YOU KNOW PEOPLE RED SHIRT
KIDS FOR AN ENTIRE. YEAH SYSTEM
OVER ENTIRE YEAR- THERE ARE A
LOT OF STRATEGIES THAT CAN BE
USED TO ACCELERATE LEARNING AND
THEY DO RELY IN PART ON KNOWING
WHERE KIDS ARE. IN THEIR
LEARNING RIGHT NOW SO THAT YOU
CAN GET A LOT OF LEARNING IS
CUMULATIVE IF YOU JUMP OVER
SKIP OVER SKILLS. YOU KNOW
THAT'S A PROBLEMS YOU DO NEED
TO HAVE THAT CONTINUOUS
LEARNING SO HAVING THAT
DIAGNOSTIC ASSESSMENTS THAT
ALLOWS YOU TO KNOW WHERE KIDS
ARE HE'S A IN YOU CAN LEARN
THAT AND KNOW THAT AS A PARA.
AND IN THE SCHOOLS. HE'S THE
WORK HERE MAIN BE OR ON
EVERYTHING BE AT MOMENT IN TIME.
IS POSSIBLE TO HOW MANY TO OF A-
OF TOOLS TO DO THAT A REPORT TO
PARENTS ABOUT THAT PRIDE. IN
ANY OF THAT WHY IS TO BE ACTED.
IN THE FALL OF OR WHENEVER
WHETHER IT'S SUMMER OR FALL
WITH NEVER LEARN. IN RISEN WAS
AND TRADITIONAL SCHOOL GEN OUR.
AT YOU NEED TO PUT. THOSE SO.
OR YOU KNOW SERVE THE SHOP THE
KIDS MIGHT NEED TO GO THROUGH A
AND WE CAN BE HELPFUL DISTRICTS
AND FROM ABOUT TOOLS STRATEGIES
THAT HAVE FOUND TO BE SIX IN.
RAP EXCEL OF AND WE CAN BE OF
COURSE OF PROVIDING EXPAND
LEARNING. THAT YOU'RE
REFERENCING YOUR ROOM. THAT
MAKE PLACE IN BOTH IN THE SOME
AND MAY BE AND YOU KNOW VARIOUS
AFTER SCHOOL SO CENTER SCHOOL
ORDER RISKY TIMES. THE KEY IS.
A TO KNOW WHY THE CHOI IS A
THEIR WORK AND BE ABLE TALK TO
RESTORE AND- IS. TO THE- NEED
AT THEM SO THAT LEARNING CAN BE
A- THANK YOU I. QUESTION
EIGHTEEN AND DISCUSS OVERALL IN
I DO I'M GET AND JUST COMMENTS
ABOUT THE FUNDING I THINK AND
WE'VE HEARD AND NUMBER OF NEED
OF ALL AND ALL COME BUT I AM
GAY ECHO. OF I THINK WE SOME
MIGHT HAVE SAY. THAT TO IT'S
CLEAR WE WILL BE ABLE TO HAVE A
DISCUSSION ABOUT ANY ADDED
FUNDING SO- I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR US ALL OF US TO
TRANSITION- TO WHAT THE NEW
REALITIES ARE OF BEING A STATE
WITH TENS OF BILLIONS. OF
DOLLARS- EIGHT IN A DEFICIT
THAT WE DIDN'T EXPECT TO HAVE
SO- I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH ALL THE GROUPS AND
ORGANIZATIONS ON A WHAT THAT'S
GOING TO LOOK LIKE- BUT I
DEFINITELY THINK IT'S SOMETHING
WE'RE GOING TO NEED TO
ACKNOWLEDGE SO THANK YOU CHAIR.
OKAY THANK YOU SO THE MEMBER
MARC RICH THANK YOU I- WANTED
TO FOCUS ON ONE ISSUE WHICH IS
THE ISSUE THAT THE- CHAIR
FOCUSED ON- THIS IDEA OF A
LEARNING LOS BLOCK GRANT FOR.
SUMMER EDUCATE. ON I WANTED TO-
BUT WITH THE FIRST OF ALL I
DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT INVOLVES
BECAUSE I'VE NOT BEEN IN ANY
COVER TUNES THE- IN TERMS THE
ARE. THERE THE NAME. THE V.
MINE JUST AND BETTER ALL. HI
I'M. TO ASK THE CAN CAN. YOU
THE ONE THAT THAT MADE THE-
THAT WAS DISTANT WITH. IT'S
THAT. IS A WIDE. RICK OF SO
PROGRAM FOR. BY A STE BYE BYE
SCHOOL THIS THROUGHOUT STATIC.
SOME PROVIDE A REAL SUMMER IT'S-
OTHERS HAVE ANY SUMMER
EDUCATION PROGRAM AT ALL. AND
THE IN WELL I IN MY- OLD SCHOOL
THIS. THE TWO UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN TOOK A TURN. A OF
THE ROUND. IN ORDER OR- A
EDUCATION PROGRAM SO I WANTED
GO DOT CAMPUS YOU'RE STILL THE
LINE IF YOU HAD ITS- BETWEEN
GETTING A- LOWER OR THIS. PER A-
BLOCKER FOR SO IS K. VERSES.
THAT THOSE. TO TRY TO. YOU KNOW
A- INCREASE THE- OR OR TO.
PROVIDE FOR PENSION RELIEF. OR
A PROVIDE FIRST. K. IN THAT
THAT'S THREE. THAT I CAN. HEARD
SCHOOL DISTRICTS. IN A WAY
WHICH WOULD YOU PREFER. YES
THAT'S THE X. IN QUESTION ON.
WHAT I WANT TO GET OFF FRAME
THE AROUND I KNOW THAT A SCHOOL
THERE SO MANY ONES AND SO WE
DIFFERENT SIR. I SO I WOULD
WHAT TO. FLEXIBILITY THERE WERE
COME. MORE DOLLARS ANOTHER
WORDS IS SOME MADE THAT'S COLD
OR STATUTE COLA. I SOME STATURE
CALLED COLA AND THAT'LL PAY AND
SPECIAL THE THOSE DOWN GIVEN
SIMPLEX SO WE CAN MAKE LOCAL A
HOW BEST TO SERVE OUR COMMUNITY
SO GIVEN THE CHOICE THE WAY YOU
FRAME DID I WOULD PREFER THE
FLEXIBILITY. THANK YOU AND SO I
JUST WANT TO CLOSE WITH THAT
COMMENT I THINK AS WE ARE. YOU
KNOW MOVING FORWARD AND MAKING
A- VERY DIFFICULT FINANCIAL
DECISIONS ESPECIALLY IN
EDUCATION FUNDING THAT THE
THEME- AND THEN I STARTED
WEAPON THE STEAM THE THEME THAT
I WILL AND WITH AND THAT I
THINK A NUMBER OF OUR SPEAKERS
HAVE. HAVE A REINFORCED THIS IS
FLEXIBILITY WE NEED TO GIVE OUR
LOCAL SCHOOL SCHOOL DISTRICTS
AS MUCH MONEY WITH AS MUCH
FLEXIBILITY AS POSSIBLE THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR THAT THANK YOU
MISTER MARTUCCI WE'LL GET CAN I
GET TO A PUBLIC COMMENT BUT I
JUST WANT TO. CLOSE THIS SAID
MAYBE CLOSE THE LOOP WITH THIS
ISSUE- DID JUST A CLARIFICATION
IT'S NOT NECESSARILY THAT WERE
LOOKING FOR- SUMMER SCHOOL
LEARNING LAS BLOCK GRANT BUT
JUST A BLOCK GRANT TO ADDRESS
LEARNING LOSS AS A WHOLE THAT
COULD CALM IN THE SUMMER COULD
BE IN PERSON COULD BE ONLINE.
IT COULD BE IN THE FALL WITH
SCHOOLS COME BACK IN THE FALL
BUT IT'S A RECOGNITION THAT WE
HAVE ONE THOUSAND SCHOOL
DISTRICTS IN CALIFORNIA. VERY
DIVERSE SOME ACTUALLY WANT TO
DO SUMMER SCHOOL SUMMER DO
SUMMER BRIDGE PROGRAMS THERE'S
SOME PROGRAMS LIKE THE FREEDOM
SCHOOL- EFFORTS RIGHT HERE IN
SACRAMENTO LA IN THE BAY AREA
WHICH WILL WITH. AFRICAN
COMMUNITIES IT DO A GREAT JOB
IS FOCUSING ON THE SUMMER
LEARNING LOSS AND SO. THERE'S
NOT ONE CRACKED PATH THERE BUT
WE NEED TO RECOGNIZE THIS IS AN
ISSUE AND YEAH I WOULD DO ONE
AT FULLY FUND THE CALL AND GIVE
MAXIMUM FLEXIBILITY TO PAY FOR.
EVERYTHING ELSE BUT I THINK
WHAT WE THOUGHT BY THAT.
PRESENTATION FROM THAT TRUST
WEST IS THERE IS A REAL- OUT IT
AND COMMUNITY HE ACHIEVEMENT
THROUGHOUT THE FERNANDO NOR THE
I THINK BE A BIG MISTAKE ON OUR
PART SO I. WE CAN. AT TO YOUR
TRY TO FOCUS ON AND NOT. OF THE
REASON. I REMEDY WILL AT BUT
HOW SOME COM ABOUT. BUT WE NEED
TO TALKING ABOUT IT. BECAUSE
THE THING DO IS. GET TOGETHER
IN. AND THEN HAVE THE DISK
SITTING ON THE REASON. FOR
MONTHS THAT BECAUSE WE REALIZE.
THAT THE ISSUE IS. US TODAY SO
WITH THAT NUMBER QUESTIONS FROM
THIS FOR THIS PANEL FROM
MEMBERS. YOU SO MUCH TO. EIGHT
PRESENT OUT THE FOR JOINING US
WILL FEW OUR- AND THAT WE WILL
SEE YOU I'M SIR- SOON AND WE
APPRECIATE YOUR ENGAGEMENT ON
THESE ISSUES SO WITH THAT. WE
WILL NOW PROCEED WITH OUR
PUBLIC COMMENT WE DO HAVE. FEW
PEOPLE ON THE LINE ALREADY AND
I NEED TO READ. THIS LITTLE
STATEMENT HERE. READ THE ENTIRE
THING. PHONE NUMBER YES OKAY SO
WE HAVE HERE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO- TO PARTICIPATE IN THIS-
HEARING THROUGH- DIALING A
NUMBER AND GETTING ON ON LAW
AND GETTING IN THE QUEUE THE
NUMBER IS. 1-877-692-8957 AGAIN.
1-877-692-8957 THE ACCESS CODE
IS FOUR EIGHT FIVE THREE TWO
ZERO. ACCESS CODE FOUR EIGHT
FIVE THREE TWO ZERO IF YOU
DIDN'T GET THAT CAN GO TO THE
ASSEMBLY BUDGET COMMITTEE WEB
PAGE TO LOOK AT THE AGENDA AND
ITS IT'S FOR YOU AS WELL SO
WE'RE GONNA ASK ALL
PARTICIPANTS TO KEEP THEIR
COMMENTS TO ONE MINUTE OR LESS
A ONE MINUTE OR LESS- PLEASE
GIVE US YOUR NAME AND YOUR
ORGANIZATION IF YOUR- IF YOU
HAVE ONE YOUR AFFILIATION. AND
BEGIN FIRST. FOR INDIVIDUAL.
OKAY THINGS IF YOU DO HAVE A
COMMENT ON THE PHONE PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD AND IT WILL
INDICATE THAT YOU'VE BEEN
PLACED INTO THE QUEUE IF YOU
ARE USING A SPEAKER PHONE
PLEASE PICK UP THE HANDSET
BEFORE PRESSING THE NUMBERS WE
HAVE A COMMENT OF FROM THE LINE
OF AIR AND APATHY- JUST MOMENTS.
I'M OPENING A LINE NOW FOR
AARON ANTHONY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI AARON HAPPY ON BEHALF OF
PUBLIC ADVOCATES A MEMBER OF
THE OFF IF THAT EQUITY
COALITION THANK YOU CHAIR
COMEDIAN. WE APPRECIATE THE
LEADERSHIP OF THE EVENT ON THE
PART OF A- AND WORKING WITH
SCHOOL DISTRICT DURING THE
CRISIS HOWEVER AS NUMBER KING
AND THAT'S THE KERN MONTHLY
APPROACH ALLOWING. TO DECIDE
PRIORITY AND HOW TO IMPLEMENT
BUT I DON'T HAVE THE STATE AND-
DISREGARD THE NEED OF THE MOST
STUDENTS AND- WHO ARE MOST
IMPACT BY THIS. PRECISELY
BECAUSE THEY NOT IN RIGHT CAN
WITH. THE DEFENSE SHOWED UP THE
FACT OF CAN DID NOT UNDER YELP
YES THAT'S USE COMMUNITY
ENGAGED AND RESTORE EQUITY.
THIS CRISIS AND THE OF
COMMUNITY. OF THE WHAT NEEDS
AND RESTART ALLOCATION. AND WE
PUT THE LETTER PROVIDER ITEMS
EDUCATION MAJOR. THAT'S. REALLY
SEPARATE TRUST LAST COMMENTS
ABOUT WAITED FUNDING FOR THE
PROPOSED BLOCK GRANTS IN
KEEPING WITH THE LVF PRINCIPLE
OF DIRECTING MORE FUNDS TO OUR
NEEDIEST STUDENTS IN. THANK ONE
MINUTE. OKAY YOU I'M GOING TO
REMIND EVERYONE TO GET INTO THE
QUESTION QUEUE PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO ON THE TELEPHONE
KEYPAD. EIGHT FOUR COMMENT SO
YOU'LL PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
THIS IS THE OPERATOR I'M JUST
GONNA REFRESH MY SCREEN JUST
ONE MOMENT. I APOLOGIZE FOR THE
DELAY I JUST NEED TO REFRESH MY
SCREEN ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
Q. SO
MUCH I'M GONNA GO NEXT YOU
COMMENT FROM ELIZABETH ETHICAL
BILL THE LINE IS OPEN. HI I
LIVE ASK ALONG WITH THE CAL. OF
SCHOOL BUSINESS OFFICIALS THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR GRANTED THE- WE
WANT TO THANK EVERYONE BEEN
WORKING HARD. TO ENSURE OUR
STATE ARE RECEIVE EDUCATE SERVE
IN A- MEAL WE BELIEVE CRITICAL
THE STATE PARK HIGH THIS TO OUR
AS PART THAT. AND SO IN ORDER
TO A HEALTHY AND BY THAT WE
DISTURB MATERIALS IN. AND I
STATE A TOPIC OF BUDGET. WE
FOCUS ON TRY GAVE THE TO TURN
THE IN THE WAY FROM OUR MùT
VULNERABLE POP. BY PROVIDING
GIFT FUND AND ACROSS OF LIVING
LIVING A- TO HELP SCHOOL
PROPERLY READ OF AND IMPLEMENT
SAY LEARNING OF. WE YOU
CONSIDER COST THIRTY THAT
MEASURE THE LENGTH IMPLEMENT OF
NEW NOT LET'S. AND THE SPENDING
FIVE. REQUIREMENTS TO ALLOW
EIGHT RESTRICT LIMIT RESOURCES.
THANK SO MUCH. IN CCAP IMPAIR
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
COMMENT AND URGE THE
ADMINISTRATION THE LEGISLATURE
TO PRESERVE FUNDING FOR ADULT
EDUCATION. DURING THE LAST
RECESSION ADULT EDUCATION WAS
DECIMATED BY CATEGORICAL
FLEXIBILITY AT A TIME WHEN IT
WAS CRITICALLY NEEDED WE URGE
THE FUNDING TO BE MAINTAINED
FOR ADULT EDUCATION IN THIS
CURRENT ENVIRONMENT. DURING THE
LAST RECESSION NEARLY FOUR OUT
OF FIVE JOBS LOST WERE HELD BY
WORKERS ONLY WITH ONLY A HIGH
SCHOOL DIPLOMA OR LESS. ADULT
EDUCATION IS A CRITICAL
RESOURCE IN SYSTEM TO ENSURE
THAT THE MOST MARGINALIZED IN
OUR COMMUNITIES HAVE ACCESS TO
BASIC SKILLS. THANK FULL
QUIBBLE AND SEE CITIZENSHIP ESL
INTEREST SHORT TERM JOB
TRAINING. FURTHER ADULT
EDUCATION IS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT TO HELP THOSE ADULTS
STRUGGLING WITH BASIC SKILLS
NEEDS WHO ARE ALSO CRITICAL TO
THE SUCCESS OF A KEY TWELVE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS EFFORTS. TO
SUPPORT THEIR KIDS STUDENTS
YOUR ADULTS STUDENTS- CHILDREN
WHO ARE CHALLENGED WITH
DISTANCE LEARNING FROM HOME.
THANK YOU SEE SCARY AND QUE
ELLA URGE YOU TO PRESERVE IT ON
OCCASION FUNDING. FOR THE MOST
MARGINALIZED IN OUR COMMUNITY
IS INTERESTED IN DISTANCE AIM
FOR THEIR CASE TWELFTH DUE. AND
TO HELP BRING ABOUT THE CODE
DISTRICT THANK YOU DONE THE YOU.
AT IN A COMMENT FOR MELISSA.
ROSS PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
LOWER COURT PROPER OUR SPEAKS
TODAY ARE COMMON TO THE ISSUE
OF LEARNING LAW CLOSURES ARE
DIFFICULT EVERY BUT IF
CHALLENGING FOR INDIVIDUALS
AUTISM AND OTHER DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES. AS YOU'RE MAKING
DECISIONS REGARDING FUNDING WE
ASK HAT YOU NOT FORGET THE
SPECIAL EDUCATION STUDENTS.
SOME OF WHICH MAY THE
COMPENSATORY SERVICE THAT WE
ASK THAT A FULL RANGE OF
INDIVIDUAL LIFE SERVICES BE
PROVIDED TO THOSE STUDENTS
INCLUDING OCCUPATIONAL THERAPY
SPEECH THERAPY AND BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH THERAPY THAT WERE
INCLUDED IN OUR INDIVIDUALIZED
EDUCATION PLAN- WE ALSO WANT TO
ADDRESS ANY POST SECONDARY
TRANSITION SERVICES THAT MAY
HAVE BEEN LOST. AND ALLOW MODE
OF STUDENTS WHO NEED
ADDITIONAL- ADDITIONAL TIME FOR
ELIGIBILITY ON THOSE SERVICES
AT THAT TIME BE EXTENDED THANK
YOU. THANK YOU AND THAT WE HAVE
COMMENT FROM JOHN JOHN WARNER
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
JOHN WARNER THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR COMMITTEE FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK I'M
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR SUPPORTERS
ADULT EDUCATION CONSORTIUM
WHICH REPRESENTS TEN THOUSAND
K. TWELVE ADULT EDUCATION
STUDENTS. ONE COLLAGEN TEN
SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN THE
CLEARING KINGS COUNTY REGION
LOCATED IN THE HEART OF THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY REGION DESCRIBES
THE APPELLATION OF THE WEST.
I'M ALSO THE STATE PRESIDENT OF
THAT CALIFORNIA DON'T EDUCATION
ADMINISTRATORS ASSOCIATION ON
THE PRESIDENT THE CALIFORNIA
COUNCIL FOR ADULT EDUCATION
CENTRAL SECTION. A REGION HAT
STRETCHES FROM JUST SOUTH OF
STOPPING TO THE GREAT MIND AND
FROM THE COASTAL RANGE IN THE
NEVADA BORDER. I AM A VOICE
FROM THE FIELD I'M ON THE
GROUND MITIGATING THE IMPACTS
TO KOBE NINETEEN ON BEHALF OF
OUR GARBAGE ASIAN STUDENTS IN
IMPLEMENTING. THE DECISION YOU
MAKE IN SACRAMENTO. SOUGHT SO I
CAN HE THE SOCIAL DISBURSING
GUIDANCE I'M CALLING YOU FROM
AN AD HOC REGIONAL CONSORTIUM.
OFFICE IN A TRAVEL TRAILER IN
CALIFORNIA. ADULT EDUCATION IS
ON THE FRONTLINE OF ECONOMIC
RECOVERY INVESTING IN ADULT
EDUCATION ON THE PRECIPICE OF
AN ECONOMIC RECOVERY IS LIKE
INVESTING IN AN ICY YOU ON THE
PRESS TODAY THANK YOU. OF A
GLOBAL PANDEMIC THANK YOU. NEXT
WEEK HERE WE GO NEXT IN THE
LINE OF CARE KAREN LOOP PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI YES MY NAME IS
KAREN MY WHEN I READ THAT I CAN
CALL CALIFORNIA AND THE
PRINCIPAL WITH A LITTLE
EDUCATION IN THE CITY OF
PORTLAND. OFTENTIMES THEY DON'T
LIKE A KITCHEN GEN ARE THE MOST
MARGINALIZED AMONG US. THE
MAJORITY OF CHAIRED BY MY
SCHOOL AND I DON'T SCHOOLS
ACROSS THE STATE HAVE LIMITED.
ENGLISH TROUT. WHEN AND THEY
ARE NOT. OUT OF AND MOST
EXPERTS THAT THEY WERE NOT SIX.
IN REGULAR KATE PRO. CATION FOR
MANY AT THE FOR HOT EDUCATE
EXPERIENCE THANK. I DON'T
PROVIDE TO AND SUPPORT TO HELP
STUDENTS NAVIGATE HI IF YOU.
THE WORK AND STEP NEEDS OF
CHILDREN AND THEIR FAMILIES I
DON'T GO FASHION. NO MATTER
WHERE THEY ARE IMAGINE. TURN WE
TRULY OFFER AND I EDUCATION
PLAN YOU. IN ORDER TO BEST MEET
THE NEEDS I INTERPRET FUNDING
FOR EDUCATION I DON'T EDUCATION
CAN AND WILL HELP YOUR
CONSTITUENTS REBUILD THEIR
LIVES AND WEEK NIGHT THIRTY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. AND A
COMMENT FROM JODY LEFFLER GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS JODY
LEFFLER AND I'M FROM BAKER SO
CALIFORNIA I'M A SUPERVISING
ADMINISTRATOR FOR BAKERSFIELD
ADULT SCHOOL I REPRESENT FEES
C. H. E. AS WELL AS THE EIGHT
EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT HI YEAR. AND
I JUST WANT TO URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT A DOLL THAT WE- SUPPORT
THE MOST MARGINALIZED STUDENTS
AND HELP CONSTITUENTS YOUR
CONSTITUENTS BY PROVIDING
PROGRAMS AND SERVICES TO HELP
YOUR CONSTITUENTS OUR STUDENTS
REBUILD THEIR LIVES WERE
CRITICAL TO THIS ECONOMIC
RECOVERY. THAT'S PART OF THIS
HANDOUT THANK PLEASE SUPPORTED
OLD EDUCATION WE CAN DO THE
WORK WERE ON THE GROUND NOW
DOING IT THANK YOU. AND WE HAVE
COMMENT FROM ADRIANA SANCHEZ
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS ADRIANA SIGNED JUST-
GONNA EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
CHEESY EIGHTY WHICH REPRESENTS
APPROXIMATELY THREE THOUSAND
TEACHERS CLASSIFIED STAFF
STUDENTS AND ADMINISTRATORS WHO
LEARN TEACH AND WORK WITH THE
ADULT POPULATION IN CALIFORNIA.
AND YOU CONTEMPLATE HOW TO
CREATE A REALISTIC STATE BUDGET
IN THE ERA OF KOBE NINETEEN
PLEASE MAINTAIN AND PROTECT THE
FUNDING FOR K. TWELVE ADULT
EDUCATION AND SOCIAL MODEL THEY
DON'T THAT. WE SUPPORT THE MOST
MARK MARGINALIZED AMONG ADULT
EDUCATION WILL HELP PROVIDE
ACCESS TO PROGRAMS AND SERVICES
THAT WILL HELP YOUR
CONSTITUENTS REBUILD THEIR
LIVES AND TO QUIT THEIR
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES. K.
TWELVE ADULT EDUCATION HAS
CONSISTENTLY STEPPED UP TO
SUPPORT THE NEEDS OF
CALIFORNIANS BEHIND ME AND THE
DOG COME TO WHAT IN DIFFICULT
TIMES SUCH AS RECESSION AND JOB
LOCK IT. PLEASE ALLOW US TO
CONTINUE THAT SUPPORT AND TO BE
A PART OF THE SOLUTION IN THESE
UNPRECEDENTED COUNTY. THANK YOU.
AND WE HAVE CHRISTIAN PERSON
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
CHRIS IMPROVE I IN OKAY. AND I
MINUTES SCHOOL I WENT CONTRA
COSTA EDUCATION IN THE RICHMOND
AREA PLEASE MAINTAIN K. TWELVE
ADULTS WILL SPENDING AT ITS
CURRENT LEVEL LIKE K. TWELVE
TEACHERS WE ARE CONTINUING HE
STARTED OLD STUDENT ONLINE. WE
HAVE HEARD A LOT ABOUT THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE DATE THAT WE
HAVEN'T HEARD MUCH ABOUT
ANOTHER POP RECORD ALREADY IN
THE DISTANCE LEARNING SITUATION
THOSE ARE THE VARYING SKILL
SETS OF THE DOLLS- PARENTS WHO
ARE LEARNING ENGLISH OR DON'T
HAVE MUCH OF THE BACKGROUND
ANYTHING TECHNOLOGY THEMSELVES
I DON'T HAVE A HIGH SCHOOL
DIPLOMA. SAVE MORE BEARD IN
HELPING OUR CHILDREN THE
DISTANCE LEARNING ENVIRONMENT
AND PARENTS BECAUSE THE THREE
K. TWELVE THE LOCALS ARE THE
RESOURCE THAT HELPS THOSE
PARENTS. THE PEOPLE. WE NEED
FUNDING HELPING SOME THE MOST
VULNERABLE. WHAT THEIR JOB
THINK. THANK YOU TO SHARE
COLLECTION GO AHEAD SHARON.
HELLO THIS SHERIN GLACE FROM
BAKERS ADULT SCHOOL I'M IN
MINISTRY AND THE PAST TEACHER I
UNDERSTAND THAT OUR PARENTS WHO
ARE STUDENTS ARE STRUGGLING
TEACHING KIDS AT HOME WE NEED
TO KEEP ADULT SCHOOL FUNDED AND
RUNNING ESPECIALLY IF THIS
CONTINUES. WE NEED OUR ADULT AT
HOME TO BE ABLE TO HELP THEIR
CHILDREN KEEP OUR ADULT FUNDING
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND THE
NEXT TO EDGAR OF HIS WEIGHT AT
EDGAR PLEASE GO AHEAD. A GOOD
AFTERNOON THAT YOURSELF BUT- ON
BEHALF OF THIS LOCATION
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATOR- AND YOU HEARD
FROM DOCTOR CAMP AND THE OTHER
EDUCATORS ON THE PANEL WE SHARE
THE CONCERN ABOUT LEARNING LOS
OUR STUDENTS- DID NOT EVEN TO
MENTION THE THAT SOCIAL MOTION
A LOT THAT WE CAN SPEAK OF MUCH
ABOUT BUT- MIGHT BE DEFECTIVE
YEAR PER STUDENT WE DO
APPRECIATE THAT THE LEGISLATURE
THINKING ABOUT WAYS. TO
MITIGATE THAT AND I THINK THE
TEARS POINT AND THAT THE MORE
TIME WE HAVE THE BETTER WE CAN
PLAN I MEAN THERE'S SO MANY
VARIABLES JUST AGAIN BUT HERE
IN TERMS THE UNCERTAINTY SO IN
ALL PROPERLY PLAN FOR WHAT THEY
HAD THE SOONER DECISION CAN BE
MADE- THE BETTER- JUST EIGHT IN
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT OUR
SCHOOLS WERE ASKED TO DO A LOT.
OF. IT BY DISTANCE LEARNING. BY
ALL ACCOUNTS SET UP BUT CHAO I
KNOW COME COP ON THE PATH
SIMILAR MEMBERS WHY WE'RE NOT
BETTER PUT FOR GIVEN THE WE AND
WE SEE THAT THE REALITY ONE
THAT WE'RE CA ABOUT BUT THE
THINK WE CONTINUED BE DON TO
MEET THAT NEXT COUNTY TALKING
ABOUT WHAT'S GOOD MAY LOOK LIKE
IN THE FALL WITH THE PHYSICAL
DID FIFTEEN WITH GOD DON'T AND
WHEN WE TALK MEMBERS ABOUT
THIS. IT REALLY THE HEART WAS
GONNA DO THAT WITHOUT THE
RESOURCES BECAUSE I THINK IT IT
IT WE UNDERSTAND THAT THE
DIFFICULT CHALLENGES FOR THE
LEGISLATURE- BUT WE LOOK FOR TO
BEING A RESOURCE AS TE YEAR
YEAH YOU MAKE. THOSE POLICY
DECISIONS IMPORT. THANK YOU.
COMMENT SO THANK YOU COMMENT
FROM KITTY ALAN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
IT COULD BE SURE WE HAVE THE
LINE OPEN YOU CAN IN PERHAPS
YOU MA'AM YOU DID YOUR LINE.
HELLO HI. CALIFORNIA I THANK A
FEW MORE IN A HURRY. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR NUMBERS FOR
CONDUCTING THIS CRUCIAL HEARING
TO ADDRESS OUR STUDENTS NEED-
COULDN'T AGREE MORE WITH
ASSEMBLYMEMBER TAME ON THE NEED
TO DEVELOP STATE RIGHT
GUIDANCE- IDENTIFIED CALIFORNIA
ACTUALLY BELIEVED- OVERCOMING A
DISTANCE ANY POLICY BRIEF THAT
OUTLINES THE IMMENSE CHALLENGES
OF DISTANCE LEARNING FOR
CALIFORNIA LOW INCOME FAMILIES
OF COLORED PROVIDES. SIX KEY
POLLUTION OUR STATE LEADERS
ESPECIALLY- CALIFORNIA COUNTY
VEGETATION CAN TAKE TO ADDRESS
THESE ARE OLD NUMBER ONE
CONDUCT NEED TO SET AN ALLOCATE
RESOURCES BASED ON NEED. BURKE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE CONDUCTING
THE SETTLEMENT OF THE DISTRICT
LEVEL BUT IT SHOULD BE DONE ON
THE LEVEL. TO EIGHT. DISTANCE
LEARNING BEST PRACTICE THROUGH
IN A BY LIQUOR MODEL NEEDS
COMMITTEE AND THE MODEL AFTER
LACKS. NUMBER THREE PROVIDE
PROFESSIONAL LEARNING SUPPORT
THE TEACHER STAFF WAITED TO
THIS LEARNING THE STATE PUT
GUIDE TO COOL DISTRICT ON MANY
SUPPORTING GUIDE TO OFF TEACHER
SUCH AS YOU THAT THE MENTAL AND
COUNSELORS. FOR LIKE YEAH AS
AROUND THAT HI ALL. JOHN
FITZPATRICK GO AHEAD PLEASE
HELLO THIS IS JOSH I LIKE FROM
THE LOS ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN REFER FRIEDMAN
OCCUPATIONAL CENTER IN THE
TEACHER AND THE ESL DEPARTMENT
CHAIR WE ARE ASKING THE
ASSEMBLY TO PROTECT FUNDING FOR
ADULT EDUCATION AT A TIME WHEN
THE MOST MARGINALIZED AMONG US
ARE SUFFERING MORE THAN MOST
ADULT EDUCATION PROVIDES A
LIFELINE TO THE STUDENT TO
LITERALLY IT'S ABOUT SURVIVAL.
AS WE KNOW THERE'S A LEVEL OF
UNEMPLOYMENT IN CALIFORNIA
DON'T EDUCATION AND THIS WILL
HELP THE UNEMPLOYED REACH AND
FIGHT THE WAY BACK INTO THE
WORK FORCE ALSO ADULT ED
PROVIDE PARENTS TRY TO CHILDREN
TO SCHOOL THAT EDUCATION IS
TRANSFORMING BEFORE I IS IT TOO
VITAL THAT WE THE PARENTS WELL
AS THE CHILDREN. ADULT
EDUCATION WILL HELP PROVIDE
ACCESS TO PROGRAMS AND SERVICES
THAT WILL HELP YOUR
CONSTITUENTS REBUILD A LOT NEED
LATER LIKE YOU FUNDING OKAY DO
YOU IN CALIFORNIA RIGHT YOUR
TIME. THANK CARLOS WHERE. YEAH
THE CARD MARKET ON BEHALF OF
THE CAL CHARTER SCHOOL
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING OVER
THIRTEEN HUNDRED CHARTER SCHOOL
THAN SIX HUNDRED THOUSAND
PUBLIC SCHOOL FAMILY- WE
APPRECIATE THAT COMMENT- FROM
DEATH AND ACCOUNTABILITY- AND
ABSOLUTELY WANT TO OFFER AND
THAT THE ASIAN UP AT THE REPORT
ON- READY YET FOR MODEL AND
ALTERNATIVE OPTION- FOR BOTH
CHARTERS AND TRADITIONAL PUBLIC
SCHOOLS DURING THE CHALLENGE
TIME WE DO. NOT THAT. THINK
ABOUT. WHAT BRING BACK YOU
PHYSICAL FAITH IS. HE IN THERE
ARE NOT CUTTING CRITICAL
FACILITY LIKE THAT CHARTER
SCHOOL FACILITY GRANT PROGRAM
WHICH PROVIDE MEET
REIMBURSEMENT FOR AT SCHOOL
BETTER SURVEY THING- HI
PROPERTY STUDENT OUT IN FACT WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
PRESERVE OUR FACILITY OPTION SO
THAT WE CAN ENGAGE IN
IMPRACTICAL- SOCIAL BIT THING
AND- ASIAN WITHIN THE-
UNDERSTANDING THAT. BY THAT
WILL NOT THEY ARE WE ALSO
PROVIDE THAT IF THE PEARL. THAT
SCHOOL AT B. GIVEN AT AT THE OP
TO GET ACCESS TO LOCAL LOAN%
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
AND AGAIN AND WE ARE JUST JUST
A NOTE JUST A NOTE REAL QUICK
WE HAD. ABOUT TWENTY MINUTES
AGO WE HAD SEVENTEEN SPEAKERS
NOW TWENTY MINUTES LATER WE
HAVE SEVENTEEN SPEAKER SO.
MULTI I WOULD STE OKAY IS THAT
IS THE PUBLIC HEARING
UNDERSTAND THAT BUT PLEASE TRY
TO YOUR COMMENTS TO ONE MINUTE
OR- OR LESS THANK YOU. AND
CROSS BE GO AHEAD. BRENDA RUIZ
pPRINTER REVIEWS FROM SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA WITH THE SACRAMENTO
FOOD POLICY COUNCIL SOME
COMMENTS FROM THE FIELD-
CONCERNING THE DIRECT
CERTIFICATION AND THE EXTRACT
OUT CALTRANS. FOR EXAMPLE THE
JUNE EXTRACT HELP CUTS WILL
PROVIDE MARCH DATA. AND SO
THERE IS ABOUT A THREE MONTH
LAG AND SO WE ENCOURAGE ON THIS
COMMITTEE AND THE EDUCATION.
EDUCATION COMMITTEES TO SIGNAL
COMMUNICATE TO SEE- TO THE PART
OF SOCIAL SERVICE IS THAT THEY
DO THEIR PRODUCTS TO- MITIGATE
THE THREE BLACK OR TO THEIR-
CURRENT DATA AVAILABLE TO THE
DISTRICTS TO BE ABLE. TO PULL
DOWN- DIRECT PATIENT OUT OF NOT
ONLY FOR PROVIDING FREE AND
REDUCED NIELSEN TO THEIR
STUDENTS BUT ALSO BECAUSE WE
KNOW THAT DOC BUT- INCREASED
FUNDING FOR SCHOOL DISTRICT IN
BOB. WILL MENTAL CONCENTRATION
ERROR OF MORE FAMILIES WILL NOW
BE SIGNING UP FOR MEDICARE ALL
THE OTHER CALIFORNIA MOMENT
WINDOW AND AT OR ACCESSING TOWN
FUNDS LET ME INCREASE- DISTRICT
THE. LADY IS TO ACT. ONE THIRD.
TITLE TO THANK YOU THANK YOU
YOU BRENDA. THANK YOU WILL GO
TO FOR PENEDO PLEASE GO AHEAD
WITH YOUR COMMENT. HELLO I'M
CONCORD COPING NEAR THE LEAD
INSTRUCTOR PERSONAL LOOK AT
ADULT ALL PART OF THE FOR YOU
TO VALUE DAHLE EDUCATION
CONSORTIUM AND A PROUD PC AND
CARRY A MEMBER ALL WE ASK
PEOPLE PROTECTION LIKE WE COULD
NOT BE HEARD OF CAR UNTIL IT
FUN. SPECIALLY TO KEEP COLA AND
TO KEEP OUR ADULT APRONS
RESTRICTED AND NOT. ALL OF THE
LOCAL STUDENTS TO HAVE IT IS
LOCATED. AT ARE ANTICIPATING
THE MARKETS. WERE TO COME OUT
TO A- WHEN WE OPEN UP IN FALL.
OUR STUDENTS EUROPE COLORADO
GETTING. LOW WITHIN OUR OWN
DISTRICT SALINAS VALLEY STATE
PRISON LOCAL MEDICAL CLINICS
AND ALSOHOSPITAL. AND
BUSINESSES IN THE COMMUNITY WE
ASK YOU PLEASE PROTECT BILL IT.
TO A REAL THIRTY TOO. FAR RIGHT
NOW. UP IN THE FALL. OF THE
CALLS. WE ARE WE'RE IN
AGRICULTURE AND EVERYTHING THE
POLICE US CONSIDER. AND NOT CUT
OUR- AN ALLOCATE COLA AND
FUNDING FOR CP. THANK YOU THANK
YOU. AND WE'LL GO TO CHRISTIAN
ART A CHRISTIAN LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU MY NAME IS KRISTEN
OUR PRESIDENT SALINAS AND I'M
THE DIRECTOR OF THE CLEAN UP
VALLEY ADULT EDUCATION
CONSORTIUM WHICH INCLUDES
VI<c.cyan> .ORG OF SCIENCE K.</c>
TWELVE DISTRICTS IN THE PLANE
OF VALLEY. AFTER THAT. AND
HEART NO. ATHLETE YOU. HATE IT
UNDER. FOR BY LEAST MAINTAINING
LEVELS OF FUNDING AND KEEPING
THE FUNDS RSTRICTED TO ADULT
EDUCATION. AND IDEALLY BY
PROVIDING A MUCH NEEDED
COLORFULLY MAY CONTINUE WITHOUT
REDUCING SERVICES. ARE PROGRAMS
PROVIDE BASIC SKILLS
INSTRUCTION AND TECHNICAL
TRAINING TO HELP ADULTS ENTER
IN ADVANCE IN THE WORK FORCE.
THANK THE SECTORS HEALTHCARE I
RECALL AND FOOD SAFETY AND
TRANSPORTATION LOGISTICS
PREPARING A DOG TO REENTER THE
WORKFORCE WILL BE MORE
IMPORTANT THAN EVER IN THE
CURRENT ECONOMIC CRISIS. WE
ALSO PROVIDE PARENTS WITH
KNOWLEDGE AND SKILLS NEEDED TO
HELP THEIR CHILDREN SUCCEED IN
SCHOOL THIS NOW INCLUDE HELPING
PARENTS LEARN HOW TO HOLD THEIR
CHILDREN DURING THE- CRISIS. WE
HAVE BEEN QUICK TO RESPOND. BY
PROVIDING INTERNET VIA THE THAT
THE IN ACCESS TECH. AND
CONNECTION TO SOCIAL SERVICES
AND OTHER RESOURCES THEY NEED.
MEET THEIR THANK YOU NEED. HE
THANK YOU OUR NEXT WE HAVE
PUBLIC COMMENT FROM IN RE KATE
REWATCH OLD PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON THAT THE CHAIR
LOOKING SYNDICATE ROGER
REPRESENTING THE TANK VEHICLES
GOING UP BY SCHOOL DISTRICT-
FIRST OFF THANK YOU FOR HOLDING
THIS HEARING TODAY WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH YOU TO
OVERCOME THE CHALLENGES THAT
STUDENTS. AND SCHOOLS WILL
CONTINUE TO CHANGE I CAN BE
ABLE UNIFIED WE HAVE NOW
STARTED GREAT IN ONLINE
DISTANCE LEARNING. AND
PREPARATION FOR THE NEXT PHASE
WE HAVE DISTRIBUTED OVER FIFTY
THOUSAND LAPTOP CONDUCTED OVER
THIRTEEN. OUT WORDS OF
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT AND
HAVE ERVED OVER TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND ME ALL. WE BELIEVE
THIS SCHOOL YEAR PATTERSON
WE'RE DOING EVERYTHING WE CAN
TO PROTECT THE LEARNING BAR.
BUT WE ALSO KNOW THAT NINETEEN
EXEMPLIFYING THE NEXT THAT
ALREADY EXISTED AND SO QUICKER
WITH THE COMMENT MY COLLEAGUE
GOT ACTUALLY. THAT THE MORE WE
CAN. THE BACK WE CAN ON THE
GROUND IN A YOU CAN GET OUR
GRAND WOULD POINT TOWARDS TITLE
ONE IS YOUR- BIOLOGY. AND WE'RE
ALSO AGREE WITH PARKS. AT THE
PAR THAT I LEAVE YOU WITH ONE.
REFERENCE MOTION A BUT AND I IT
THAT. BUDGET PART FIGMENTS OF.
AND WILL WE OFFER. EQUITY
IMPORTANT. TO PROTECT AGAINST
LEARNING LOG IN TO ENSURE THAT
THE CAT. ABOUT YOUR PAST THANK
YOU. AND WE HAVE COMMENT FROM
CRISTINA HILDEBRAND PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I COULD YOU KNOW HOW THE
BRAND THE VOICE BETRAYED ATTIC
HE I ONE ASPECT OF THE LEARNING
LAW ISSUE THAT HAS NOT BEEN
ADDRESSED IS THE MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES THAT WHILE KIDS OF BEING
STUCK AT HOME TEACHERS THE
BEING BACK AT HIM- THERE HAS
BEEN. NO NET INCREASE TRAUMA-
AND WHETHER THAT AT HOME AND
WHAT THEY COULD BE IN
EXPERIENCING AT HOME OR WHETHER
IT WHEN THEY COME BACK TO A
CLASSROOM THAT IT LOOK AND FEEL
COMPLETELY DIFFERENT FROM WHAT
THEY WERE USED TO WHETHER IT
WEARING MOCK SPECIAL THAT.
THERE WILL NOT HI. ALL IN AND
WHICH ALL OF THOSE THINGS. ARE
A BE. DEADLINE IN BY BY I WHEN
YOU. LOOK AT THIS NAY KNOW BUT
THERE I CAN. BY THE- HEALTH
NEEDS OF THAT IS THE IMPORTANT
ONE LOOK AT. THE NUMBER AND
BRING THE IT BACK SCHOOL AND
WHAT HAPPENED AND THANK YOU.
TWO SHE TOWN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI AMY IS JAN FROM AND I'M A
SPECIAL EDUCATION AND MAKE AND
I'M CALL TO GET. DEVELOP IN
EDUCATIONAL REGRET OUR STUDENTS
WITH DISABILITIES ARE NINETY
PIZZA FIVE OH FOURTH IN
CALIFORNIA THE MAJORITY OF HIM
WHO HAD THEIR SERVICES ABRUPTLY
DELAYED DURING THE COLD AT
NINETEEN CLOSURE OF SCHOOLS AND
CONTINUE TO HAVE A LACK OF
SERVICES OR HAVE HAD THEIR
SERVICES OUTRIGHT CANCELED BY
ITSELF BUT CROSS THE STATE
INCLUDING EL DORADO CHARTER
PAPA. THIRD PARTY. ARE WE IN IT
IN WE WILL BE LOOKING AT A X.
CONTENT. THANK YOU COSTS AT
PARENT THEIR FOURTH TO BECOME
THEIR SHE THERE. PROVIDE NO
BURKE OR IN PERSON INSTRUCTION
THE COST OF RE EDUCATING THE
DEVELOPMENTAL AFFECT AN
ACADEMIC OUT FOR THE STUDENTS
EXPONENTIAL AND I URGE THE-
COMMITTEE TO CONSIDER. FULLY
FUNDING SPECIAL EDUCATION I
ALSO WANT TO POINT OUT THAT
EIGHTY FIVE HAD CUT THE PROBLEM
FOR MANY AYE THE THERAPIST. AT
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTOR MULTIPLE
DISTRICT THE PACKAGE FIRE THEM
DURING THAT TIME BECAUSE THERE
ARE. ONLY HIRE THEM ON. IS THAT
YOU THEIR SPECIAL EDUCATION
TEACHER THANK YOU THANK YOU.
AND WE HAVE COMMON FROM THE
LINE OF CHINESE THE PRESS
SEARCH THE LINE IS OPEN. THE
CAMERA MEMBERS JUDGE THE
PRODUCT THAT WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION- THANK YOU FOR ALL
THE QUESTIONS AROUND PPP ONE OF
THE NUMBER ONE PRIORITY FOR US
TO GET THAT SAFETY GEAR TO A
MEMBER OF. I STRIVE AND OTHERS
WHO ARE ALREADY ON THE
FRONTLINE I WOULD WOULD WANT TO
WORK WITH YOU TO TRY TO
MAXIMIZE THE DOLLARS BECAUSE
ALL MEMBERS THE CLOCK BIKE UP
TO HELP RUN THE SCHOOLS ONLY
GET IT SIXTY DAYS NOTICE- FOR
THEIR DELAY OP IT DOES NOT
CONTEMPLATE ACOSTA FALL.AND WE
WOULD HAVE TO WORK WITH YOU TO
MAXIMIZE THE DOLLARS TO OF LIKE
ANY NAY OFF POSSIBLE IN THIS
ENVIRONMENT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. TIME THANK YOU. OKAY ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. HOW WE WILL GO
NEXT TO THE LINE OF MARTHA
ALVAREZ THE LINE IS OPEN.
MARTHA ALBERS LOS ANGELES
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN FOR
CONVENING TODAY'S HEARING.
MARCH EIGHTEENTH LOS ANGELES
UNIFIED HAS PROVIDED OVER
THIRTEEN POINT SIX MILLION MAIL
TO BOTH CHILDREN AND ADULTS
THAT'S THE LARGEST RELIEF
EFFORT IN THE COUNTRY. WE HAVE
ALSO BEEN BRIDGING THE DIGITAL
DIVIDE BY PROVIDING DEVICES AND
CONNECTIVITY TO STUDENTS AT
HOME. OVER 85% OF OUR TEACHERS
HAVE COMPLETED TEN HOURS OF
TRAINING ON DISTANCE LEARNING
AND OVER 50% OF OUR TEACHERS
HAVE SIGNED UP FOR AN
ADDITIONAL THIRTY HOURS WELL
THE PLAN FOR SUMMER SCHOOL. ALL
OF THIS EFFORT WILL COME WITH
THE CAR. I WE HAVE ESTIMATED TO
BE ABLE THREE AND NINETY
DOLLARS. AS PART OF THE FINAL
BUDGET ADOPTION WE ASK THE
LEGISLATURE TO LEVERAGE STATE
AND FEDERAL FUNDS. TO ALLOCATE
TO ALFIE OFFENSE. AND ALSO
PROVIDE DISCRETIONARY DOLLARS
TO HELP SCHOOL DISTRICT OFF
THAT THE COMPANY NINETEEN COST.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR DOING. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU AND I WILL TURN
IT BACK TO OUR SPEAKERS AT THIS
TIME THANK YOU. OKAY THANK YOU
AT THAT WE HAD A FEW MORE THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
PARTICIPATION. AS ALWAYS IT IF
YOU WERE ABLE TO- BEEN. TO GET
IN THE QUEUE AND SHARE YOUR
THOUGHTS YOU CAN ALWAYS EMAIL
THE COMMITTEE. OR FIND OTHER
WAYS TO COMMUNICATE WITH US SO.
THANK YOU FOR THEIR
PARTICIPATION TO OUR PANELISTS
TO THE PUBLIC WITH THAT WE WILL
ADJOURN THIS HEARING AND
RECONVENE THE CHILD CARE IT IS
SUCH A WORKERS- SECTION AT
THREE O'CLOCK. THANK YOU.